Ja, ist aber komisch, ne? Nerds haben generell, glaub ich, so nicht so eine Affinität zu Fußball.
Ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Kannst du kurz erklären, was Fußball ist?
Nee, ich guck nur, wenn es wichtig ist.
Viertelfinale.
Ja, wenn's spannend wird. Wenn damals Klaus Alochs irgendwie danebentritt und auf dem Spielfeld heulen zusammenbricht, dann ist Sport ab und zu.
Ist nicht so dein Sport, oder?
Die Berichterstattung ist vorher so groß, dass es dann immer denk, alles klar, das kommt ja dann irgendwann und kommt ja dann irgendwann und plötzlich warst du dann schon da.
Ich war mal im Fußballverein.
Ich war mal im Handballverein.
DJK-Würmtal. Kurz bevor ich's wieder gelassen hab, haben wir ein Spiel bestritten, wo die andere Mannschaft in der Unterzahl war und wir haben es trotzdem 7 zu 0 verloren.
Aber ich war ja auch mal im Fußballverein.
Naja, auf jeden Fall werden wir keine aktuellen Instände durchgeben. Wir hatten das erwogen, aber leider mussten sich die Stadionbetreiber nicht dazu durchregen lassen, den aktuellen Stand der Freak Show gleichzeitig im Stadion durchzusagen. Und deswegen ist die Sache dann öfter gestorben.
Aber vielleicht hört jemand im Stadion jetzt geradezu vielleicht sogar in der Stadionsprecherkabine und dann noch was arrangieren.
Wir müssen mal wieder mehr über Max reden. Meinst du schon mal jemand aus der Bundesliga hat unsere Sendung gehört?
Du, ich bin nicht in Brasilien. Aus gutem Grund.
Nigeria, Argentinien, 2 zu 3.
So sieht's aus. Aktueller Stand. Was war deine Frage, Dennis?
Ob jemand aus der Bundesliga schon mal unsere Sendung gehört hat?
Welche Position aus der Bundesliga, in der Bundesliga?
Ist egal.
Ein Spielermeister?
Womit denn, denn sind gerade die Kopfhörer weggenommen worden.
Ja, so ein zweiter Sieg als Spieler soll sich mal melden. Ich würde beweisen können, wir haben nicht nur Nerds, sondern auch Leute, die aktiv Sport machen. Wir fangen mal mit Fußball an, nicht, dass die andere jetzt beleidigt fühlen.
Freak für vier, oder nee, wir für Freak. Wie war dieses Internet-Meme von den ganzen Prominenten, die ihre vier Finger für den vierten WM-Titel in die Kamera gehalten haben, um ein Meme zu starten, was so lame ist, wie vier Finger in der Kamera? Vier für vier, ja. Diese Pose, wo irgendwelche Prominenten das in die Kamera halten, das ist für den vierten WM-Titel. Und wir machen jetzt Vier für Freak, also die prominenten Fußballspieler, die halten jetzt irgendwie ein F mit ihrer Hand irgendwie in die Kamera und machen ein Selfie und dann...
Die Handbewegung musst du nochmal erläutern, wie man so ein F macht.
Vier für Freak.
Also ich bin für Bier um vier.
Ja, hier ist eher Krach um acht.
Das ist eher Nachacht, aber Krach um acht.
Krach um acht.
Acht nach acht.
Ja, rupiger Start heute, aber wir mussten noch ein Spiel gucken.
In den näheren Stunden, die wir inzwischen hier sind, hatten wir auch keinerlei Zeit vor allem mal zu testen, ob das Mikrofon richtig sitzt.
Der hört uns im Chat noch keiner, oder?
Doch, im Chat schlug einer schon Freak Ultras vor.
Ich hoffe es schon wieder irgendwann.
Das sind die Hartesten.
Die Freak-Freaks.
Genau, dann müssten sie aber auch mal anfangen, am Anfang eine Choreo zu machen.
Welle durchs Podcast-Stadium.
Choreo ist, wenn im Stadion so die Fan-Kurve, also ob man die dann Ultras oder Hardcore-Fans nennt oder so, aber sagen wir mal so die regelmäßigen Gäste. Die haben ja auch immer so ein eigenes Segment, wo dann so Antreiber sind. Und am Anfang wird dann auch Choreo gemacht. Da wird dann mehr oder weniger aufwendig was veranstaltet, was weiß ich, großes Banner aufgezogen, wo irgendwie ein schickes Motiv drauf ist.
Wo dann die Ordner kommen und gleich wieder einsacken.
Genau.
Wir wollen die Freak Show hören. Ich bin so beschwert da, trinken schicken. Wir wollen die Freak Show hören.
Aber nur mit den richtigen Kopfhörern.
Eine Stunde geht noch, eine geht noch rein.
Ja, da bewegt sich schon was in den Rängen. Was die Engländer mal machen. Die klatschen alle. Die klatschen alle.
Alle klatschen.
Klar, alle klatschen.
Unsere Fans sowieso hier.
Alle haben eine an der Klatsche.
Guck, jetzt kommt schon die erste Laola Aski-Welle im Chat. Siehst du mal, es gibt nicht mehr Kreativität als in der Podcast.
Und schatzt sie sich einmal rum, die Fans von Bits und so, ob die da bei der Bälle mitmachen.
Falsch Spieler, rennt durch die Sendung.
Ja, Cheerleader. Gute Frage, wo sind die Cheerleader?
Ja, das Bits und so-Team ist leider nicht aufgelaufen, also wir sind ganz alleine hier auf dem Platz.
Das Spiel wird als 10 zu 0 gewertet. Und überhaupt und sowieso.
Mal gespannt, wie lange wir hier die Fußball-Meme noch auf den Platz gejagt bekommen.
Rennt auch gleich der erste Flitzer hier wahrscheinlich.
Das ist natürlich die finale Adelung.
Ich staune sowieso, dass in all den Jahren wirklich noch keiner, also ich will jetzt auch niemand ermutigen natürlich, aber ich meine...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, jetzt kommen wir in dein Annen.
Das wollen wir gar nicht zu Ende denken.
Du bringst die Jugend nur auf falsche Bedeutung.
Ich spreche es ja nicht aus.
Ich dachte, das gab es schon.
Du hast schon genug gesagt.
Aber mich wundert halt.
Ja, wundert du dich mal.
Ich dachte, das gab es schon.
Jetzt ein anderes Thema.
Also als Flitzer nicht mehr als Flitzer.
Also ich verkündige jetzt erstmal, dass die Mannschaft des ersten FC Freak Show vollständig angetreten ist. Wir haben auch Roddy wieder an Bord nach einer längeren Verletzungspause.
Ne, wir haben ihn als Auslang verliehen.
Kurz in der italienischen Liga gespielt.
Genau, aber das war nicht so von Erfolg gekrönt.
Wie man sieht, sind doch gleich raus, ne?
Doch, der sieht guter Holt aus.
Italien ist ausgeschieden. Roddy wieder am Start.
Mission gelungen.
Ja, auch wieder für die Startelf nominiert. Ja, Hucke, einfach in guter Form. Du machst auch auf mich den Eindruck, als ob du die vollen 4 Stunden durchhalten könntest.
Ich hab lang trainiert.
Wir spielen auch volle Länge.
Die Laktat-Teste sahen gut aus.
Du hast auch überhaupt keine andere Wahl, weil die Bank ist sehr schwach besetzt. Also, auswechselnd ist nicht. Man muss jetzt auch schon wirklich die volle Strecke gehen.
Nur nasser Handtücher auf der Bank.
Nur nasser Handtücher. Ja. Immer gesetzt, Dennis. Dich kriegt auch keiner weg. Die Verteidigung.
Der Charles Puyol der Freak Show.
Ja, also Libero und Viererkette in einem.
Du könntest mal deine Webseite verteidigen. Die Freak Show FM-Webseite.
FM wie Fußballmeisterschaft?
Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Was soll ich machen?
Das geht, mach das geht.
Haben sie dich geohnt?
No excuses.
Erst hat er mich hier angefleht. Ich soll mich jetzt endlich mal um die Sendung kümmern. Jetzt läuft die Sendung und jetzt wollte er, dass ich hier Webseitenadministrationen betreibe.
Ich will nicht, dass du die Webseite administrierst.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich machen soll.
Clemens, unser Joker.
Geht mich deine Webseite an.
Du hast diesmal früher eingewechselt, weil die Bank so schlecht ist.
Gleich ran, vorne im Strafraum der Gegner.
Wo das Ding liegt.
Ich bin hier für die Zusammensetzung der Mannschaft zuständig. Ich doch wohl.
Wo ist der Team-Masseur? Einfach rennen, nicht liegen bleiben.
Es.
Gut, dass wir noch keine Gegner haben. Aber es formiert sich ja schon was hier. Heute ist ja wirklich ein Live-Event. Jagt den anderen, eben noch Argentinien gegen Nigeria. Wo ging es ja auch hin und her. Und Google ist auch alleine in den Krieg gezogen hier. Die Google IO. Keynote. Ich weiß nicht, läuft sie noch? Sie lief jetzt auf jeden Fall. Doch, die Reden, die machen ja auch so ewig lang. Die sind ja schon seit zweieinhalb Stunden dabei. Das würde es ja bei Apple nicht geben.
Das gibt es auch im Livestream. Reicht mal auf den Schirm, man. Kommt mal so eine Minute.
Ja, das ist besser als der Chat.
Besser als Fußball.
Mal gucken, was ist jetzt hier.
Nee, aber man muss ja, wir wollen ja auch mal auf den Tellerrand schauen, äh, über.
Den Tellerrand? Welchen Tellerrand? Welchen Tellerrand? Äh, ich weiß nicht, wo sind denn hier meine, ach, da.
Google-Kino, bist du, bist du besoffen, Dennis, oder was?
Man muss rein gucken, kann jetzt nicht so schlimm sein. Okay, also rennt einer hin und her, dahinter ist eine Leinwand.
Keine Ahnung, aber der Chat ist sehr hilfreich irgendwie. Wenn man sich das anschaut, was da abgeht, ist halt YouTube, ne?
Geht echt voll ab.
Meinen Sie hier Amazon ans Bein pinken?
156.000 Nutzer sehen grad so.
Darf ich das wieder ausblenden irgendwie? Das ist ein bisschen so...
Muss man schon sagen, respektvoll. Also, da das ja alles noch alte Unicast-Scheiße ist, 155.000 Leute zu bespielen, ist schon mal okay.
Also Apple rückt ja keine Zahlen raus. Aber vor vielen Jahren haben sie schon gesagt, 50.000, also das ist schon ewig her. Also ich denke mal...
Nochmal, klar geht das. Wir sehen ja, dass das geht. Aber ich weiß tatsächlich, dass für ein paar Leute ganz schön...
Nur, dass wir das sehen. Mehr sehen wir hier nicht. Ansonsten glauben wir irgendwelchen Zahlen auf irgendwelche Webseiten.
Denn wir haben keinen Cloud-Monitor.
Besser als keinen Zahlen.
Ja, also irgendwas mit Android.
Irgendwas mit Cloud.
Hast du nicht vorhin gesagt, Android wird jetzt voll toll mit Schatten und was war das andere?
Sie haben jetzt hier irgendwie so komisches ein neues Design für ihr Android vorgestellt. Also die Version, die wahrscheinlich in 4 Jahren auf 35% aller Telefone installiert sein wird.
Da wirst du aber optimistisch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt. Sie nennen das L, Android L.
Welche Süßigkeit fällt dir bei L ein? Leckerli ist nicht süß.
Leberwurst. Kann ich aber mal kurz einstreuen, so Statistiken, die ich immer so mache, wenn ich mal irgendwelche Netzauswertungen mache, wie viele User sich da so rumtreiben, gerade so in Wireless-Lans oder so was, die Apple-Geräte kommen ins Hintertreffen. Also ich sehe jetzt bei den Wireless-Lans, so von öffentlichen Veranstaltungen, je jünger das Volk ist, sehe ich deutlich, deutlich mehr Androids als Apple-Geräte. Und was mich sehr, sehr ärgert, was heißt das deutlich? Also auch technisch relativ moderne Zeugs am Start. Also ich sehe zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal Geräte sehe, die wirklich 802.11ac benutzen, also Gigabit WLAN, die sind Zeugs, dann sehe ich, da habe ich gedacht, jetzt müssen hier massenhaft Apple-Geräte auftauchen, so Laptops oder nix. Android-Geräte sehe ich.
Jetzt sag noch, dass Deutschland verliert, komm.
Natürlich verliert Deutschland. Wenn du dein erstes Spiel mit so vielen Dingern machst und alle dich hochjubeln, das haben sie doch bisher mal gemacht, dazu dann den Rest verkacken, ist doch klar. Aber wir sehen davon. Also ich fühle mich da als Apple-Benutzer auch so ein bisschen beschämt, aber die Statistiken sind klar. Vor allen Dingen, weil ich sie selber gefälscht habe. Aber die, das könnt ihr dir auch gerne mal zeigen. Aber ihr seht, je jünger das Volk wird, also diese Nummer mit Apple ist cool oder so was ist jetzt vorbei. Die Leute rennen alle mit Android draußen rum. Das sehe ich auch so. Das ist cool jetzt oder was? Ja, das sind so alte Säcke wie wir, die auch schön gesetzt sind und nur Kohle haben oder wie auch immer woher Apple-Geräte noch haben oder weil sie dran hängen oder so was. Aber Wetter draußen an jungen voll krumm läuft, da ist Android cool.
Dann sind wir endlich wieder an der Dorf.
Wollte ich nur mal sagen, dass das auch mal...
Aber mit so einer Grundton...
Also, ich finde, früher war das anders. Entspann dich mal, Clemens.
Mach mal ein Lächeln auf die Lippen. Ja, nicht gleich.
Es gab so eine Zeit, wo wir uns diebescher darüber gefreut haben, wenn bei irgendwelchen Microsoft-Veranstaltungen die Leute alle saßen und ihre Apple-Laptops aufgeklappt haben. Das wird bestimmt im Laptop-Markt auch immer noch so sein. Aber dann haben wir uns hier gefreut, dass jetzt überall alles voll ist mit iPhones und iPads und Lara und Peeper-Pool. Das war auch schön. Aber jetzt ist es mir ein ganzes Teil egal. Jetzt hat der RCP-Sauer es immer voll mit Android gesockt. Das merkst du schon daran, dass die zu doof sind, ihr Telefon umzubenennen. Oder vielleicht geht das auch gar nicht, weil die heißen nämlich alle Android-Unterstriche und dann irgendeine Mac-Adresse. Wohingegen die iPhone-User immer so kreative Sachen benutzen wie Dirk's iPhone. Aber die normalen iPhones draußen melden sich bei RCP an, ich bin X, Y's iPhone. Das ist total kreativ. Gegenüber den Android-Usern, die ihr Telefon immer nur Android-Android-Hexzahl nennen.
Hexzahl?
Ja, vielleicht geht es ja nicht anders. Vielleicht kann man denen ja gar keine Namen geben. Aber die melden sich mit Android-Android-Hexzahl.
Da machen sie auch die MAC-Adresse hinten dran, hinter deinem Hostname.
Was sind die default Sharing-Namen? Von Android lernen heißt siegen lernen. Sie machen ja jetzt hier auch so ein neues Design. Material Design heißt das. Grund hat es mich, dass sie nicht gleich Madonna auf die Bühne geholt haben.
5 Euro.
Sieht jetzt hier in so einem Demovideo eigentlich ganz schick aus, finde ich. Also, wollt ihr das mal sehen hier? Genau, hier Material Design. Und das werdet ihr irgendwie kennen. Das ist nämlich irgendwie so flach mit Tiefe, würde ich mal sagen. Lassen wir das mitlaufen? Auf jeden Fall hier ist so Optik-Demo. Keine Ahnung.
Sieht nach Windows Phone aus.
Na ja, es ist vor allem mal wieder... Es ist halt so ein Video, wo das irgendwie so alles hintereinander animiert ist. Es ist nicht richtige Software. Es sieht zwar teilweise aus wie richtige Software.
Ich meine, es ist so ein Movie-OS-Modus. In Movie ist halt auch immer alles irgendwie bunt und fliegt durch die Gegend und so weiter.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall haben sie sich da schon das eine oder andere...
Ja, eine Menge, würde ich gerade sagen. Dieser Physikseffekt, der da gerade war.
Na ja, genau. Also Animationen und so ein bisschen Kram und so. Aber sie haben halt Schatten. Also du kannst jetzt wohl auch bei den User-Interface-Elementen sagen, auf welcher Höhe sie sind. Was auch immer gut das auch immer funktionieren mag.
Und die machen keine Parallaxeneffekte.
An Schatten.
Na ja, mal gucken. Also vielleicht ist das ja jetzt auch der heiße Scheiß.
Man wisset ja nicht. Man wisset ja nicht.
Na ja, und jetzt kontern sie halt alles. Es gibt Android Auto. Das ist dann halt so ihr Ansatz von CarPlay.
Mal gucken.
Also keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist das ja auch alles total toll. Aber ich bin mir sicher, die verdienen immer noch keinen Markt damit.
Wer, Google?
Doch, wieso nicht?
Na mit Android verdienen sie halt kein Geld.
Ich dachte, die kriegen die ganzen Lizenzgebühren. Mit ihrem Telefon verdienen sie kein Geld, weil sie nicht so genug haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel die wirklich in Lizenzgebühren verdienen, aber sehr viel kann das nicht sein.
Wozu machen die denn den ganzen Scheiß?
Na damit nicht iOS auf deinem Telefon ist. Sollen sie mal die 1 werden, sollen sie mal der Standard werden. Ich meine, das ist ja eh alles schon so ein bisschen wie bei Windows da. Wie ist das recht? Also ich halte es da ganz mit Huckel. Die Underdog-Abteilung hat es irgendwie besser gefallen. War irgendwie cooler.
Na ja, wie gesagt...
Du meinst Back to 1997, ja?
Ja, aber wir können uns jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nicht...
Beschweren?
Nee, wir können es überhaupt nicht äußern hier zu diesem ganzen Keynote-Kram, weil das läuft halt gerade und was weiß ich, was da jetzt hier die Realität ist. Und ansonsten interessiert uns das ja eh nicht so.
Das ist ja kein Android-Podcast.
Wir sind ja, wie sagt man so schön...
Ditt.
Und... Und ignorant. Schlecht informiert.
Stimmt alles bisher.
Und überheblich.
Hat wer gesagt.
Voreingenommen, da die Hörer, also die Kommentatoren, dass auch Hörer sind, weiß ich halt nicht. Das kann ja auch sein, dass das einfach nur so Hater sind. Ja, aber wir wissen, wie wir mit Hatern umgehen müssen. Wir nehmen das einfach an.
Wir laufen einfach rückwärts.
Wir haben so einen Lotus-Effekt auf den...
Freak Show 135, jetzt mit Lotus-Effekt.
Lotus-Effekt.
An uns perlt alles ab.
Kein Schmutz.
Ein Kollege, der auch Tim heißt, der hat sich jetzt bei so einem Kickstarter-Projekt ein T-Shirt mit Lotus-Effekt gekauft. Also das ganze T-Shirt innen wie außen ist sozusagen Lotus-Effekt behaftet.
Weil die nassen Flecken sind jetzt unten an der Hose oder was?
Ja, oder wenn ein seiner Kinder ihn mit Marmelade beschmeißen sollte, dann müssen sein T-Shirt einfach immer sauber.
Warte, hast du mal vorführen lassen?
Aber jetzt gehen sie ran hier, bei Google, jetzt haben sie sogar Frauen auf der Bühne. Das hat ja Apple noch nicht geschafft. Da war da eine Frau auf der Keynote?
Klar. Wo, wann?
Na, irgendeiner hat am Ende so einen Song gespielt.
Naja, das war's dann aber auch. Ich meine, Apple hat das jetzt glaube ich überhaupt das erste Mal in seiner Geschichte geschafft, sich eine Frau in ihr Exekutiv-Gremium reinzuholen.
An dem Board war schon eine.
Ja, ich meine jetzt...
Oder irgendeiner Bude.
Ja, ich meine halt die Executives. Also die, die wirklich was zu sagen haben. Immerhin. Ich meine, hab jetzt von denen noch nicht so sehr viel wahrgenommen. Man muss mal schauen, wie sie sich da mit den Retail-Stores rumschlägt, aber immerhin. Das ist bei Google offensichtlich anders. Gut so.
Komm, mach das Zeug aus.
Soll ich es ausmachen?
Na gut.
Dann können wir ja mal... Roddy, hast du denn die letzte Sendung gehört?
Ich hab die letzte Sendung gehört. Die vorletzte allerdings nicht.
Das ist egal. Die letzte hast du gehört.
Wie faszten die so? Lang.
Weitere, belastbare Beobachtungen.
Ähm, ja, gut, also, was genau möchtest du wissen?
Weiß ich nicht. Feedback, einfach so. Also, gut, selbst ein bisschen. Klingt ja schon fast wie eine Ausrede. Ne, ich meine, wir hätten dich ja gerne dabei gehabt, weil das ist ja noch sehr viel mehr dein Thema als unseres. Und wir hatten uns ja dann glücklicherweise den Gernot geangelt, der hier sehr ausführlich Rede und Antwort gemacht hat.
Ja, ausführlicher als ich das hätte tun können, weil ich gar nicht so gut vorbereitet gewesen wäre.
Ja, der hat sich das ja nun auch komplett reingeschneuchelt da. Aber absolut.
Ja, das Schlimme an der WWDC ist, dass da irgendwie immer so 80, 90, 100 Videos bei rausfallen. Und dann lädt man die sich alle runter und denkt sich, ja, die gucke ich mir alle an.
Kannst du die gar nicht mehr runterladen.
Na ja, und dann, ja.
Wie, kann man die nicht mehr runterladen?
Klar kann man die runterladen.
Ich denke, die gibt es jetzt nur noch per Stream.
Nein, nein.
Also per iTunes dann. Ich gucke die immer so, aber die kann jetzt jeder gucken ohne Account, ist das richtig?
Ja.
Das war früher auch nicht so.
Und runterladen.
Ja, per iTunes oder was?
Nein, aber per Webseite.
Nein, per Webseite.
Kannst einfach anklicken.
Mann ey.
Anklicken, runterladen und so weiter.
Genau.
PDF runterladen von den Folien und so.
Ja, und du sagst, alles war richtig, was wir gesagt haben. Da lässt sich auch gar nichts dran drehen. Wir haben es einfach so auf den Punkt geworfen. Beste Zusammenfassung der WWDC ever.
Na ja, nun, da ich da immer noch nicht so tief drin stecke, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Du glaubst es halt einfach, weil es kommt ja von uns. Also muss es ja stimmen.
Ja, gerne. Das eine, was du ja sowieso wissen wolltest, mit dem AV-Audioengine, was ich mir noch mal ein bisschen näher angeguckt hab.
Ja.
Ja, das ist meine Audio, endlich tut's mal was.
Und das andere ist Swift, was ich mir sehr intensiv angeguckt hab, was wahrscheinlich auch sehr viele andere Leute sehr intensiv angeguckt haben, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, Gernot hatte das noch nicht so direkt drauf, wahrscheinlich. Ja, das ist inzwischen drauf, aber da... Vielleicht war's auch, weil's ganz am Ende war, dann auch...
Ja, das war ein bisschen knapp in der Zeit.
Da muss man sich, glaube ich... Ja, da muss man sich auch, glaube ich, ganz schön, erstens das und zweitens muss man sich da, glaube ich, auch eine ganze Menge angucken, bis man da wirklich Aussagen treffen kann. Plus du hast dieses Heft schon durchgelesen, was sie da zum Gauen haben.
Ich fand nur schick, dass innerhalb von Minuten, nachdem man das verkündet hat, schon irgendwie die ersten in Emoji geschriebenen Programme durch die Gegend gesetten. Weil, wenn du jetzt schon eine Sprache machst, die damit wirbt, dass sie auch explizit... Das können ja viele andere auch. Ja, das kann ein paar fünf Uhr schon seit Jahren. Oder vermutlich noch viel tollere, sophisticatedere Sprachen. Aber dass man da halt seine ganzen Identifier und alles in Unicode schreiben kann, war natürlich nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis die ersten Leute anfangen irgendwie...
Lachende Männchen, Shithaufen aufzupfen.
Naja, das Schöne ist, dass du halt diese Playgrounds hast, wo du wirklich drauf los tippen kannst.
Hab ich auch gleich gesehen. System Klammer auf Gänsefuß R minus R auf Slash Gänsefuß Klammer zu.
Probier doch mal. Ja, womit wollen wir einsteigen?
Womit wollen wir einsteigen? Wenn du das Gefühl hast, wir haben da auch gar nichts vergessen, dann kannst du einfach mal damit einsteigen, was du dir genauer angeschaut hast.
Also fangen wir mal mit dem Audio an. Du hattest letztes Mal schon ganz richtig gesagt, dass alle Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben und die du auf Core Audio ansprichst, immer gleich mal zusammenzucken. Und das halt auch aus gutem Grund.
Ja, du hast ja auch eine Menge gezuckt.
Ja, es ist halt ein C-Interface, wie so ein C-Interface halt sein kann.
Nichts gegen Makro-Assembler hier, ja?
Es ist nicht so schlimm wie OpenSSL, aber es ist halt nur kurz drunter, also so als Interface, weil du hast dann diese teilweise diese komischen Core Foundation referenzgezählten Objekte, aber teilweise halt dann auch so, ich rufe eine Funktion auf mit einem Funktionspointer, der mir im Callback dann sagt, wie groß irgendwelche Strukturen sein können, damit ich dann die Struktur anlege und im nächsten Call dann den eigentlichen Call machen kann, damit das, was zurückkommt, auch in die Struktur passt und solches Zeug. Also das ist Core Audio. So und zu iOS 8 und Yosemite ist halt dieses AV-Audio-Engine neu gekommen und man guckt sich das an und denkt sich, yes, genau so sollte Core Audio eigentlich schon immer sein. Wir haben einen kompletten Rapper über alles gemacht und zumindest sieht es auf den ersten Blick so aus, als könntest du auf dieser High-Level-Ebene erstmal alles zusammenbauen, was du in Core Audio zusammenbauen kannst. Dazu muss man jetzt wissen, Core Audio ist halt so eine Audio-Engine mit Modulen. Also man kann jetzt so ein Eingabemodul haben, das ist eine Audio-Interface und dann mach ich hier ein Effektmodul und noch ein Effektmodul und noch ein Effektmodul und dann mach ich da einen Recorder dran oder ich mach da wieder ein Mixer, Audio. Also man kann diese ganzen Module zusammenbauen und dann kann man Start sagen und dann läuft es. Und dieses Konstrukt nennt sich Graf, U-Graf. Ist fürchterlich aufwendig. Keine Ahnung, ich hab mal so was gebaut. Also, oder was heißt, ich hab was gebaut. Es gibt ein Apple-Beispiel, wo die, das nennt sich Playthrough, wo die irgendwie einen Input nehmen und so eine Vari-Speed und ein Output und das zusammenpacken und dann kannst du das anwerfen und das zusammenpacken von dem ganzen Scheiß ist irgendwie mehrere Bildschirme seitenlang. Und mit AV Audio Engine müsstest du das in fünf Schritten fünf Zeilen Code erledigt haben. Also es ist irgendwie, es ist halt der Traum.
Ja, das klang sehr gut. Ich hab mir auch diese Präsentation angeschaut und dachte mir so, jetzt müsste man doch endlich mal was ordentliches programmieren können. Aber das betrifft natürlich jetzt auch nur so die Applikationsebene, ne?
Also es betrifft halt, wenn du nicht selber eine Audio-Unit, wie diese Module heißen, schreiben möchtest, also wenn du selber eine Audio-Unit schreiben willst, dann musst du wahrscheinlich wieder runter auf Core-Audio. Aber wenn du die mitgelieferten Audio-Units benutzen willst, also auch die Third-Party-Audio-Units, dann kannst du oben auf der AV-Audio-Engine-Ebene bleiben und das alles in Objective-C oder Swift machen.
Ja, aber wenn man jetzt sowas wie Soundflower, also diese virtuelle Audio-Device-Geschichte bauen möchte, quasi so eine Colonel-Extension.
Soundflower ist ja nochmal was anderes. Das ist ja der dritte Teil. Es ist nämlich ein Audiotreiber, der im Colonel lebt. Und die Sachen, die im Colonel sind, die haben erstmal, also sie haben natürlich schon auch was mit Core-Audio zu tun, sind aber eigentlich ein bisschen separat. Und da kommst du damit nicht weiter. Also es ist wirklich die Anwendersicht. Und ganz interessant ist, du kriegst ein In-Port-Device und ein Out-Port-Device, kriegst du relativ einfach das Standard-Device. Aber wenn du nicht das Standard-Device haben willst, also das, was eingestellt ist, dann weiß ich nicht. Also rein von der Doku her war es jetzt nicht so klar, wie man an eins der anderen Devices rankommt. Das ist dann nicht ganz so einfach. Das geht ja schon mal gut los. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es eigentlich das, was man haben will.
Kann jeder auswählen für Programme?
Ist das auch einfach?
Das scheint ja ein echtes Problem zu sein.
Was ich wirklich spannend fand, ist, du kannst quasi zu jeder Audio-Unit eine Side-Chain machen. Also du kannst das, was aus der Audio-Unit rauskommt und in die nächste Audio-Unit reingeht, kannst du dir mit einem Callback auf einem normalen Thread zurückliefern lassen. Weil das Gemeine an Audio ist ja, der Audio-Thread ist ja der höchst priorisierte Thread im System. Es gibt keinen, der drüber ist. Und man muss relativ viele Klimmzüge machen, um unterbrechungsfrei da irgendwas abgreifen zu können und es irgendwo anders hinzukriegen. Weil Loks oder so im Audio-Thread zu benutzen, ist eine verdammt dämliche Idee. Und wenn man mal versucht, was über lockfreie Cues und so weiter irgendwo nachzulesen, dann wird es meistens schnell esoterisch. Das sind so Datenstrukturen, die kriegt man nicht mal so eben geschenkt. Und an der Stelle scheint es aber relativ einfach zu sein, dass man halt einfach sagt, ich hänge meine Closure mit an diese Audio-Ione hier dran. Und immer wenn es Daten gibt, werde ich dann zurückgerufen auf diese Closure.
Das heißt, wenn man halt so sich seinen Mix zusammengebaut hat und man will zum Beispiel wegschreiben an irgendeiner Stelle, aufnehmen, streamen...
Na, wegschreiben geht sowieso relativ einfach, weil es halt ein Recorder-Modul gibt als Audio...
Na gut, also angenommen du willst irgendwas wegschreiben und nicht unbedingt die Audiodaten selber, also irgendeine Detektion darauf machst oder wenn du halt...
Genau, das müsste an der Stelle relativ einfach gehen, beziehungsweise was man ja auch ganz gerne hat, ist einfach mal ein Level-Meter an jeder Stelle. Damit du weißt, wie viel geht denn jetzt in die Audio-Unit rein und wie viel kommt hinten wieder raus und passt das alles noch.
Das klingt doch sehr hoffnungsvoll.
Da muss man dann schnell upgraden.
Ja, muss man. Na ja, da gab es ja letztes Mal große Klagen, dass es so fürchterlich aussehen würde. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr alle habt, ich finde es super.
Super findest du es?
Ja, mir gefällt es total.
Super oder Gardiola super super?
Was ist denn Gardiola?
Wir sind hier voll im Fußball-Thema.
Ich mag das Design, ich mag das.
Der Safari kommt ja nicht ein bisschen hässlich vor.
Wieso, was ist daran hässlich?
Na, da oben.
Wo da oben?
Diese weißen Buttons?
Diese Leiste da überhaupt generell, die sieht doch aus wie hingekackt und hingeschissen.
Also ganz ehrlich, es geht immer nicht.
Eben warst du noch bei Super.
Ja, ich meine, der alte Safari sah nicht viel besser aus. Man braucht aber einen Retina. Also auf nicht Retina sieht es wirklich kacke aus. Aber auf einem Retina sieht es wirklich gut aus.
Wenn dir sieht es gut aus, muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Ich habe keinen Retina.
Ich kann gucken, wir fahren hier noch Classic.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie iOS 7. Also iOS 7 unter nicht Retina sieht halt auch beschissen aus.
Man könnte auch sagen, das sieht auch mit Retina.
Nein, aber noch beschissener. Können wir uns auf noch beschissener einigen?
Oder einfach nur beschissener. Das wäre am neutralsten und immer noch korrektesten.
Zu AV Audio Engine gibt es eigentlich so viel gar nicht mehr zu sagen. Außer, dass du halt wirklich, wie der eine hier im Chat meinte, im Swift Playground fängst du an, machst du.
Ja, ich meine, ich finde es einfach schön, wenn das mal jetzt zu einem Zustand kommen würde, wenn man jetzt Leute anspricht, ob sie nicht mal irgendwas mit Audio, dass sie nicht einfach alle davonrennen, sondern sich denken so, ah ja, das ist ja jetzt total einfach. Man kann sich mal um den Rest kümmern. Ich frage mich, warum sie so lange gebraucht haben dafür.
Sagen wir mal so, die ebene Module zusammenzuklicken ist relativ einfach geworden, wenn du wirklich Audio machen willst. Also das, eine Audio-Unit, wo auch Audio drin verarbeitet wird und so, dann ist es glaube ich nach wie vor nicht so einfach. Aber den Use-Case, den Apple jetzt erschlagen hat, dürften irgendwie 90, 95 Prozent der Leute glücklich machen.
Für mich bin ich gar nicht so sicher.
Ich mir, so wie ich dich kenne und lieben gelernt habe, bin ich mir schon relativ sicher, dass du am Ende doch wieder mit einer langen Nase da sitzt.
Glücklich machen hält bei Tim immer nicht so lange.
Ich weiß nicht, die OS X-Updates haben mich ja eigentlich weitgehend...
Befriedet.
Ja.
Beim Mavericks warst du voll des Lobes, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Außer das Audio.
Ja, ich meine...
Das war Buggy, aber das haben sie irgendwann nie gekriegt, oder?
Meine erste Enttäuschung war natürlich, dass sich bei diesem Audio-Midi-Setup halt immer noch nichts getan hat. Es gibt halt immer noch keine Möglichkeit in diesem Evo-Git.
Irgendwas ist ja immer.
Ja, das fehlt halt schon seit Ewigkeiten. Ich meine, das hat sich zumindest nicht verschlechtert. Das hat sich halt nur nicht verbessert. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe das nicht, warum das nicht geht. Das wäre einfach das Feature überhaupt, dass man sich einfach so ein virtuelles Audio-Device zusammenbastelt und einfach bestimmte Kanäle einfach weglässt. Einfach nur weglassen. Stattdessen muss man da immer alle wieder reintun. Und wenn man sich das einfach mal so zusammenbauen könnte, wie man es braucht, das heißt, du hast so eine Kaskade von Audio-Devices und du willst darauf einen Virtual-View machen, wo einfach nicht alle Kanäle dabei sind.
Quasi ein Audiopool und du machst dann irgendwie so wie ZFS für Audio quasi.
Also ZFS für Audio würde jetzt schon sehr weit gehen, würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube, Use Cases sind ein bisschen unterschiedlicher.
Aber du weißt schon so irgendwie, einfach volle Kontrolle, volle Flexibilität, was du so mit deinen...
Alles geht, aber du brauchst 32 Gig Speicher.
Was du mit deinen Audio-Providern halt so machst. Du hast halt einfach so einen Audio-Provider-Pool und dann kannst du da drauf virtual routen und mappen und...
Ja, Echoer Audio ist eigentlich genau das, aber halt ohne Kommando-Zeilen-Tools. Ich sehe gerade hier dieses Audio-Medi-Setup. Gibt es auch noch in Your 17?
Tim, aber gerade oben links war ja noch das zweite Buch, was man ja auch braucht. Es gibt ja nicht nur Swift-Buch, sondern es gibt ja auch das Swift mit Objective-C-Integrieren-Buch. Das war gleich oben links neben dem hier.
Natürlich habe ich das gesehen, ich habe es selber runtergeladen. Lass uns doch das Thema erstmal einführen, bevor wir es irgendwie gleich unterbrechen. Bist du denn durch mit deinem Audio?
Mehr oder weniger, es sei denn, du willst noch was wissen.
Nee, will er nicht.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass die Sachen nicht dabei sind, die ich gerne hätte, aber es sind andere Sachen dabei, die...
Ja...
Kommen wir zu Swift?
Swift. Swift. Was sagst du da? Das war echt unerwartet, oder? Also ich meine, ich hab das Video ja irgendwie Tage später gesehen und konnte mich dann genau auf den Moment konzentrieren, wo er sagt, neue Programmiersprache, die Kamera schwenkt ins Publikum und alle so. Also der ganze Saal so. Das war schön.
Ja, Hucke hat seit Jahren auf McRuby gewartet. Geplatzt, die Blase. Schon früher geplatzt.
Also ich weiß nicht, das waren ja 70% der Teilnehmer, sagten sie ja selber, waren ja das erste Mal da und so sahen die auch aus.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich hab so den Eindruck gehabt, die haben diese ganzen Anspielungen mit, ja, und jetzt ist auch das neu und ihr müsst nicht mehr das und das machen. Alle so, das musste man vorher machen.
Die haben ja schon vor den Kinos und die Vorträge auch ein bisschen gesehen haben, oder nicht? Meinst du, da waren jetzt nur vollblutige Anfänger, die letztes Jahr noch nicht mal eine WWDC-Sicht die Videos angeguckt haben?
Also ich hab da irgendwie bei diesen Schwenks irgendwie zu 80% immer nur 15-jährige indische Teenager gesehen, die so den Eindruck machen, als wäre das jetzt nicht nur ihre erste WWDC, sondern dass sie gerade mal jetzt seit einem halben Jahr dabei sind. Und die hatten auch die Stamina, sich 8 Stunden vorher anzustellen, damit sie auch in der ersten Reihe einen Platz kriegen.
Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie diese ganzen, diese ganz jungen, wahrscheinlich diese ganzen Student irgendwas, da gibt's ja so ein, man kann sich da bewerben und dann kriegt man die Karte umsonst und so weiter, dass sie die alle in die erste Reihe gesetzt haben. Also insofern sahen die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überrepräsentiert aus. Aber ja, mit Swift hatte wirklich niemand gerechnet. Ja, richtig. Also den Eindruck, den ich bekommen hab, als ich das Buch gelesen hab, war so, da hat sich irgendwie jemand die fünf Standardwerke zum Thema C genommen und mal geguckt, was die so schreiben, was man alles auf keinen Fall tun darf, weil das gefährlich ist, und all die Features aus der Sprache ausgebaut haben. Also zumindest so die erste Hälfte von dem Swift-Buch ist so einmal C, aber alle Bugs gefixt.
Kein implizites Casting mehr.
Na ja, die Syntax ist schon noch sehr C-lastig. Gut, sie haben ein paar Runde Klammern weggeworfen, am If, am Vor, am Switch, sonst wo. Sie haben Semikolons weggeworfen.
Semikola.
Semikolay, wie auch immer. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das nicht groß anders als die C-Syntax. Gut, wenn man draufguckt, sieht es erstmal anders aus, aber es sind halt nur ein paar Klammern und Semikola weniger. So ein Semikolibri. Aber wenn man dann so ein bisschen reinliest, es gibt schon einige richtig coole Sachen. Was ich zum Beispiel sehr cool finde, sind diese Konstanten. Bei C ist Konst Keyword. Das Zeug ist halt Konst und der Compiler muss zur Compile-Zeit herausfinden können, was für ein Wert das ist, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Bei Swift ist es eher so ein Single Assignment, wie man es von den funktionalen Sprachen wie Erlang oder so kennt, was schon mal sehr geil ist. Also du kannst mitten im Dings, kannst du sagen Let und dann kriegst du eine Konstante und dann kannst du eine große Rechnung dahinter machen und dann rechnet dir das aus und die Variable wird halt einmal zugewiesen und danach ist sie konstant.
Haben sie auch gesagt, dass sie sehr viel drauf Wert legen, dass viel halt Konst ist?
Na ja, ist es nicht so wie bei Erlang, weil bei Erlang gibt es das halt nur. Also das ist schon nochmal was anderes.
Ja, aber bei Swift funktionieren so wie bei Erlang alles funktioniert. Können wir uns darauf einigen? Egal.
Weil sie sind konstant. Ich meine, das ist jetzt bei C auch nicht anders.
Ja, wir kommen noch zu den Feinheiten. Wir kommen noch zu den Feinheiten. So, dann das ist das erste. Das Zweite, es gibt keine implizite Typumwandlung. Und zwar gar nicht.
Ja, das ist sinnvoll.
Das finde ich auch gut.
Das ist sehr sinnvoll.
Das ist überhaupt der Tod jeder Programmiersprache. Also so automatische Typwandlung. Das ist auch so sinnlos. Das ist einfach nur Faulheit. Eine Faulheit, die eigentlich auch, weiß ich, für die Designer der Programmiersprache ist es eher schwieriger, das dann immer noch zu machen. Und man versucht den Programmierern dabei irgendwas abzunehmen, was nicht abgenommen werden sollte, weil sie sich dann entweder drauf verlassen und dann passiert es nicht, oder eben nicht damit rechnen und dann passiert es.
Vor allem muss man die Wandelungsregeln, wohin wie gewandelt wird, muss man ja auch alle kennen, sonst geht es ja irgendwie schief.
Wenn du so ein Typ-System hast, es gibt ja zwei Schulen quasi, die einen, die wollen eigentlich gar nicht typisieren, und die anderen sagen, ich habe ein Typ-System, weil ich der Meinung bin, es bringt mir was. Nämlich der Compiler soll mich auf alle dämlichen Fehler, die ich mache, hinweisen. Wenn ich dann eine implizite Typumwandlung habe, dann unterlaufe ich ja den eigentlichen Sinn meines Typ-Systems.
Es gibt auch die anderen Schulen, die sagen, man braucht beides.
Also ich muss ja sagen, bei Ruby, da ist ja alles total freiform, da geht ja alles Mögliche bunt durcheinander. Ich finde das ja teilweise schon sehr schön, gerade so zum Loshacken.
Ja klar, wenn du noch selber den Überblick hast, ist es prima, wenn dein Projekt mal riesengroß wird.
Na sagen wir mal so, es ist nicht so wie JavaScript, wo String plus Zahl irgendwie komplett was anderes macht als Zahl plus String. Oder irgendwie so andere Beispiele, wo, weißt schon, bei JavaScript ist ja wirklich die Sprache, wo so diese Art von Umwandlung so immer the element of most surprise ist. Bei Ruby ist es weitgehend, weitgehend, weitestgehend vorhersagbar, was passieren würde, also man gewöhnt sich relativ schnell ein und dann gibt's da nicht so diese Überraschungsfälle, wie plötzlich kommt da eins statt einem True raus.
Du spielst auf dieses 5 Minuten Wet Video an. Dieser Vortrag. Let's for example take JavaScript und dann macht er irgendwas. Was ist denn das plus das? Ist doch ganz einfach und dann kommt irgendwas raus und alle, hä?
JavaScript ist ja glaub ich wirklich furchtbar.
Ah ja, da einer, im Chat hat es einer reingehauen.
Ich muss mich heute mal zwischendurch ein paar Mal hinstellen. Ich bin heute irgendwie zappelig mit den Beinen und dieser Stuhl nervt mich.
Der Stuhl ist ja auch dazu zappelig zu halten.
Da darf doch mal eine Sendung stehen, denn da dauert es noch nicht so lange.
Du kannst den Stuhl übrigens auch richtig hoch machen.
Oder den andersrum drehen, du kannst den auch andersrum drauf setzen.
Mach ihn mal ganz hoch.
Zum Thema implizite Sachen, die nicht gehen. Noch explizites Methoden-Overwriting. Wenn du eine Methode überschreiben willst, brauchst du ein Keyword, was sagt, ich überschreibe jetzt eine Methode, die da vorher war.
Die komischerweise Funk heißt, weil Mess war ihn wahrscheinlich zu Drogen mäßig.
Dann strikteres Type-Checking bei IF.
Und der Block muss geklammert werden. Keinzeilige Dinger sind nicht mehr da.
Das ist das Allergeilste.
Am Anfang an, nach Goto Fail, haben sie das dann reingenommen.
Wahrscheinlich, aber ich konnte das noch nie sagen. Aber Goto Fail, abgesehen davon, dass es keinen Goto gibt in Swift, zumindest war keins im Buch.
Kann da aber noch kommen. Kann nicht alles überlegen, was sie wollen.
Also das wär mit Swift nicht passiert. Was hab ich mir noch aufgeschrieben?
In Switch-Cases haben sie keine Brakes mehr. Das heißt, man kann keine Fall-Through-Switch-Dinger bauen, was ja manchmal ganz cool ist, aber es ist doch sehr grenzwertig.
Moment, es gibt ein Fall-Through-Keyword, was du benutzen kannst, um ein Fall-Through tatsächlich zu machen. Was ich aber sehr cool finde. Weil das ist der Ausnahmsfall und den will man trotzdem machen können.
Also geht weiterhin, nur sie haben es umgedreht. Das finde ich aber voll gut, weil ein Break per Default ist besser.
Dennis hat deinen Strom geklaut.
Ich dachte, du hast ja Überblick, wo du noch Strom hast. Naja, passt schon. Aber du kannst es auch wieder haben, ich habe 100 Prozent jetzt.
Man sieht sich ja immer wieder.
Ja, ne, zwei Wochen.
So, dann kommen die ersten Sachen, wo es aus der C-Welt weggeht. Tupels, was ich schon mal ganz cool finde.
Also mehr Rückgabewerte bei einer Funktion.
Ja, genau. Aber man muss sich es so vorstellen wie ein Tupel unter Erlang. Funktioniert auch genauso. Und du kannst auch so, wie man das bei Erlang macht, irgendwie einen Tupel nehmen und zwei Variablen aus dem Tupel zu weisen. So, ich weiß nicht, habe ich das jetzt ordentlich erklärt. Also ein Tupel ist halt... Sylvain hatte das ja auch. Es sind halt zwei oder mehr Values in einem Ding ins...
Also bei C hat klassischerweise eine Funktion nur ein Rückgabewert und da können es halt mehrere sein.
Ja, du kannst halt einen Tupel zurückgeben und ein Tupel kann mehrere Werte enthalten. So, das ist halt...
Sogar mehrere Tupel.
Aber das kannst du ja auch geben, der jetzt mit einer Programmiersprache anfängt, dem kann man ja auch nicht erklären, wenn du sagst, du kannst der Funktion mehrere Sachen übergeben, aber du kriegst immer nur eine zurück, dann sagt er auch, warum geht denn da nicht auch mehrere Sachen zurück? Das war schon immer unlogisch eigentlich, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon. So, und jetzt wird es langsam richtig spannend. Bei Case Statements kannst du Pattern-Matching machen. Und zwar so, wie man es von den funktionalen Sprachen kennt.
Erstens das und zweitens, was wir auch vergessen haben, den Switch muss immer, wie ist das Wort, was sie benutzt haben?
Alle Cases abdecken.
Alle Cases abdecken, genau.
Aber du kannst Default benutzen.
Jaja, klar, aber wenn du das nicht machst, dann sagt er gleich, hier, da fehlt ja die Hälfte. Dann beschwert sich der Compiler.
Aber das Pattern-Matching, das fand ich schon mal sehr cool. Sie machen es leider nicht bei Funktionen, aber vielleicht ist es auch nicht so wichtig.
Ist das auch so ein bisschen Erlang-mäßig?
Pattern-Matching? Überhaupt nicht.
Das ist eines der Grundprinzipien dieser Sprache.
Also doch.
Ja, also, ja, erklären wir jetzt nicht, aber mal nachgucken. Also es gibt beim Pattern-Matching auch diesen Unterstrich, wenn dir irgendwas egal ist, wo du halt sagst, der und der Parameter, der kann irgendeinen Wert haben, aber matcht trotzdem, dann kannst du den Unterstrich benutzen. So. Also das geht nicht. So, das waren so die Sachen, die ich mir als toll aufgespielt hab.
Wenn ich in Swift wissen will, ob das dritte Bit-Gesetz ist?
Gute Frage, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wie man es macht. Meine Fresse. Also es gibt natürlich Bitweise Operatoren.
Ja, also und und oder, na dann geht es doch schon.
Jaja.
Also anders geht es ja an C auch nicht. Du musst halt dann ein Bit-Muster machen, wo das Bit gesetzt ist, dann unten und gucken, ob es noch da ist.
Ja, aber du hast kein Bit-Weises Pattern-Matching wie in Erlang.
Aber man kann schon noch so ein bisschen zu Low-Level.
Ein bisschen geht noch. Also du hast ja keine Pointer, ne? Also das steht hier in der Liste gar nicht drin, weil es so jenseits ist, es gibt halt keine Pointer mehr. Fertig.
Kann man den Swift rotieren? Weil das konnte C ja immer nicht, C kann nichts rotieren.
Also schiften kannst du, ob du rotieren kannst, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Schiften ist ja multiplizieren zur Not, aber ähm... Rotieren ging nämlich in C nicht, und das war immer ein Problem bei den ganzen Krypto-Alberthmen-Dinger, weil die wollen halt rotieren, und dann musst du es da mal komische Sachen machen oder Inline-Assembler nehmen.
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern, ob ich das gelesen hab. Diese ganzen Bit-weisen-Dinger, die hab ich überblättert, weil ich es nicht so spannend fand.
Finden wir gerade mal so einen noch.
Generics hab ich mir noch aufgeschrieben. Also du kannst, wenn du einen Array oder einen Dictionary machst, kannst du halt sagen, das sind Typen von drin. Das sind halt ein Array von Strings oder ein Dictionary mit Key, String und Value von...
Objektivistik auch schon. Bei Vor-Each hast du ja auch gesagt, wenn du dir die Werte rausgeholt hast, hast du gesagt, der Typ ist so und so. Ist ja ein bisschen ähnlich. Bloß da ist noch ein bisschen mehr festgenagelt. Nicht nur für deinen Blog, sondern auch für die Vorschleife.
Vor allem der Compiler checkt halt, ob du die richtigen Teile reintust. Und naja gut, und der gibt dir halt... Ich weiß nicht, ob du einen Runtime-Error kriegst, wenn du trotzdem falsche Werte reintun.
Also man kann wesentlich mehr festnageln, wenn man will, aber man muss nicht.
Man muss nicht. Es gibt was vorher bei Objective-See-It hieß. ID heißt jetzt AnyType. Also kannst du sagen AnyType und dann kann es irgendwas sein. Egal ob ein Int oder eine Klasse oder ein Enum oder ein Strukt oder weiß ich nicht. Also das ist so ein... Das hab ich mir so als die positiven Sachen aufgeschrieben. Die neutralen Sachen, Type Inferral, weiß ich nicht so recht, was ich davon halten soll. Also du kannst sagen, var VariableName ist gleich und aus der Zuweisung kommt ein Typ raus und der Compiler weiß, welcher Typ rauskommt, deswegen bekommt die Variable den richtigen Typ zugewiesen. Nennen sie Type Inferral. Also du musst den Typ nicht hinschreiben.
Ach so, du erbst sozusagen den Typ gleich von dem Wert, den du auch übernimmst.
Genau.
Wenn es eh eine Konstante ist, dann ist es halt...
Na ja, aber es geht auch bei einer Variable.
Ja, aber es ergibt sich ja an der Stelle der Typ.
Da man ja explizit casten muss, kann es ja auch nur noch der Typ sein. Der Computer hat ja nicht irgendwie... wird einfach weggecastet. So gesehen geht es ja eigentlich. Ja, das sagst du so einfach.
Man muss immer wissen, was für ein Typ ist.
Ja, aber da treffen sich halt die beiden Schulen zwischen... Entweder ich typisiere und ich mach's richtig oder ich typisiere halt nicht oder nicht so sehr. Also ich weiß nicht...
Mach mal zu Ende, weil dann...
Die Frage ist ja, ist die Variable typisiert oder ist der Wert typisiert?
Beides.
Ja, manchen Sprachen ist es so, manche Sprachen ist es so. Also du kannst einer Variable auch andere Typen zuweisen. Es ist halt immer klar, was der Typ ist in dem Moment. Die Variable hat den Typ nicht selbst. Du kannst dem Namen unterschiedliche Typen zuweisen. Das kann mal das und dann kannst du mal wieder das sein.
Nee, also wenn du eine Variable einmal deklariert hast und sie hat einen Wert bekommen...
Dann ist sie stark getypt.
Dann ist die Variable fest typisiert und du kannst nicht mehr ein anderes Objekt einziehen.
Kann man das hinschreiben oder macht das automatisch? Schreibt man einfach let a gleich b und a hat dann den Typen, der b auch war? Oder musst du das auch wieder explizit schreiben, dass egal welcher Typ es ist, er übernommen werden soll?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das ist dieses Type-Inferno.
Du meinst, wenn ich jetzt sage, war a gleich 5 und danach sage ich war a gleich hallo, dann ist das ein Fehler?
Ja.
Ihr habt das sowieso, weil du zweimal war geschrieben hast. Das heißt, du würdest die Variable erneut... Okay, aber wenn ich a gleich hallo sage und dann sagst du a gleich hallo, ist ein Fehler. Weil bei der ersten Zuweisung a gleich 5 ist die Variable a zu einem Integer geworden. Und hallo ist aber ein String. Und du kannst einen String nicht, eine Int-Variable zeigen.
Ich kann keine Variable sagen, die nicht festgelegt ist, die alles Mögliche sein kann.
Aber dann hat sie explizit den Typ Any.
Dann darf die nicht initialisiert werden sozusagen.
Nein, du musst dann sagen, die Variable hat explizit den Type Any. Ich hab mir auch geschrieben Any und Any Object. Aber die genauen Sachen müsste ich nochmal nachgucken. Also es ist, was so ein bisschen unklar ist, was sie auch in der Dokumentation nicht so ganz sauber beschreiben, ist den Unterschied zwischen Reference-Counted-Type und Simple-Type. Also es gibt halt Typen, die werden referenzgecounted, so wie Objekte einer Klasse oder irgendwie, ja, Objekte einer Klasse eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Und es gibt die, die, die Objekte, also die Typen, die werden kopiert jedes Mal, werden also by value übergeben, so wie ein Int, ein Float. Beim String bin ich mir schon gar nicht mehr sicher, aber ich glaube, das String ist by reference. Und das ist, Struct sind by value, ne? Während... Wieso?
Ja, wenn du wieder so eine Mixtur hast, mal ist es so, mal ist es so.
Viel Spaß. Na, in dem Fall ist es relativ sinnvoll, dass du, also nehmen wir mal an, du machst sowas wie... Was hatte denn ihr letztes Mal?
Android ist auch relativ gut.
Ihr hattet letztes Mal so ein Frame und ein Rect, das ist halt ein Origin, XY und Width und Height, sind vier Float-Values. Normalerweise. Und wenn du die vier Float-Values aber in eine Klasse einpackst, dann hast du vier Floats, die eigentlich per Value kopiert werden, wenn du sie kopieren würdest. Die hast du aber in einer Klasse eingepackt und die Klasse wird aber wieder gerefcounted. Solange du nur Arc machst, ist es noch nicht so ein Problem, aber sollten die später mal, ich sag mal in zwei Jahren, für Swift eine Garbage Collection machen, hast du das Problem, dass du immer dann, wenn du so mikrokleine Objekte hast, deren Werte sowieso Biowalue sind, erzeugst du ein Objekt, das hinterher deinen Garbage Collector wieder abräumen musst. Angeblich hat Java dieses Problem und C-Sharp nicht, aber da bin ich auf dünnem Eis, da sag ich besser nichts weiter zu.
Aber wir können schon mal festhalten, dass in zwei Jahren keine Garbage Collection kommt, weil das Swift ja wahrscheinlich auch eher so Arc-mäßig das automatisch macht, oder?
Swift macht Arc, ja. Das auf jeden Fall. Nein, ich sage nur, für so eine Sprache wie Swift ist ein Garbage Collector sinnvoller oder machbarer als für eine Sprache wie Objective-C.
Ja, aber trotzdem wird es nicht kommen.
Wer weiß, was kommen wird. Aber wenn, dann wird es nur für Swift kommen.
Objective-C war schon da und ist auch schon wieder weg, so schnell ging es. Da hat man ja nicht mitbekommen, dass es da war.
So schnell ging es. Und insofern, es gibt Strugs, für die ist es sinnvoll, dass man den gesamten Strug, in dem Fall von dem Rekt, sind das halt vier Floats, sprich vier mal vier Byte, 16 Byte, dass man die by value kopiert, jedes Mal, wenn man sie woanders hin tut. Weil der Aufwand, dafür ein Ref Counting zu machen und das irgendwann abzuwickeln und mit Speicher allokieren, wieder zurück und vor, einfach mehr Aufwand ist. Und das ist die Design-Idee dahinter.
Das heißt, du meinst, die machen bei Ref Counting nur für größere Objekte, wo es sich halt auch lohnt. Also ein String kann ja da wahrscheinlich auch 64-Bit-Größe haben, also die Länge. Und da lohnt es sich halt und Data und alles und Objekte und so, aber halt nicht irgendwelche Floats oder Ints oder sonst die. Dann bräuchten sie aber schon so ein bisschen eine genauere Liste, wie das was, was ist und wo sie da die Trennung ziehen, oder?
Die gibt es wahrscheinlich hinten in der Language Reference. Also diese Language Reference, die ist dann auch ein bisschen trocken.
Aber am Ende dann doch auch irgendwann mal wichtig, ne?
Jaja, wenn man solche Sachen wirklich nachgucken möchte.
Bei Enumerations, da war doch auch was, ich weiß nicht, hast du dir das, wenn du das ganze Buch gelesen hast, hast du es ja vielleicht auch besser drin, dass man die Enumerators dann so einfach so mit Punktnotation so angehen kann? Also wenn man Alignment zum Beispiel hat, dann so Punkt-Right und man nicht mehr den Enumerator aufführen muss?
Also das eine ist, also die einzelnen Values oder diese einzelnen Enum-Werte sind nicht im globalen Scope per se, sondern du musst immer den Typ von dem Enum vorne dran schreiben, Punkt, den eigentlichen Value von der Enumeration. Das ist die eine Sache. Das zweite ist, du kannst an ein Enum wie an eine Klasse oder ein Struct Methoden ranhängen. Was manchmal sinnvoll ist. Nicht immer, aber...
Ja, da waren die aber auch schon sehr high-levelmäßig die Beispiele, die sie da hatten. Also da muss man sich ein bisschen länger beschäftigen, bis man das so aus dem Ärmel schüttelt, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, bestimmt. Also das ist auch so was, was wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute irgendwie im ersten Jahr nicht benutzen, weil man nicht dran denkt, dass das geht und der Use-Case wahrscheinlich auch eher seltener ist. Also das Gleiche gilt ja für Structs. Du kannst in Structs auch Methoden dranhängen. Kann man jetzt auch diskutieren, ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht?
Ja, aber ich finde es schon cool, wenn ich halt so ein Alignment schreibe, aber bei Objective-C kommt das ja oft, wenn dein Text-Filter irgendwie links, rechts, oben, unten, weißt du schon. Und dann willst du halt hinschreiben, ja soll jetzt rechts sein? Ja und dann scheiße, wie war das jetzt? NS-Text-Filter, bla bla, Punkt, right. Und da weißt du das halt immer nicht. Und ich meine, der Autokompliter, der kann das zwar schon ganz cool, aber wäre trotzdem cool, wenn man einfach Punkt, right hinschreibt. Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Hast du noch ein paar Dinge zu Ende? Sonst würde ich kurz das noch dranhängen.
Also ich bin ja jetzt gerade mal durch die positiven und die, ich weiß selber nicht so genau, was ich davon halten soll, Sachen. Wir können ja mal die Sachen machen, die ich nicht so toll finde. Also da ist erstmal diese Funktionssyntax. Also ich weiß nicht. Naja, runde Klammern und irgendwie in der Mitte von der Funktion fängt die runde Klammer an und dann hast du zwar named parameters, aber dann ist es alles irgendwie wüst.
In der Mitte der Funktion fängt die runde Klammer an.
Mach mal auf die Mitte, ich sehe nichts.
Naja, du hast halt die klassische C-Funktion Syntax. Funktion Name, Klammer auf, Parameter. Aber du kannst benannte Parameter benutzen. Das heißt, du kannst dann machen Funktion Name, Klammer auf, Name erster Parameter, Doppelpunkt. Der Typ? Ja, bei der Deklaration der Typ, beim Aufruf dein Wert. Zweiter Name, Doppelpunkt Wert. Dritter Name, Doppelpunkt Wert. Und in Objective-C war das halt irgendwie alles eins. Also da waren zwar auch Doppelpunkte drin, aber der Funktionen Name war nicht getrennt in Funktion Name und Name der Parameter, sondern das war halt eins. Also gut, das kann man natürlich auch schlecht finden. Aber irgendwie diese neue Syntax, die ist so...
Die geht einem noch nicht so raus irgendwie so.
Na gut, vielleicht haben wir uns alle in einem Jahr dran gewöhnt und dann ist es auch nicht mehr so wild. Ein Vorteil daran ist natürlich, wenn du das mischst, Objective-C und Swift, dass du dann nicht so leicht durcheinander kommst, weil das halt wirklich eine ganz andere Syntax ist. Ja...
Nicht im gleichen Fall.
Und was ich rausgefunden hab, was nicht so richtig funktioniert, ist, wenn du ein Objective-C++-File hast, wo du Objective-C und C++ drin mischst, kannst du nicht ein Swift-File inkludieren, weil da kommt da irgendwie durcheinander. Das fixen sie vielleicht noch, aber das hat erst mal auf Anhieb nicht funktioniert. Ne, das Schlimmste finde ich ist immer noch Operator-Overloading. Es gibt Operator-Overloading und das ist meiner Meinung nach eine Katastrophe.
Ich find's auch scheiße.
Weil du erkennst eine schlechte Programmiersprache daran, dass es Operator-Overloading gibt. Das braucht man nicht, das macht nur den Code unleserlich. Es bereitet einem mehr Probleme, als man Probleme damit löst.
Du musst es erstmal beschreiben, was es ist.
Operator-Overloading ist, ich kann... Ja, du kannst an einer beliebigen Klasse deinen Operator Plus dranhängen und dann kannst du Objekte dieser Klasse Plus irgendwas anderes machen. Und dann passiert irgendwas.
Ich finde es grundsätzlich toll, solange diese Sprache nicht sämtliche Typen mitbringt, die man so braucht. Das simpelste Beispiel, das wird immer aus der klassischen Lehre...
Lass mich raten, Vektoren?
Ne, imaginäre Zahlen.
Ja, ist auch so was wie ein Vektor. Ja, gut, ist aber auch das einzige Beispiel und dann verließen sie ihn.
Es gibt jede Menge Sachen, die man super toll addieren kann, die aber jetzt nicht notwendigerweise natürlich die Zahlen sind. Ja, die addieren vielleicht jetzt nicht, da kann man jetzt noch bei den Pluszeichen streiten.
Also zum Schreiben ist das ja nicht ganz cool, aber jemand, der das dann später lesen muss, der das vorher nicht geschrieben hat, ist die Katastrophe.
Hallo, du musst halt das ganze Ding lesen. Du kannst nicht einfach einen kurzen Nippet rausziehen von fünf Zeilen sagen, ah. Du musst halt gucken, was es für Typen gibt in der Sprache.
So ein Programm, was eine Tonne groß ist, und dann musst du das gesamte Programm finden, ob da nicht irgendwelche Oberlaute irgendwo sind.
Nein, du musst erst mal verstehen, was es für Typen gibt. Sonst fallen wir zurück in die Zeit von Makro-Assembler. Wo es nur einen Integer gibt und fertig.
Ich will jetzt das komplette Programm studieren.
Und du überlegst doch nicht die... Du überlegst doch nicht global Plus und Minus. Das machst du ja sehr lokal, wenn du es tust.
Naja, trotzdem hast du... Also der Unterschied zwischen jetzt ein Objective-C, wo halt die Methodennamen eher zu lang sind für Leute, die es nicht gewöhnt sind, und einem überladenen Operator, wo dann nur noch ein Zeichen steht, ist... Der Unterschied ist schon sehr groß. Und du musst immer daran denken, du liest dein Programm 20 mal öfter, als du es schreibst. Und deswegen muss ein Programm löserlich sein. Und überladene Operatoren machen ein Programm nicht löserlich.
Wenn ich mich auch nochmal kurz unqualifiziert melden darf. Das ist so eine Sache, also... Ich würde dir zustimmen, dass Operator- Overloading in Sprachen, wo Operator was Spezielles sind, nämlich was anderes, durchaus zu Konfusion führen können. C++ und so weiter, da ist das irgendwie... Also ich will mich da auch jetzt nicht zu sehr aufs dünne Eis begeben. Andererseits sollte, und ich weiß nicht genau, wie das bei Swift ist, auch ein Operator im Kern nichts anderes sein als eine Funktion. Die, also plus, ist für mich gar nicht ein Operator, sondern es handelt sich um Syntax Sugar für die Abkürzung der Funktion add. So, ja, das heißt, man müsste halt immer schreiben können, add, Klammer auf, a, b und die andere Variante ist halt einfach hinzuschreiben a plus b. Aber funktional sollte es dasselbe sein.
So, jetzt kommt mein Vorschlagargument.
Ja, warte noch kurz ab.
Warte nur ein Weilchen.
Warte nur ein Weilchen, wenn a und b irgendwie was beliebiges sein kann. Wie alles First Class Objects sind, die ich mit Funktionen bearbeiten kann. Herr Clemens schon ganz gut recht. Sehe ich halt auch nicht ein, warum ich auf einen Staubsauger nicht auch eins draufaddieren könnte, was auch immer das in der Welt der Staubsauger bedeuten mag.
Ein Staubsauger plus zwei Staub sind?
Na, ja.
Dann darf jetzt auch nicht Operator Overloading mit Problemorphism verwechseln.
Das ist auch noch ein anderer Operator als plus.
Genau, und jetzt wird es nämlich spannend. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich die logischen Operatoren überlade? Weil in fast allen Sprachen ist es so, dass wenn du so ein If hast, und das If wird ausgewertet, sagen wir, If Ausdruck A, logischer Operator, und Ausdruck B. Wenn aus dem Ausdruck A ein False rauskommt, wird meistens der Ausdruck B nicht mehr ausgewertet. Aber wenn das Und in der Mitte ein überladener Operator ist, dann muss der Ausdruck B zuerst ausgewertet sein, weil er nämlich eingangswert für den überladenen Operator ist. Und da fängt's an unangenehm zu werden, weil du jetzt nämlich plötzlich nicht mehr sagen kannst, in welcher Reihenfolge wird eigentlich mein Ausdruck ausgewertet werden.
Aber Hody, wer macht denn sowas? Das sind total herbeifingierte Beispiele. Niemand wird sowas programmieren.
Darum geht's ja nicht.
Schön wär's, wenn du direkt hättest.
Also wirklich. Zum Beispiel ein Ruby, wo ja alles ein Object ist und auch die Operatoren alles Funktionen sind und es auch Operator-Overloading gibt, da müsste man, um das zu tun, müsste man halt auf dem Global Object sozusagen die Operators da umdefinieren. Macht aber niemand. Wenn jemand da irgendwelche Operators overloadet, dann immer lokal und für einen total sinnvollen Use-Case. Zum Beispiel, letztens erst gesehen, hat jemand Ist-Gleich-Ist-Gleich, also hier vergleichen, Gleich-Gleich, für also zwei Objekte und die zwei Objekte stellen eine Versionsnummer da, also Major-Minor-Patch. So und wenn du die Objekte jetzt so vergleichst, dann kommt halt totale Grütze dabei raus, weil du verstehst halt nicht größer, kleiner und dann implementierst du halt Ist-Gleich-Ist-Gleich auf diesem Objekt selber und implementierst das halt mit ja guck dir mal die drei Stellen an und vergleichst halt so und das ist total sinnvoll, finde ich gut. Will ich haben.
Macht den auch lesbar, was ja genau Sinn und Zweck der Aktion ist.
Sieht da auch plus?
Warum nicht?
Version 1.01 plus 0,9.
Plus drei Patchlevels.
Bei Swift gibt es jetzt was interessantes und zwar es gibt den Gleich-Gleich-Operator und den Gleich-Gleich-Gleich-Operator.
So wie den Punkt-Punkt-Punkt.
Manche sind gleicher als andere oder was?
Ja, der Gleich-Gleich-Gleich-Operator vergleicht, ob du wirklich das gleiche Objekt im Speicher hast. Nein, dasselbe. Wenn du noch Pointer hättest, pointen die auch.
Ist der Unterschied zwischen das Gleiche und dasselbe?
Also der Gleich-Gleich- und derselben. Man könnte ihn Selboperator nennen.
Absolut sinnvoll, gibt's auch in anderen Sprachen.
Man kann vorher das Pointer vergleichen.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, funktionieren die Dictionaries und die Arrays aber auch so, dass du denen, wenn du eigene Objekte machen willst und das ordentlich funktionieren soll, dass du tatsächlich den Gleich-Gleich-Operator überladen musst. Beziehungsweise Sort-Algorithmen und so weiter. Also es ist...
Du hast gerade gesagt, Operator Overloading für Sort-Algorithmen. Da ham wa wieder.
Aber dass das jetzt alles... Ich meine, es gibt ja eine grundsätzliche Einschränkung für Swift im Design. Nämlich die Anforderung einerseits, dass es halt so ein bisschen, naja, also es sollte halt in seinem Language-Design bzw. auch in seiner... Na, ich lass das mal raus. Die grundsätzliche Kompatibilitätsanforderung ist, muss mit derselben Rantime laufen. Es muss Rantime-kompatibel sein zur Objective-See. Und ich frage mich jetzt, ob du Stellen gefunden hast, wo du dir gesagt hast, ähm, tja, wäre schön, wenn man den Klotz jetzt nicht unbedingt am Bein hat. Ich meine, warum das so ist, ist ja vollkommen klar. Aber wäre schön, wenn man da diese Bedingungen nicht gehabt hätte, weil da hätte man ja mal was Modernes machen können. Also ich frage mich halt, wie modern ist diese Sprache?
Ja, da hab ich vorhin schon gesagt, sag mal, was für dich modern ist bei der Sprache.
Ja, also zum Beispiel so Funktionen in Objekten finde ich ja schon irgendwie seit 20 Jahren vollkommen.
Wie Funktionen in Objekten?
Ja, so Methoden in Objekten, also das Klassen ihre eigenen Methoden haben, halte ich halt...
Ja, aber das macht doch eine Klasse aus.
Nein.
Jetzt kommt Tim wieder mit seinem dünnen Beispiel, das halt, wie war das mit dem Sex und dem...
Ja, aber es ist keine funktionale Programmiersprache. Also, aber das hat ja auch nichts mit modern zu tun. Also entweder hast du halt eine objektorientierte, wie auch immer man das Wort definiert, Programmiersprache, oder aber du hast eine funktionale Programmiersprache. Aber jetzt zu sagen, Funktional wäre modern und objektorientiert riecht, also...
Nein, nein, das hat jetzt mit Funktionalen nichts zu tun. Du kannst Funktional und objektorientiert sagen, gleichzeitig, das ist ja nicht das Problem. Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Aspekte. Nichts aber.
Ich hab deine Frage aber immer noch nicht verstanden. Glaub ich.
Ja, ich weiß, dass diese Debatte auch nicht weit führt, aber es ist halt immer so eine Annahme, wie du das auch so schön gesagt hast. Es gibt so sehr viele Leute, sehr viele Programmierer nebenan, dass eine Klasse sich vor allem dadurch auszeichnet, dass sie Methoden hat.
Und Encapsulation, dass sie halt den State encapsulated und die Methoden, um den State innerhalb zu modifizieren, halt alles in sich bondelt und nicht halt nach außen.
Ja und ich finde halt...
So ist der inzwischen klassische Weg, wie man objektorientiert beschreibt, oder? Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich da auch ein Holzweg.
Ja, gibt es auch durchaus, in mir sprach es halt nicht so mal.
Ja, aber so Encapsulation ist schon ein cooles Feature, finde ich zum Beispiel. Bei Objektorientierung dazu gehört für mich auch, dass der State gefälligst im Objekt modifiziert wird und nicht von außen.
Du kannst zwar alles encapsulaten, aber du musst ja nicht gezwungen werden, das in der Klasse selber abzulegen. Du kannst ja deine Funktion, deine Methoden nach wie vor in ein eigenes Modul packen, da sind sie wunderbar encapsulated. Dann kommt es immer noch beim Laden des Moduls alles mit, aber deswegen musst du noch lange nicht die Methode auch im Objekt selber vorhalten. Also ich sage mal so, die meisten Objekte, die du modellierst, wissen nicht, was sie mit sich selbst tun sollen, sondern sie bekommen Dinge mit sich getan.
Also du könntest diese Art, wie du gerade beschrieben hast zu programmieren, durchaus mit Swift machen, aber das gesamte Coco Framework macht es anders.
Ja, ich weiß, darauf wollte ich ja darauf hinaus.
Und das hat aber jetzt erstmal nichts mit der Runtime zu tun.
Ja, gut, Runtime und natürlich das Framework. Das sind beides diese Bedingungen. Das habe ich jetzt quasi so in eins reingeworfen.
Meinst du, dass Swift wird sich genauso, wie soll man sagen, von den Programmierern, von den Apple und iOS Programmierern übernommen, so wie Objective-C. Weil Objective-C ist ja dafür, dass es eigentlich nur auf dem Apple geht. Ist ja eigentlich ganz gut durchgestartet, oder? Also es geht weiterhin nur auf dem Apple, bis auf dieses, wie heißt der andere?
GNU, irgendwas.
Genau, habe ich sogar mal benutzt für Linux, aber naja.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Objective-C ist ja schon cool mit C-Mischen, ist ja schon auch ein cooles Feature.
Ja, im Prinzip kannst du Swift auch immer noch mit C-Mischen, also kannst du ja tatsächlich C-Funktionen aufrufen, das geht ja. Das ist ein bisschen painful, da muss man dann das zweite Buch lesen und dann denkt man, oh Gott, eigentlich will ich es halt gar nicht so genau wissen. Also, die Core-Foundation-Sachen ist noch okay, aber echte C-Funktionen, glaub, das will man dann auch nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung. Also, ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass man... Also, viele Sachen, die in C geschrieben sind, haben für andere Sprachen Language Bindings, die gut funktionieren. Und ich denke nicht, dass der Vorteil von Objective C, dass man das C jetzt direkt aufrufen kann, noch so viel gilt heutzutage.
Überhaupt nicht. Das ist alles vollkommen überfällig gewesen, dieser Move zu Swift. Ich finde es großartig, dass sie Ballast abschmeißen. Mir ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie viel Ballast jetzt wirklich abgeworfen wurde. Meiner Meinung nach wäre da noch sehr viel mehr abzuwerfen. Aber ich verstehe auch, dass das nicht abwerfbar war, weil sie natürlich ab einem bestimmten Punkt ihre Rückwärtskompatibilität zu ihrem eigenen Framework verlieren würden. Und natürlich werden auch in fünf Jahren noch Leute Objective C programmieren. Und vor allem, allein weil sie Libraries machen, die noch mit Alpencode und das haben sie halt gelernt.
Apples selber wahrscheinlich sogar.
Ja, das wird zum Beispiel schon mal eine interessante Frage. Wann Apple dazu übergeht, intern alles Neue nur noch in Swift zu machen?
Also momentan sieht es ja so aus, als wäre die Vor- und Zurückkompatibilität so gut, dass es dann auch egal ist.
Ja gut, aber sie wollen ja diesen Produktivitätsgewinn auch selber umsetzen. Das würde ihnen ja beim Framework entwickeln enorm weiterhelfen, wenn sie jetzt mit einer moderneren Sprache arbeiten.
Natürlich, du kannst heutzutage auch noch Objective-C und Coco mit manueller Memory-Reference-Counting machen, wo du deine Retains und Releases alle per Hand machst. Kannst du machen. Gibt sogar Leute, habe ich neulich einen Blogpost gelesen, die schwören da drauf, weil es angeblich so viel schneller ist.
Man kann auch alles in Assembler schreiben.
Was ich meine ist, das ist halt kompatibel. Du kannst also immer noch ein Framework mit manuellem Reference-Counting machen und kannst mit ARK drauf zugreifen. Insofern, solange nicht Apple sagt, okay, wir unterstützen es nicht mehr, dass ihr Objective-C aufruft, von Swift aus oder Swift aufruft von Objective-C, solange, weiß ich nicht, ist die Frage... Ja, also ich meine, eine große Code-Basis neu schreiben, das will man eigentlich nie.
Ja gut, aber wenn sie jetzt Neues angehen und sie werden auch weiterhin Neues angehen und jetzt komplett neue Frameworks schreiben, nachdem wir schon alle immer gejabst haben. Ich meine, nehmen wir mal Audio. Jetzt haben sie irgendwie diese AV-Engine da gebaut. Ein erster Schritt ist gemacht. Da wird uns wahrscheinlich noch eine Menge einfallen, was sonst noch so gehen könnte. Auf Basis dieser Audio-Engine. Die Grundvoraussetzung dafür ist sowieso 10.8. Sie müssen da gar keine Rückwärtskompatibilität mehr leisten. Das ist vielleicht ein blödes Beispiel, weil das ist jetzt schon neu geschrieben worden, wahrscheinlich in Objective-C und bla. Aber es kommt irgendein anderes High-Level-Ding, was wir schon immer mal haben wollten. Keine Ahnung, irgendein cooles Framework, mit dem du irgendwie in drei Zeilen dein PDF zusammengekritzelt bekommst. Oder was weiß ich, das gibt es ja auch schon.
Um deine Frage mal ein bisschen anders zu beantworten. Es gibt in Swift so gut wie nichts, was nicht ein direktes Objective-C-Äquivalent hat, was jetzt Klassen und vor allen Dingen auch Protokolle. Du kannst halt so Sachen machen, wie in Swift ein Protokoll machen für eine Klasse. Diese Klasse muss die und die Funktion implementieren. Und kannst dann von Objective-C aus sagen, meine Klasse conforms to this Protokoll. Und dann musst du die implementieren. Das kannst du hin und zurück in nur bestimmte Protokolle, aber es geht. Der ist doch auch gut. Wieso?
Das ist rückständig.
Also ich finde, wir haben bei C++ alle gesehen, was multiple inheritance uns schöne Dinge bringt. Das wollen wir nicht haben.
Weil C++ scheiße ist, wenn du das richtig umsetzt, in der richtigen Sprache, dann geht das auch. Du hast sehr viel gain, weil du keine Protokolle mehr selbst programmieren musst, für jede Klasse, die dir entsprechen muss. Du programmierst einmal das Protokoll und erbst es einfach rein. Fertig.
Wenn das so einfach wäre.
Ich bin eher für Mixins als für multiple inheritance.
Das ist ja dasselbe an der Stelle. Also Mixing Classes machst du halt am besten darüber.
Na gut, lassen wir das. Wollen wir noch ein bisschen fighten?
Ich wollte ja jetzt...
Ich will zwei Fragen nur stellen.
Ich wollte jetzt nur noch mal in der 72. Minute einen Spieler bringen, der dich einfach in deiner Systematik einfach total aus dem Tritt bringt.
Du, ich hab noch einen Spieler in der Hinterhand. Den wechsel ich gleich an.
Zwei Publikumsfragen. Erstens, was ist mit Concurrency?
Nichts explizites in der Sprache. Du hast halt die netten Sachen wie diese Konstanten, die ja schon mal viel nützen können, nicht unbedingt müssen.
Aber du hast keine Threads. Du benutzt deinen Grand Central Dispatch über Coco.
Du hast nach wie vor deinen Grand Central Dispatch, was übrigens nicht Coco ist, sondern nochmal eine Lage tiefer.
Gibt es ja auch als FreeBSDC-Library.
Aber da kannst du halt Closures reinwerfen.
Und das ist da irgendwie auch schon erwiesen, dass das jetzt so geht.
Die Sprache macht die Nutzung des selben...
Sie haben es zumindest im Vortrag erwähnt, dass es doch wie gemacht sei, dafür das...
Okay, zweite Frage, Error Handling.
Genau, das war mein Geheimspieler, den ich einwechseln wollte. In dem Buch gibt es keine Erwähnung von Exceptions. Ich weiß nicht, ob es sie gibt und sie das nur aus dem vorgelassen haben.
Kannst du mal irgendwie einfach in dein Playground ein Stück kaputten Code reinkippen?
Also es gibt Runtime Errors, davon sprechen sie immer wieder, aber es gibt nicht wirklich Exceptions. Also es gibt in dem Buch keine Anleitung zu sagen, das ist das Throw-Kommando und hier ist Try Catch.
Ja, Exceptions werden hier nur im Trademark-Bereich.
Immerhin.
Also entweder wollen sie sich da noch bedeckt halten, oder das ist ein bold move, wo sie sagen, ja vielleicht war Exceptions halt doch mal eine dumme Idee irgendwann in den 90ern. Und wir machen das jetzt mal anders.
Also bei Objectivs, die auch schon keiner benutzt, außer Java-Programmierer, die umgestiegen sind.
Aber das ist ja auch so ein schöner Streitpunkt. Ich bin ja eher so der No Exception Guy. Aber andere Leute machen lieber alles mit Exceptions. Am besten finde ich ja Python. Was passiert, wenn du einen Syntax-Fehler in einem Python-Dokument hast? Du bekommst eine Exception. Und jetzt frage ich mich, was soll das? Erwarten die von einem, dass man da einen Try Catch drum macht, so nachdem ich jetzt die Funktion in einem einen Dokument aufrufe und wenn ich eine Exception kriege, na gut, dann versuche ich es halt aus einer Funktion aus einem anderen Dokument. Also ich meine, was soll das?
Das wird dein Programm nicht unbedingt terminiert und du hast die Möglichkeit, eine graceful Termination zu machen. Das finde ich schon vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also schreibst du dann Error Handling, ist doch am Ende genau das Gleiche.
Also ich will nicht ewig mit den alten Zoten kommen, aber bei Dillon zum Beispiel, was ja auch von Apple kommt, da ging das sogar noch weiter mit den Exceptions. Da waren Exceptions eine Sonderform eines übergeordneten Konzepts und das heißt Conditions und das war sozusagen so richtig in die Sprache rein gedacht, dass sozusagen Fehler so normal sind, dass du sie nicht nur abfangen kannst. Nein, du kannst sie sogar beheben und den Code-Teil nochmal neu starten unter geänderten Bedingungen. Ohne, dass der eigentliche Code selber davon irgendetwas gesehen hat. Das heißt, du schreibst da irgendwie eine Datei, dann ist die Platte voll, dann fängst du diese Exception ab, sagst, ich tu jetzt was, damit die Platte nicht mehr voll ist und dann sagst du Restart und dann macht er einfach weiter und du hast genau einen Nullzeilen-Code an dieser Stelle, wo geschrieben wird, die in irgendeiner Form etwas zu tun hat.
Genau das ist ja das Problem. Du versteckst ja nur das Error-Handling, aber es ist nicht weniger Error-Handling, sondern da kommen wir wieder zur Code-Readability. Du handelst den Fehler an einer Stelle, wo er nicht aufgetreten ist und es ist völlig unklar, was passiert? Weil es nicht mehr offensichtlich ist. Weil dein Fehler-Handling plötzlich an einer total merkwürdigen Stelle ist. Du hast halb gebaute Objekte, die irgendwie abgeräumt oder nicht abgeräumt werden. Den Code testet ja auch keiner. Was passiert eigentlich an der Stelle von dem Code, wenn die und die Exception fällt?
Aber ich finde, es klingt so, als werdet ihr einfach total gebrannte Kinder von dieser Objective-C-Welt und ihr habt noch gar nicht gesehen, das ist eine An- oder so. Klar, ihr habt da schon so ein paar Brandeisen irgendwie auf die Arschbacken bekommen. Aber es gibt echt Sprachen. Es gibt auch so Wiesen und Wälder, die irgendwie ganz hübsch sind, wo das total super funktioniert und nicht irgendwie nur mit, wenn man tausend Stück davon benutzt, dann erst funktioniert das.
Da muss ich sagen, finde ich aber, dass Erlang, die Erlang-Herangehensweise nach, naja, dann stirbt der halt einfach der Prozess und dann starte ich den neu.
Erlang ist auch hochgradig fehlerresistent durch Behandlung von Fehlern. Nur, dass sie halt in ihrem Framework schon standardmäßig auch sogar schon ein Handling der Fehler mit drin haben.
Ja, aber nicht über Exceptions.
Naja, also ich würde das in Erlang tatsächlich schon eher so in diese Exception-Ecke einordnen, weil deine ganze Runtime crasht ja nicht einfach so.
Das heißt da jetzt nicht Exceptions, sondern das heißt halt anders, weil einfach Erlang an der Stelle ganz anders funktioniert.
Error. Das Problem ist glaube ich, dass die Art, wie Exceptions verwendet werden, gerne mal inflationär ist. Weil Exception heißt Ausnahme und nicht Regel. Und es gibt halt Leute, die geben halt sonst was mit Exceptions zurück, was halt nicht eine Exception ist, sondern halt ein Return Value. Und plattevoll ist halt auch kein Ausnahmezustand, sondern es ist was, was ganz normal passieren kann.
Ja, aber wenn dir bei McDonald's einer einen schwarzen Hamburger auf den Tisch legt und du sagst was ist denn das hier, schwarzer Hamburger? Und der schaut dich an wie was ist denn das hier? Ja, verstehst du, dann haben wir einfach kein ordentliches Exception-Handing am Start. So, Fehler kann man nicht ignorieren, weil Fehler passieren laufend, dauernd, immer, überall, permanent. Und die beste Methode, das irgendwie abzufangen, ist ein System zu haben. Ich sag gar nicht mal Programmiersprache, es kann irgendwas sein, was einfach zumindest mit dem Auftreten von Fehlern grundsätzlich schon mal klarkommt. Da kann das ignorieren, dieses Thema ist ja nicht sein. Hier ist immer noch irgendwie If-Result gleich minus eins, denn, tra la la, da ist alles überall If. Du, du weißt, was der Erfinder von Erlang gesagt hat, wenn dein Programm ein If enthält, ist es wahrscheinlich, enthält es wahrscheinlich einen Fehler.
Ja gut, aber es ist halt auch Erlang.
Er hat recht, ich meine, was Roddy meint, ist halt, klar, die Kehrseite der Medaille, das sind Leute, die für Flow-Control missbrauchen. Das war so ihr ganzes Programm Flow-Controllen mit Exceptions. Und ja, wenn jetzt hier der Wert nicht eins oder null ist, dann ist es halt nicht irgendwie eine normale Case-Statement, sondern ein Throw-Wish is not one exception. Also ich hab schon auch kurz gesehen, wo die irgendwie vergessen haben, dass es If- oder Case-Statements gibt und irgendwie alles nur noch mit Rescues und so weiter geregelt oder Try-and-Catch-Aber...
Aber das ist doch das Ding, also die Error-Handling und Exceptions, die führen doch beide zum Ziel, die einen machen so, die anderen machen so. Die Frage ist doch, was halt besser angenommen wird und später besser lesbar ist.
Aber ich sag auch, wenn ihr eine Sprache wie Objective-C kennt oder C++, die jetzt beides, für mich zumindest, die ich ja anders gewohnt bin, keine Könige der Lesbarkeit sind, und man dann sowieso wahrscheinlich... ganz furchtbar. Aber für euch ist das halt normal. Und für euch ist dann halt auch wiederum noch normal, dass Exceptions halt bare sind. Für mich, wo ich aus einer anderen Welt komme, ist das eigentlich auch ganz schön.
Ich glaub auch dieses C und vor allem dieses C++, das hat einfach wirklich viele Leute in so eine Denke versetzt, dass bestimmte Dinge einfach falsch sind. Wie zum Beispiel Multiple Inheritance ist böse, weil in C++ macht das alles kaputt. Ja, macht das, das macht in C++ alles kaputt. I totally agree, aber das ist ein C++-Problem. Kein Problem von Multiple Inheritance. Also die Konzepte werden für irgendwas gescholten. Oder dass halt so Dinge immer so sein müssen, wie das Methoden in Klassen sein müssen. Das ist halt so ein Dogma. Das kriegst du irgendwie auch aus vielen Leuten überhaupt nicht rausdiskutiert, weil sie einfach das Konzept aufgibt.
In welcher Sprache ist das nicht so?
Noch nie anders.
Nee, die angewandt wird.
Ada.
Die wird auch angewandt.
Ganz tolle Sprache.
Du, die Ariane 5 ist mit Ada geflogen.
Die ist auch schon mal nicht geflogen mit.
Die ist schon mal aufs Maul geflogen.
Ja, die Ada-Jungs haben sich ursprünglich mal auf die Fahne geschrieben. Ein Ada-Programm, das kompiliert, ist korrekt. Weil alle Exceptions und so weiter. Du hast die Rakete abgestürzt. Seitdem behaupten sie es nicht mehr.
Und was war der Fehler? Haben sie wieder...
Sie haben falsche Module zusammengelinkt. Und irgendwie ein Modul hat einen Fehler als Input-Value verwendet und was weiß ich.
Also ich meine, eine Menge ist ja auch wie bei anderen Sachen Geschmackssache, oder ob man so eine Exceptions löst oder mit Error-Handling, ich denke immer.
Ja, dass wir jetzt die Sprache jetzt überhaupt gar keine Aussage dazu trifft, wie man Fehlerhandling irgendwie stream-lined. Das finde ich auch...
Na ja gut, ich meine, welches Fehlerhandling meinst du denn jetzt? Also es gibt halt, es gibt halt so ein...
Du rufst ein System-Core auf.
Es gibt einen katastrophalen Fehler, wie ich versuche, jenseits des Endes eines Arrays auf ein Objekt zuzugreifen. Das ist ein klarer Programmierfehler, da nimmt jedes Programm die Hufe hoch, das ist auch okay so. Du fix den Bug und es ist gut. Brauchst du keine Exceptions für. So, und der andere Fehler ist, dein System will dem User etwas sagen. Hallo, deine Platte ist voll. Und auch dafür brauchst du nicht unbedingt eine Exceptions, sondern da brauchst du ein Fehler-Objekt, was in der Lage ist, von deinem Programm an die Oberfläche deines Programms gepusht zu werden in irgendeinem Dialog oder dem User zu sagen, da ist jetzt deine Platte voll.
Das ist das Code, der sich darum kümmern muss, ob du über Error Handling oder Exception aufrufst, ist auch egal.
Die Frage ist, musst du an jeder Scheißstelle in deinem Programm, wo du irgendwie in eine Datei zwei Bytes schreibst, immer den vollen Klumpatsch von allen Möglichkeiten, die diese Schreiboperation an Resultaten bringen kann, reinschreiben? Oder hast du ein Framework in irgendeiner Form, also in der Sprache oder in einem Framework, was dir sowas abnimmt?
In Coco ist es zum Beispiel so, du bekommst bei der Schreiboperation ein NS-Error-Objekt zurück. Und dieses NS-Error-Objekt enthält so viel Information, dass du es über die Responder-Chain, wo normalerweise solche Dinge wie Klicks und so weiter fließen, in die Vio-Hierarchie deines Programmes einfügen kannst und es kommt hinterher so raus, dass deine Applikation von sich aus einen Dialog anzeigt.
Achso, der Fehler wird sozusagen global als Event zugestellt?
Am Ende muss man sich trotzdem darum kümmern.
Okay, wenn das Framework selber solche Sachen bereitstellt, ist das schon mal ein Ansatz.
Dann hast du natürlich noch so Sachen wie, du hast Netzwerkzugriff, du kriegst entweder nichts zurück oder das, was du zurücktust, tust du in deinen XML-Parser und der XML-Parser kann es nicht parsen und so weiter. Am Ende der Sache hast du entweder ein ordentlich geparstes XML oder es ist Mist bei rausgekommen. Ob du das jetzt über Exception löst oder nicht, auf jeden Fall musst du diese Information überhaupt über Thread-Grenzen hinweg woanders hin kommunizieren und ob du jetzt deine Exception fängst oder einen Return Code machst, um das dann über Thread-Grenzen woanders hin zu kommunizieren, das ist dann am Ende auch egal, weißt du? Also dieses ganze Exception-Ding, das funktioniert halt so lange, wie du Single-Threaded bist. Und wenn du großartig mit Multi-Threading anfängst, dann kannst du es sowieso knicken. Also das ist so... Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde, das ist ja weiter.
Da hast du noch mehr Punkte auf deiner Liste.
Das Einzige, was ich da noch habe, sind halt die Container oder Collection-Types. Das Dictionary funktioniert ungefähr so, wie man sich das vorstellt, aber beim Array ist einiges komisch. Also wenn man ein Dictionary hat und man weist dieses Dictionary einer Konstanten zu, dann hat man hinterher ein Immutable Dictionary. Alles schön und gut, so will man es haben. Aber das Array, wenn man das Array einer Konstanten zuweist, hat man plötzlich kein Immutable Array mehr. Man hat nur noch ein Array einer konstanten Größe. Man kann dann einzelne Werte austauschen, aber man darf die Größe nicht mehr ändern. Das ist völlig unklar, was das soll. Außerdem kannst du ein Array einer anderen Variable zugreifen, und es wird nur per Reference weitergegeben. Und du musst sagen, an share, wenn du willst, dass dieses Array plötzlich disjunkt ist zu dem Array, was du zugewiesen hast. Es ist völlig unklar, was das soll. Also sie schreiben irgendwas von... Na ja, ist halt schneller.
Hast du auch so einen Fiepen gerade im Ohr?
Dennis wedert hier.
Ja, der wedert immer.
Ihr seid alle doof.
Also das hatte ich noch unter...
Aber die Sprache ist ja auch noch beta, ne?
Die Sprache ist noch beta, ja.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie sehr die sich verinnert und vor allem bin ich gespannt, wie sehr sie jetzt bereits angenommen werden wird von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Ich denke, wer sich heute überlegt, mit iPhone-Programmierung anzufangen und dann guckt Objective-C oder lieber Swift, der wird vielleicht gleich zu Swift greifen, weil es ja kaum eine Sprache gibt, die ähnlich wie Objective-C ist. Also wer kann schon Smalltalk, ne? Ich auch nicht. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn wir sich mit diesen Unbequemheiten von C herumschlagen, da ist Swift auf jeden Fall die bessere Wahl. Wenn man jetzt, so wie ich, erst mal irgendwie fast ein ganzes Jahrzehnt Objective-C gemacht hat, dann ist es natürlich...
Der Nachteil ist natürlich, wenn du jetzt damit anfängst. Und du hast grundsätzlich Fragen zu, wie denn das so ist mit Coco und so. Dann musst du natürlich Millionen Code-Beispiele in Objective-C finden, aber halt genau gar keine in Swift. Und das ist natürlich schon...
Das ist auch ein Problem, die Millionen Code-Beispiele, die sind dann irgendwie aus Next-Step-Zeiten und auch alle voll überholt, so gesehen.
Aber die ganze Doku haben sie schon umgestellt. Es gibt immer ein Call-Beispiel für Swift und eins für Objective-C. Also da waren sie wirklich flocken.
Ja, das haben sie aber auch durch den Autogenerator durchgejagt, oder?
Wie sie es machen, ist ja deren Sache, aber sie haben es gemacht. Auf der anderen Seite finde ich es jetzt auch nicht so schwer zu lernen. Also ich glaube, wenn man wirklich das intensiv macht, hat man es in zwei Wochen drauf.
Ich habe im Chat übrigens der Hinweis, dass das angeblich hier dieses Array-Verhalten noch angepasst wird.
Haben wohl doch zu viele Leute geschrien.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt für dich auch das Spannende. Ich meine, dass der Lettner das entwickelt hat, ich meine, das gibt einem schon so das Gefühl, dass sie schon wissen, was sie tun.
Der Lettner weiß zumindest, wie man einen Compiler baut.
Ja, wenn man einen Compiler baut...
Du musst die Checkbox anklicken, Tim.
Ja, genau. Dann will man so eine... Scheiß User-Agreements, Scheiß-Tricks. Hier kommt eh nichts.
Was ist denn hier so was?
Jetzt brauche ich noch einen Screen nehmen. Der Lettner weiß schon, was er tut.
Ich glaube, das ist ein krasser Nerd.
Wir hören aktiv zu Feedback.
Niemand hat gelacht.
Das war schon eindeutig. Ich glaube, der ist wirklich ein krasser Nerd. So, was ich noch sagen wollte... Ach so, bist du fertig?
Ja, sag mal.
Sind wir noch bei WWDC? Ich habe vorhin geguckt, weil ihr habt gesagt, man kann diese Videos auch runterladen in HD. Ich dachte, ich lade die mal runter. Scheiße, ich musste alle einzeln klicken. Eigentlich, wenn ich die alle runtergeladen habe, später zu Hause, kann ich ein richtig geiles Pirate Bay Torrent draus machen. Ich dachte, ich gucke mal. Natürlich gibt es das Ding schon längst. Ich poste hier mal den Hashtab von. Damit kann man bei Pirate Bay suchen oder nach WWDC 2014. Das ist 30 GB groß. Dann klickt man einmal, dann kommen die alle rein. Dann hat man seine Ruhe. Ich mag das nicht einzeln klicken. Ich will die alle lokal da haben und will die gucken können, ohne dass es mittendrin ruckelt. Oder was auch immer. 30 GB HD und dann geht das einmal. Das wollte ich schon mal gesagt haben. Das habe ich hier live während der Sendung rausgefunden. Ist ja nicht, dass ich hier nur rumwäder, wenn ich nichts sage.
Wenn er wädert, ist er besonders aktiv.
Erhöht den Sauerstoff zur Uhr.
Der Turbolader saugt an. Hier wollte ich noch mal kurz über das Metal reden. Das ist in der letzten Sendung ein bisschen kurz gekommen. Der hat ja auch so tief aus den Schubladen erzählt, dass es nicht mehr Zeit für alles war. Auf Swift wurde ja dann doch ein bisschen schnell abgehandelt.
Swift war nur noch eine halbe Stunde.
Jedenfalls bei Metal wollte ich sagen, weil letztes Mal wurde gar nicht erwähnt, was es eigentlich genau ist, außer, dass es mit Grafikkarten zu tun hat. Und dass Gernot meinte, dass er denkt, dass es nur für den A8 kommt, also für die Grafikeinheit in der CPU des nächsten iPhones. Dazu kann ich natürlich auch nichts sagen. Aber Metal ist halt ein Ersatz für OpenGL, aber auch nicht direkt ein Ersatz an OpenGL. Da könnte man als Grafik-Schnittstelle mehr so High-Level betrachten. Und das Metal ist mehr so Assembler, würde ich glatt mal sagen. Ein bisschen. Nicht genau. Also schon gar keine Commands oder so. Aber ich weiß, dass es halt von AMD auf dem PC gibt es halt einen Mental-Treiber seit Anfang des Jahres. Mental, der heißt da Mental. M-A-S-T-L-E. Und die meinten, damit kriegt man halt mehr Draw-Calls pro Sekunde hin als mit OpenGL oder mit auch hier, was heißt das von Microsoft, DirectX 11 oder 12, wo sind die inzwischen? Keine Ahnung. Und dann gab es von denen nämlich auch, und ich denke, es ist sehr vergleichbar, gab es das erste Spiel, was, glaube ich, auf dem PC rauskam, was diese Mental-Unterstützung hat, hieß Battlefield 4. Und laut den Benchmarks, die es da so gibt, ist es so, dass wenn man halt eine sehr hohe Auflösung nimmt und die CPU wirklich viel, viel zu tun hat, dann holt man mit diesem Mental-Treiber eine Menge raus. Also es ging bis 30% schnellere Framerates. Nee, von Mental noch. Es ist nicht das gleiche, aber es ist ähnlich. Also ich denke, das ist das Metal von AMD auf dem Desktop. Also die gehen sozusagen jetzt von OpenGL weg oder halt von DirectX und machen halt so ihr eigenes Ding. Wie weit sie damit kommen, ist halt unklar. Also ich hab das Gefühl, auf dem iPhone hat Apple da eigentlich noch mehr Chancen, weil da gibt's halt nur das von Apple. Auf dem Desktop hast du halt OpenGL und DirectX und da weiß ich nicht, ob die Spielehersteller Bock haben, ihre Engines alle irgendwie jetzt für drei Sachen zu schreiben. Also weil du musst ja die schon ein bisschen umschreiben. Aber das ist halt das Ding, das halt mit Mental oder mit Metal auf dem iOS, dass du halt mehr Calls pro Sekunde hinkriegst und du kannst niedriger auf die GPU zugreifen und musst da nicht so high-levelmäßig rangehen. Da kannst du eine Menge Overhead sparen.
Wie ist denn das, diese ganzen Konsolen, was für Schnittstellen unterstützen die denn? Ja, weil das wär halt noch interessant.
PlayStation hat bestimmt was ganz Eigenes.
Ja, aber ich meine...
Und die Xbox hat natürlich DirectX, würde ich mal behaupten, in irgendeiner abgespeckten oder aufgepumpten Form. Weiß nicht genau was. Und ich denke mal die Steambox, die macht, glaube ich, die wird ja weiterhin diese Steam-Spiele machen und die machen ja da auch OpenGL, oder?
Nee, ich frage deshalb, weil wenn du als Spielhersteller eine Engine baust und du musst sowieso zwei Apis unterstützen, dann kannst du auch eine dritte unterstützen, glaube ich.
Ja, aber Bock haben die da nicht so drauf, oder?
Naja, ich meine, Apple hatte irgendwie vier Engine-Hersteller irgendwie an der Hand. Da Crytek und die Unreal-Jungs. Und hast du nicht gesehen, also es sah jetzt nicht so aus, als würde das so direkt ein Rohr-Krepierer werden.
Nee, das mental wie gesagt. Also 30% Framerate irgendwie schneller, dann dauert es nicht lange, dann wollen die Gamer das. Also die Frame-Hit ist ja das A und O. Nur von Nvidia hört man da auch noch nichts. Also wie gesagt, das gibt es nur von AMD. Was Nvidia da bringt, ist noch nicht so klar. Aber ich denke, die werden da auch mit irgendwas kommen. Und es kann wirklich passieren, dass am Ende DirectX und OpenGL irgendwie gar keine Rolle mehr spielen, sondern gibt es für jeden Grafikersteller, bringt sein eigenes Ding da mit. Und ja, keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich genau das, was Apple auch an der Stelle verhindern will, indem sie ihr Metal rausbringen.
Indem sie einfach ihr eigenes bringen. Die Frage ist, ob sie das Metal auch vielleicht noch für OS X bringen. Und das mit dem OpenCL haben sie es ja schon mal geschafft. Das AMD hatte ja Stream. Nvidia hatte dieses Cuda. Und Apple hat gesagt, hey Jungs, hier geht alles gar nicht. Könnt ihr voll vergessen, machen wir nicht mit. Wir wollen gerne OpenCL, damit wir euch demnächst weiterhin schöne Gegner ausstechen können. Und das hat ja auch funktioniert. Und ich denke, OpenCL ist eine gute Sache geworden. Und hat was gemacht. Und wenn sie vielleicht cool sind, machen sie es mit Metal aus. Also sagen, wir wollen jetzt hier ein Low-Level-Interface auf Grafikkarten. Aber es muss ja gar nicht nur für einen Hersteller sein. Sondern es kann ja auch, kann man sich ja auch was für alle überlegen. Aber dann ist es halt schon wieder nicht so schick angepasst, wie jetzt auf dem iOS. Erstmal für diesen A8. Weil da können sie ja wirklich genau die Feature so machen, wie der Chip, die er halt auch bietet. Wenn du schon wieder mehrere GPUs von verschiedenen Herstellern supporten willst, muss es ja wieder ein bisschen breitflächiger werden.
Also, unter Mac OS gibt es das nicht. Ich hätte das so verstanden, als gäbe es das Metal da.
Metal ist jetzt erstmal nur für iOS 8 und nur für den A7.
Also ihre eigene Software, also ihre eigene Schnittstelle für ihre eigene GPU, was sie ja auf dem OS X nicht haben, weil sie ja keine eigene Hardware haben.
Noch nicht.
Die Frage ist, wo kommt das halt noch zum Einsatz? Es ist klar, das iPhone 5 ist ja jetzt quasi damit schon unterstützt.
Du meinst 5S.
Was auch immer jetzt 5S, richtig, das iPhone 5S ist damit unterstützt.
iPad Air und iPad Mini Retina.
Genau, aber sagen wir mal so die aktuelle Top-Notch-Generation, die jetzt seit knapp einem Jahr verkauft wird und auch in nennenswerten Mengen draußen ist und so für High-End-Spiele auf jeden Fall auch so ein Target ist, so ein Potenzielles, das kann das halt schon mal. Was auch immer sie jetzt im Herbst Neues rausbringen, wird das natürlich auch alles können, weil es entweder auf A7 basiert oder eben auf A8 oder wie das Teil dann auch immer heißen mag. Und damit haben sie natürlich dann, ich weiß nicht, wie viele populäre 3D-Engines gibt es denn überhaupt, außer den vieren, die sie da schon als Unterstützer bekannt gegeben haben?
War da idz Software dabei? Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Die haben die ja verkauft an Bethesda oder wie die heißen, oder? Ja, hatten sie, bis sie sie verkauft haben. Ja, die auch andere nutzen, meine ich.
Ja, sicher.
Das Quakespiel war immer der Demonstrator für ihre Engine. Danach kamen dann die ganzen Spiele, die waren alle auf Quake Engine. Dann gibt es noch hier, Unreal war die andere. Dann kam vor ein paar Jahren hier Crytek irgendwie mit ihrem Zeug raus. Dann Electronic Arts hat jetzt irgendwie noch einen. Dann gibt es noch Unity-Engines. Dann gibt es halt noch Engine für...
Bei Electronic Arts ist eigentlich die Unreal Engine gewesen.
Oder immer noch.
Bei Electronic Arts ist jetzt auch in dieser Liste dabei. Also das Unity war dabei. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, sie haben schon im Wesentlichen die Marktführer. Vielleicht fehlt da noch einer. Die meisten Spielehersteller, Spieleprogrammierer schreiben ihre eigene Engine. Die benutzen halt eine, die schon da ist. Die dann angepasst ist. In dem Moment, wo sie die Engines mit Metal verheiraten, haben sie im Prinzip schon gewonnen.
Im Prinzip ja. Ich glaube, dass das Engine-Schreiben inzwischen so komplex geworden ist, dass du eigentlich das gar nicht mehr realistisch selbst machen kannst, sondern eine lizenzieren musst. Wir wissen ja auch nicht, was dahinter steckt. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass Apple gesagt hat, ihr kriegt für ein Jahr 20 Mann. Die machen das bei euch im Laden. Und wir bezahlen alles.
Ich weiß das, und das weiß ich nicht von Hucke, dass die Unity benutzen. Auch.
Was baut Apple als nächstes? Bauen sie Apple TV mit dem A7?
Na ja, wenn sie ihn quasi als Spielkonsole haben wollen. Also viele Bausteine hätten sie jetzt. Sie haben eine performante Engine, also eine performante 3D-Layer. Sie haben Controller-Unterstützung in iOS drin. Na ja, eine funktionierende App-Store haben sie sowieso. Weiß ich nicht, also eigentlich sind alle Bausteine da, die sie brauchen, um morgen das Teil auf den Tisch zu legen und sagen, hier, Nintendo, Peer, Connectivity, Bluetooth. Also ja, ich meine, es wäre logisch für Apple, jetzt diesen Schritt zu tun. Sie haben jetzt alles in Verdacht.
Hat nicht auch irgendwer geschrieben, dass es auch Sinn machen würde, wenn dieses Gerät dann gleichzeitig auch noch die HomeKit-Basis-Station ist? Ich glaube, Apple ist ganz schön fies. Die bauen drumherum alles fertig. Alle sehen es schon kommen, aber es kommt und kommt nicht, bis sie wirklich alles so perfekt fertig haben. Und dann schalten sie per Software eigentlich nur noch das Apple-TV frei, dass es zur Konsole wird. Und dann macht es Peng, und dann ist es da und schneller, als man dann doch irgendwie dachte. Und dann gucken alle doof. Könnte aber auch sein, dass einfach gar nichts passiert die nächsten Jahre, weil die gar keinen Bock auf Konsolen haben. Das weiß man eben nicht, aber für die anderen ist es, glaube ich, ganz schön fies.
Ich glaube, dass Apple den Markt, wenn dann nicht in der üblichen Konsolenschweinezyklusart angehen würde, wie wir haben jetzt Apple-Konsole 1, und in fünf Jahren gibt es Apple-Konsole 2, sondern da gibt es halt dann jedes Jahr, gibt es dann halt die Apple-Konsole, die aktuelle.
Und wird halt immer schneller und besser.
Und wird immer schneller und besser. Und das ist eigentlich auch immer das gleiche System.
Aber das ist doch genau auch der Grund an den Konsolen. Du hast da so ein Gerät, da kommen Spiele für raus. Und ich meine, die holen ja aus diesen Konsolen auch raus, wie früher auf dem 64er, was du halt nie geglaubt hast, was man aus dieser Konsole rausholen würde. Und das werden die da mit Apple nie machen. Weil holt euch doch einfach die schnellere, wenn es euch nicht schnell genug ist. Da wird dann nie halt so Top-Notch-Zeug für rauskommen. Ob das natürlich am Ende doch vielleicht besser ist, weil du immer die schnellste Konsole hast, weiß ich nicht. Aber es macht schon auch Sinn, halt so eine Konsole bis an die letzten Grenzen auszureizen.
Einerseits ja. Andererseits im PC-Markt funktioniert es ja auch.
Mit jedes Jahr neue Kisten oder so?
Es gibt alle halbe Jahre neue Grafikkarte. Und du hast halt das Spiel, wenn du nicht die neueste hast, dann fährst du da irgendwelche Regler runter, dann sieht es nicht mehr so toll aus, aber du kannst es spielen. Also, das ist halt eine andere Herangehensweise. Aber also, spricht nichts dagegen meiner Meinung nach, dass Apple in den Konsolenmarkt einsteigt.
Sie haben es auf jeden Fall schon ein paar Mal gezeigt, dass es so ein Markt, der dachte, eigentlich alles so in der Hand zu haben, mal kräftig umzukrempeln.
Ja, und alle werden gesagt haben, ja, das machen sie nie, bis sie das dann irgendwann mal machen.
Dann will ich noch was kurz erzählen zu WWDC. Ist jetzt nicht so spannend, aber hau ich mal raus. Und zwar gab es ja hier dieses Yosemite Beta. Und viele haben es installiert. Und ich hab auch geschrieben, glaube ich, per Twitter, wie ich installiere jetzt gleich oder bin jetzt dabei. Und dann schrieb einer gleich zurück, ja, bei ihm geht es nicht, weil er kommt nach dem Booten nicht mehr hoch. Hatte ich dann erstmal nicht, bei mir ging es. Aber irgendwie habe ich dann mal wieder gedacht, ja, ist ja mal wieder ein neues Update. Mein Trim ist bestimmt nicht an und habe den Trim-Enabler gestartet. Und dann dachte ich, ah, nee, schlechte Idee. Ich mache das mal nicht, ich lasse das mal aus und habe das Programm wieder geschlossen. Aber ich hatte es schon einmal angemacht und dann dachte ich, nein, lieber doch nicht und wieder ausgemacht. Dann war auch erstmal, okay, es lief weiter. Aber als ich dann irgendwann gebootet habe, aus irgendeinem Grund, weil das GUI dann doch irgendwie fing in der Feinde an rumzuzicken, dachte ich, ich boote mal. Und dann kam die Kiste nicht mehr, auch nicht so scheiße. War auch gerade nicht zu Hause, konnte nichts machen. Dachte, kacke, kacke, kacke. Und dann habe ich gegoogelt und gemacht und getan und mit den Rechnern von anderen Leuten, die weiter noch surfen konnten und so habe ich dann rausgefunden, man muss irgendein, ja was war es eigentlich, im Parameterrem muss man halt so ein, so ein Def, Tralala, irgendwie, dass so irgendwie Kecks nicht mehr gecheckt werden, weil da werden jetzt, bei Yosemite werden die Colonel Extensions gegen eine Signatur gecheckt. Und wenn die nicht okay ist und auch deine Colonel Extensions nicht auf so einer Exception-List steht, wo die halt weit, wie heißt es? Gewidelistet ist, dann bootet dein Colonel nicht mehr und du siehst aber auch nicht, was das Problem ist. Jedenfalls hab ich geguckt und das von Treminabler, die Colonel Extensions, die war's noch nicht mal, weil ich hab's ja gar nicht gemacht. Also an der lag's nicht, ich weiß nicht, warum es sich plötzlich aktiviert hat. Jedenfalls musste ich dieses Parameter-Ram setzen, dass das Signatur nicht mehr gecheckt wird und ich musste einmal den Colonel Cache irgendwie neu machen, dass der checkt, was da gewidelistet ist und was nicht.
Mit Stift starten, oder?
Mit diesem Emergency-Modus, genau. Single-User würde, glaub ich, auch gehen, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Der Wissen ist auch, dass es im Apple-Dokument für Yosemite, ich weiß nicht, ob's erst dann in dem Update mit drin stand, weil da stand genau das drin, was ich vorher gemacht hatte, oder ob das in dem ersten Dokument auch schon drin stand, was ich natürlich nicht gelesen hab, wie immer, wer liest schon Doku und so. Aber ja, das hat auf jeden Fall geholfen. Und die Info war auch von dem Typen, der den Trimmy-Enabler schreibt, weil der hat halt den ganzen Ärger bekommen, weil alle Rechner mit Trimmy-Enabler, die konnten nicht richtig booten. Und der hat auch geschrieben, ey, Jungs, hier so und so müsst ihr das machen. Und ich glaube, inzwischen hat er auch schon gesagt, dass der Trimmy-Enabler nämlich funktioniert, ohne dass er was umschreiben muss. Man muss halt nur dieses Ding aktivieren, dass seine Extension da irgendwie dann auch zugelassen wird. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum es nicht geht. Ansonsten ist es wohl sogar gerade kompatibel.
Wenn Apple einfach mit der Kinderei aufhören würde, dass man diesen ganzen Trimmy-Enabler nicht braucht, sondern dass sich das wie ein Betriebssystem in 2014 verhält.
Ja, wahrscheinlich haben sie wieder Angst, dass sie wieder Features aktivieren für fremde Software, wo sie nicht wissen, ob es tut und so. Da sind die ja immer pingelig.
Also ich hatte das irgendwann mal unter Mavericks, dass er nicht hochkam. Und der Trick war dann, die Shift-Taste zu drücken. Der bootet dann ewig langsam.
Der macht den Kernel-Cache dann neu.
Der macht den Kernel-Cache, schmeißt ihn weg und macht ihn neu und dann war alles wieder gut. Also vielleicht hätte das ja auch geholfen.
Kann sein. Also wenn Leute noch eine Kiste rumstehen haben, die halt nur grau bleibt beim booten und sich noch keine Lust hatten, sich darum zu kümmern, die müssen einfach mit Shift- oder Single-User-Mode booten und in der Apple-Doku hier gucken, da steht der Spruch genau drin, den man einmal abfeuern muss oder zwei sind, weil man den Cache halt neu bauen muss mit Minus, Groß-U oder irgendwie sowas und dann geht die Kiste wieder und alle Daten sind noch da und da ist nichts verloren und überhaupt, weil ich hab schon geschwitzt, dass ich irgendwie Backup einspielen muss und dass gar nichts geht, aber es war alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich hab noch einen kleinen, super kleinen Nachtrag zur Swift. Ich hab dazu noch einen Blogpost geschrieben, den hab ich kurz vor der Sendung veröffentlicht. Ihr könnt mal unter Winkenschürfel lesen. Da hab ich eigentlich alles noch mal geschrieben, was ich sowieso erzählt hab. Aber ich wollte es nur nochmal erwähnen, dass es mit in die Shownotes kommt. Winkenschürfel, andersrum.
Ich wollt gerade dein verballhaunted Wort verballhornen und festgestellt, dass du relativ beeilbar und unterfangen bist.
Im Chat wird übrigens noch gesagt, dass hier dieser Torren mit den ganzen Sessions von der WWDC in HD, dass es da nicht genug CIDA gibt. Also alle Leute, die diese Videos vielleicht schon geladen haben, die könnten ja dieses Torren nehmen, die Files dann von Hunter reinschmeißen und dann können sie ja sofort losziehen. Das müssten ja exakt die gleichen Files sein. Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann hat der Typ, der das Torren erstellt, sowieso ein bisschen gefuscht. Deswegen, vielleicht können die da mal ein bisschen mitziehen, indem sie schon ein paar Files irgendwie haben.
Ja, konkret.
Ich finde eigentlich hätte Apple selbst das Torren ausgeben können. Aber ist ja nicht so...
Ich glaube, Torren ist nicht so die Technologie, die Apple so...
Was machst du da Clemens?
Ich geb dir gerade das Kabel an, den du eben klopfen hast. Oder nicht.
Doch, ich brauch's gleich doch.
Na siehste, du wusstest, die Leute hier sogar ihren Strom selber mitbringen müssen.
Ah, muss erstmal ne ordentliche USB-Verlängerung angebracht werden, bevor ich damit weiterarbeiten kann.
Diese eine, die nicht so leicht rausrutscht?
Ja, Gott sei Dank hab ich ja tolle Hörer und hab wirklich einen nicht enden wollenden Vorrat an diesen USB-Verlängerungen.
Großartig.
Ich hab übrigens hier diese externe Festplatte, auf der ich dieses Yosemite hab, das ist so eine USB-3-Festplatte, mit so einem kleinen Stecker auf der Seite, wo die Festplatte ist. Sag mal, wen ham's denn da ins Hirn geschissen, solche Stecker zu designen?
Wie meinst du das mit so einem kleinen Stecker?
Naja, das sind diese USB-Mini- Stecker, die sind ja normalerweise nur so flach. Man kennt die so von Android-Telefonen zum Laden. Und dann haben die da nochmal so ein Stück ran. Ich mein, ich kann sie nicht abstecken, sonst stürzt das Betrieb. Und der ist immer rausgerutscht. Dann hab ich irgendwann die Zange genommen und den Stecker, die Buchse ein bisschen verbogen und jetzt hält er. Das Gleiche hab ich mit dem.
Das wird immer schlimmer mit diesen ganzen Steckern.
Apropos, Lightning ist aber irgendwie auch ein Problem Kind. Also ich hab schon irgendwie zwei Lightning-Kabel, wo irgendwie der Stecker da so einer von den Pins zum Laden irgendwie schon schwarz ist. Jaja und man muss den immer wieder frei kratzen, dass er wieder Kontakt hat, weil irgendwie da wo zu viel Strom über den Pin geht.
Lightning oder Thunderbolt?
Lightning.
Aber der Stecker ist doch eigentlich ziemlich cool, oder?
Mir ist noch nichts passiert.
Der entweder ein bisschen einschmuddelt.
Du bist ein gebranntes Kind. Hast du so ein Schiener-Netze heißen billiget?
Nee, das sind Apple-Netzteile. Er hat dich auch zurückgerufen.
Ich würde sagen Feuerzeug in die Buchse halten und dann zu Apple gehen und sich einmal beides neu geben lassen. Das habt ihr jetzt nicht gehört.
Sag mal, Tim und dir schicken die Leute immer noch diese USB-Verlängerung?
Also ich hoffe jetzt nicht mehr, weil ich hab wirklich genug.
Okay, dann können ja die Hörer, falls sie andere Formen der Danksagung und Beteiligung suchen und jetzt keine USB-Verlängerung haben. Also heute gab es keine Schoki mehr.
Aber ich hab was anderes lecker und Süßes dabei. Soll ich ein neues Thema einleiten?
Ne, mach einfach auf.
Und Grüne in Ohm-Widerstände können die Hörer auch gerne mehr senden. Oder die braunen 10 Ohm-Widerstände.
Es gibt für jeden einen.
Ist aber jetzt nicht so wegschleckern während der Sendung.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Der klebt schon ein bisschen.
Miele, Monto, Cavallo, Mille, Fiore 2014.
Ach so, du warst ja in Italien.
Ich war in Italien.
Da gibt es Honig.
Tim, du musst den Honig...
Nimm mal den Honig. Der klebt ein bisschen.
Alle haben den gleichen, ja?
Wurdi, für dich gibt es auch noch ein Geschenk. Fällt mir da gerade ein. Eine original Initec-Tasse.
Wer ist denn Initec?
Da ist er schon.
Sie baden ihre Hände drin.
Nee, hab ich nicht geguckt bisher.
Du hast Office Space nicht gesehen?
Ich übe es auch nicht.
Immer noch nicht. Trotz der Tasse... Nächstes Mal vor der Sendung...
Das gibt gelb-rot. Und das nach zwei Drittel der Sendung.
Ich sag ja, wenn es hier auch keine Show-Ki gibt, dann lassen wir jetzt hier gerne von Platz verweisen.
So einfach können wir es jetzt auch nicht machen. Du kannst ja nicht die Mannschaft im Stich lassen, jetzt wo es noch Qualifikationschancen gibt.
Du, das ist das brasilianische Klima. Da muss man unter anderem Bedingungen...
Roddy, Hausaufgabe zum nächsten Mal. Wirklich. Du wirst es nicht bereuen. Es wird dir Spaß bereiten. Du wirst es mögen. Ich verspreche es dir. Und Clemens, für dich gilt genau das gleiche. Das ist dein Film.
Was?
Du hast Office Space auch nicht gesehen, Roddy?
Mach das mal, wirklich.
Doch. Wie?
Es wird dein neuer Lieblingsfilm werden.
Doch.
Ziemlich sicher.
Ja, haben sich bisher alle bedankt. Die das dann endlich mal gesehen haben.
Wie steht's in meinem Fußballsummer? Wie läuft das seit 5 Minuten?
Also die Geschichte zum Honig. Ich war ja in Italien. Da gibt es ein Fan-Haus. Das ist mitten in der Pampa, in der Toskana. An diesem Fan-Haus sind außen so Klappläden dran. So Fensterläden zum Klappen.
Fan-Haus? Ich dachte du warst arbeiten.
In Italien?
Nee. Am besten noch in der IT oder was? In Italien.
Du bist ja auch schon in Sibirien gewesen. Da ist ja ein bisschen die Toskana nicht weit.
Ja, bei Italien wird nicht in der IT gearbeitet. Seriously, da gibt es einfach nichts. Guck mal auf den Jobmarkt. Da gibt es keine Jobs in der IT. Da gibt es kaum Konferenzen. Da gibt es keine User Groups, da gibt es nichts. Auch kein schnelles Internet.
Auf jeden Fall hat im Spätsommer letztes Jahr der Letzte die Türen dicht gemacht und die Klappläden vor die Fenster gemacht. Vor ungefähr einem Monat, als die Erste da wieder eingetroffen ist, ging das eine Fenster nicht auf. Bei genauerem Hinsehen war das so, dass da ein Bienenschwarm zwischen dem äußeren Klappladen und dem Fenster eingezogen ist und so viele Bienenwaben zwischen Klappladen und Fenster gebaut hat, dass das Fenster nicht mehr aufging. Gibt es bei meinem Blog auch ein paar schöne Bilder.
Das muss man doch winken, schon.
Ich hab das regelmäßig auch so mit meinem Lanz. Wenn ich da in drei Tagen nicht bin, ziehen da Viecher ein. Überall. Ich kann dir sagen, wenn ich da jetzt hinfahren würde, nächste Woche ist garantiert eine Spinne im Waschbecken. Und Ameisen überall.
Auf dem Klodeckel ist immer der große Stein, damit die Ratten nicht reinkommen. Aber, ähm, ja.
Voll das Demo, äh, die Demonstration.
Ja, ja, das ist irgendwie...
Wo muss ich hinsurfen?
Fit. So, und jetzt, ähm, kamen wir überein, dass diese Bienen jetzt an dem Fenster vielleicht doch ein bisschen blöd sind. Und dann haben wir einen Impker gerufen. Der war aber eher nicht so erfahren, glaube ich. Auf jeden Fall, der hat halt dann dieses Fenster aufgemacht. Und dann den Fenster laden und dann passierte eigentlich das, womit man vorher schon hätte rechnen müssen.
Da war die Suppe runter.
Ja, die strukturelle Integrität dieses Bienenstockes war dann mal durch. Und dann ist irgendwie der halbe...
Das mögen die noch nicht so gerne.
Das mögen die überhaupt nicht.
Das ist so ein Feigling da in seinem Vollkörperkondom.
da ist dann leider der halbe Bienenstock auf das Dach da drunter gefallen. Und dann hat er noch versucht die Königin zu finden, um den gesamten Schwarm einzufangen. Das ist aber alles irgendwie nicht geglückt. er hat ein paar von den honigführenden Waben aussortiert.
Die habt ihr dann mal schleudert.
Na ja, es ist eher gematscht.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht der Honig, den du uns gerade gegeben hast.
Doch, natürlich.
Ich hab das Zählchen vom Fußboden aufgefuckt. Ja.
Der Honig.
Der ist vom Boden abgekratzt und abgefüllt.
Nein, nicht vom Boden abgekratzt. Also das waren schon Waben, die noch hingen und die hat er dann in so eine extra Schüssel getan.
Die so orangene Schüssel da?
Ja genau, sieht man die irgendwo.
Okay, lass mich raten, also wir kriegen jetzt hier Honig, weil du mal so 10.000 Bienen da gekillt hast.
Nein, die hab ich nicht gekillt.
Aber die sind jetzt tot.
Du hast dem Schauspiel beigewohnt.
Massenmord.
Jetzt schmeckt mir das Brötchen morgen früh gar nicht mehr.
Aber ich hab den Honig abgefüllt, bevor er dann mit dem Zeug kam, um die Bienen plattzumachen. Weil er dann der Meinung war, da hilft jetzt aber dann leider nur noch das Insekten-Vertilgungs-Vernichtungsmittel. Das war ein bisschen heftig. Also da standen wir dann drinnen und haben gesehen, wie er da auf dem Dach stand und da dieses Zeug angesprüht hat. Warum auf dem Dach? Na, das Haus ist so gebaut, dass direkt unter dem Fenster ist ein Dach.
Unter dem Fenster? Ach, hier kann man sehen. Das heißt, er hat die ganzen Waben einfach aufs Dach geschmissen und dann da Zeug rufig sprüht, damit die Bienen alle die noch irgendwie...
Er hat angefangen, die Waben dann runterzuschneiden, hat immer geguckt, ob er irgendwo die Königin findet und so weiter, hat die aber nicht gefunden, weil da so ein Chaos entstanden ist. Und das war also so eine Wolke von bösen Bienen. Das war schon...
Ja, massive destruktive Aktivitäten an ihrem Stock mögen die nicht so. Ich hab in meinem familiellen Umfeld Imker und auch mit durchaus erkläglichen Völkchen und so, aber...
Aber das nur, damit Roddy die Fenster aufmachen kann. Ja, naja, die hatten da auch schon überwintert, ne? Also das ist halt dann so der Punkt, wo du dann weißt, ja, das kann jetzt drei oder vier Jahre oder noch länger dauern.
Du hättest einfach ein Glas abholen sollen, auf der anderen Seite so ein kleines Loch ins Glas, wo du morgens irgendwie dein Brötchen ranhältst und den Hahn auftrehst und dir ein bisschen rauflaufen lässt und dann machst du wieder zu. Merk nicht, gar nicht.
Und Diamantbohrer in den Akku-Bohr-Schrauber einspannen und dann geht's los?
Wie viel Honig hast du da rausgeholt?
Ungefähr drei Kilo.
Und das heißt, drei Kilo, die meiste wurde wahrscheinlich irgendwie verschwendet und gar nicht richtig ausgeschleudert? Das heißt, das waren locker irgendwie zehn Kilo da in dem ganzen Fenster?
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, ich hab die so runtergekratzt und dann war das erst mal noch ganz viel mit so Gebrösel dazwischen und dann hab ich es erst einmal durchs Nudelsieb gefiltert und dann noch durch ein etwas feineres Sieb gegossen und so weiter.
Und das war aber alles, bevor er seine Todstoffe da versprüht hat, ja?
Ich hab die Waben weggepackt, bevor er da ankam. Also der Honig, so wie du ihn jetzt da siehst, der ist halt dieser doppelt gesiebt gefilterte Honig. Der ist jetzt natürlich nicht klar, weil da ist immer noch irgendwie Schwerbstoffe mit drin und so.
Der muss ja nicht klar sein.
Und wir haben Bienenwachs irgendwo. Keine Ahnung, wie so ein echter Imker das macht, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, als würdest du noch...
Der sieht genauso aus.
Als würdest du jetzt noch großartig hier auf Bienenwachs beißen, was aber auch nicht schlimm wäre. Weil das ist ja nicht giftig, das Bienenwachs.
Ich fehlte das Hause nochmal zu.
Also, ja, das ist so.
In der Raumfahrtagentur haben sie ja auch Bienen. Und letztes Jahr hatten sie glaube ich auch so 5 oder 6 Kilo rausgeholt und dieses Jahr ist auch die 10 Kilo Marke angepeilt. Aber die haben da so richtig oben auf dem Zwetsch, auf dem Zwischendach da so schön so Kästen. Da wird nicht gemordelt.
Naja, das ist halt so ein Wildding. Ich weiß nicht, im Prinzip hätte man die Waben möglicherweise irgendwie vorsichtig rausschneiden und in Kästen reinkleben oder so. Keine Ahnung, wie man so ein Schwarm dann unbeschadet umzieht. Wahrscheinlich geht das gar nicht.
Nicht, wenn die so festkleben, glaube ich, weil die bleiben da schon eigentlich. Also man kann zwar Bienen mit den ein oder anderen Trick steuern, zum Beispiel diese typische Nummer mit dem Rauch.
Ja.
Aber die Leute mal machen, damit kann man die zum Beispiel auch dazu bringen, dass sie schön nach Hause gehen, weil das signalisiert die nämlich in ihrem Urinstinkt, oh Waldbrand, dann gehe ich mal nach Hause und kümmer mich mal um meine Leute und bleib mal da drin und das gibt diverse so Mechanismen, wo man die durch die Gegend steigen kann. Das kannst du auch natürlich zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit machen, wenn es kühler ist. Diese gerade Insekten sind ja extrem empfindlich, weil es so geringste Temperaturschwankungen angeht. Die werden sehr schnell dann müde, langsam und faul oder halt eben, wenn es wärmer wird, agiler bis hin zu schwer ärgerlich.
Zwar eher ein wärmerer Tag.
Ja, da wären die dann auch ein bisschen aggressiv. Aber deswegen machst du sowas dann früh morgens zum Beispiel.
Wenn die zu Hause sind und warten, dann musst du da auch da sitzen und müssen da mit den Flügeln schlagen, damit sie dir den Baum kühlen.
Das ist kein Witz, wenn du dir das anguckst. Es gibt durchaus welche, die dann da vor der Tür sitzen und da einfach Ventilation machen und so. Ich kenne das nur persönlich, wenn ich da mal mit dran gehe an so einem Stock oder so, wenn das zu warm ist, dann werden die auch relativ schnell stinkig, die Wiese. Deswegen machst du sowas eben, wenn es kühler ist, früh morgens oder eben abends, aber nicht am hellerlichten Tag, da gehst du nicht ran an die Dinge.
Also ganz früh morgens, wo es halt noch kühler war, da konntest du dann in die Scheibe fassen und auf der Seite, wo die Bienen waren, war es doch merklich wärmer als die Seite, wo keine Bienen waren. Also die wärmen irgendwie ihren Stock auch.
Und kühlen auch. Ja, aber die sind dann selber eher faul oder matt. Und dann sind die auch zahmer, dann kannst du alle Möche mit denen machen. Ich hab mal einmal gesehen, wenn so ab und zu schwärmt so ein Schwarm mal aus, also die teilen sich dann. Das kommt halt vor, dass so ein Teil von so einem Schwarm, wenn zum Beispiel eine zusätzliche Königin mal entsteht, oder so was noch mal da ist, dann zieht die aus und nimmt Leute mit. Also entweder nimmt sie den Schwarm, indem sie die andere Königin tötet, aber manchmal hauen die auch dann eben einfach ab. Und dann hängt plötzlich mitten in der Stadt irgendwo so ein Bienenschwarm irgendwo dran. Wie so eine Traube, wie so eine fette Traube. Und ihr habt das mal gesehen, da ist da so ein Imker angerufen, so ein Profi, und er kommt einfach mit einem Eimer, hält den drunter und bürstet das mit der nackten Hand, bürstet diese ganzen Bienen in diesen Eimer rein. Die fallen rein wie so eine, als wenn du irgendwelche Plastikkugeln oder sonst was. Die fallen halt einfach runter, denkst du, ey hallo, das sind Bienen, die müssten da jetzt eigentlich mal... Aber die kannst du denn so... Dann hat der diesen Schwarm da im Eimer und trägt den durch die Gegend und kippt den in so eine Kiste wieder rein und dann gründen die da, oder haben wir ja einen Stadion gegründet, dann bauen die da ihre Waben und alles und sind da happy und so. Aber das ist total komisch, mit so einer Masse von Bienen, in welchen Stadien die sein können. Also entweder wahnsinnig aufgeregt und fliegen durch die Gegend oder halt eben so eine träge Traube, die du echt mit der Hand runterbürsten kannst von der Wand. Das ist total krass, also irgendwie auch sehr spannend.
Also die waren nicht träge, die waren gar nicht träge.
Nee, wenn eine Tasse über ist und du ihnen am Stock rumbastelst und es warm ist, dann sind die da nicht so cool drauf.
Dann lass es dir neu schmecken. Ja, Monte Cavallo deshalb, weil der Berg, der gibt's gleich nebenan. Es ist eher so ein Hügel, aber der heißt halt Monte Cavallo aus irgendeinem Grund. Also wer den suchen will, der kann das in Open Street Map mal machen. Den hab ich nämlich eingezeichnet. Da weiß man dann auch, wo es ist für die Freaks.
Ja, komm wir jetzt zu anderen Themen. Neues Betriebssystem.
Auf deinem Telefon.
Auf meinem Telefon.
Jetzt kurz vor iOS 8, stell nochmal ein iOS 7 Schnuppern, bevor es zu spät ist.
Na ja, jetzt war ja klar, wie der Hase so läuft, so wo sie sich irgendwie hinbewegen. Ich finde ja, so iOS 8 hat ja durchaus positive...
Hast du schon mal gesehen, live?
Nö, das nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Irgendwo anders hier?
Ihr habt jetzt nicht schon längst eure Dinger drauf?
Nein, alter mein Telefon ist mir heilig, da kommen keine Betas drauf.
Ich hab...
Also auf dem Rechner kein Problem, hab ich zuhause noch einen, aber auf meinem Telefon nicht.
Also ich hab's aufs iPad mal draufgemacht, aufs alte.
Und hast du jetzt nicht dabei?
Äh, doch.
Marodi.
Wir fragen hier gerade, ob das schon mal jemand gesehen hat.
Ja, es ist nicht übermäßig spannend, meiner Meinung nach.
Gib her, dann...
Das entscheiden wir.
Für mich ist es spannend. Bitte schön. So Tim, jetzt darfst du. Ich quatsche jetzt auch nicht mehr dazwischen. Vielleicht.
Ja, also es war ja ein längerer Prozess. Mir war ja auch immer klar, dass ich der Widerstand nicht ewig halten können wird. Aber ich hatte mich jetzt, sagen wir mal, auch mithilfe meiner anderen Geräte ja auch schon so an die Realität gewöhnt. Ich habe ja noch zwei andere I-Devices, die mit iOS 7 schon die ganze Zeit liefen. Aber es ist schon immer noch mal ein bisschen was anderes, wenn man so sein Primärgerät umstellt. Also ich fand das auf jeden Fall interessant. Nachdem ich dann dieses Update durchgeführt hatte, was denkt ihr, wie viele Updates, also wie viele meiner Programme Updates hatten? Ich habe hier ungefähr 100 Programme gezählt. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Alle? 90?
Nee, nicht ganz, aber es waren so 61 oder so. Und auch teilweise Programme, bei denen es nicht unbedingt erwartet hätte. Ich meine, ich habe vorher natürlich alle iOS 6 Updates gemacht, das heißt, das waren jetzt sozusagen nur iOS 7 Updates. Das zeigt schon mal ganz gut, was da sozusagen stattgefunden hat. Das nimmt man ja sonst noch gar nicht so richtig wahr. Tja, ja und abgesehen von den Sachen, die ich eigentlich auch schon vorher wusste, dass sie doof sind, ist es, ja, es geht.
Du wolltest es doch nur haben, weil es eine Podcast-App gibt, stimmt's? Gib es zu.
Na, es gab jetzt eine Reihe von Gründen, warum ich das gemacht habe.
Und du sagst dir, ich wurde erst erpresst.
Nein, ich wurde überhaupt nicht erpresst. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man jetzt irgendwie auch gerade so mit PodLav weiterentwickeln will und neue Sachen machen will, dann ist es ein bisschen doof, mit Sachen zu testen, die einfach keine aktive Entwicklung mehr erfahren. Das ist schonmal das eine. Also zum Beispiel kann ich auch nochmal erzählen, was wir gerade machen, was nämlich auch so ein grundsätzliches Problem ist. Wir wollen jetzt mit PodLav dieses Problem lösen, aber dem Problem ein wenig beikommen, dass es so schwierig ist, Podcasts zu abonnieren, aus dem Web heraus. Bist du irgendwie auf einer Webseite? Hier, Podcast, toll, abonnier uns. Und was steht dann da? Ja, hier ist der Feed. Dann klicken die Leute da drauf.
Nee, da steht meistens, wenn sie ein So und So haben und heute Mittwoch ist und die Sonne scheint, dann klicken sie hier. Wenn, ne und so weiter.
Das auch, genau.
Mit diversen Buttons und äh...
Also es gibt nicht ein vorherrschendes System, aber es ist immer eine Variante von so drei oder vier verschiedenen Lösungsangeboten. Das, was du beschrieben hast, ist dabei. Was ich beschrieben habe, ist dabei. Andere Sachen sind dabei, bis hin zu der total nerdigen Variante mit hier ist die URL und tun sie das Richtige damit. Also so ist es ja eigentlich am laufenden Meter. Und die Sache ist, wir haben halt überlegt, wie kann man das irgendwie einfacher machen? Weil eigentlich will man ja, was will man ja eigentlich machen? Man will Button haben und dann läuft der Hase. So, man klickt da so drauf und dann wird das Abonnieren eingeleitet. Das Problem ist, du musst natürlich jetzt auf eine Applikation umleiten. Du möchtest ja gerne, dass die richtige, im Idealfall drückst du auf einen Button und ein Programm startet und sagt dir, ah, vielen Dank, dass sie diesen Podcast abonniert haben. Alles ist gut, legen sie sich wieder schlafen. So wie Dennis gerade.
Das ist wirklich...
What has been heard cannot be unheard. Ja, man muss ja einfach da beim Klaren sein huckeln, dass sonst gerade gar keiner hört.
Ist das wirklich so? Ihr da draußen halt nicht?
Wir streamen vielleicht ein bisschen, aber...
Aber die danach nicht.
Die Konserve nicht.
Ich hab zwar schon weggedreht.
Das hilft bei dir überhaupt nichts.
Er wedert durch die Ohren in die Kopfhörer rein oder so.
Du lass doch mal den Dennis nur holen.
Immer auf die Kleinen.
Ja, immer auf die Kleinen. So, und soll ich das jetzt mal erläutern oder nicht? Wie startet man also ein Programm? Wie startet man ein Programm? Und sagt ihm, dass er bitte ein Podcast-Feed abonnieren soll?
Vorschläge?
Ja, indem du einen Alltype generierst, der heißt Podcast, Doppelpunkt, Slash, Slash, mit irgendeinem tollen Format drin, was alle kennen und implementieren und gut ist.
Alle kennen und alle implementieren.
Also ein URI-Schema, um genau zu sein.
Ja, genau, ein URI-Schema.
Ein URI-Schema, genau. Und da haben wir dann mal ein wenig geforscht und festgestellt, also es gibt natürlich sehr wohl bestimmte URI-Schema, die so mal eingeführt wurden. Schon relativ früh hat zum Beispiel iTunes angefangen, gleich zwei URI-Schema da zu implementieren. Das eine heißt ITPC.
Logisch, würde ich auch so nennen.
Also iTunes Podcast. Das heißt, wenn du dein Feed mit der URL ITPC doppelpunkt und dann dein Feed angibst, dann wird auf dem Mac, wo iTunes installiert ist, tatsächlich iTunes gestartet und er fragt dich, ob das jetzt abonniert werden soll. Alternativ konntest du auch PCAST doppelpunkt verwenden. Dasselbe funktionierte unter iOS auch. Nur, dass jetzt seitdem die Podcast-App draußen ist, PCAST quasi auf die App weiterleitet. Das ja auch irgendwie verständlich ist. Das Problem ist nur, wenn jetzt eine andere Podcast-App, sagen wir mal zum Beispiel Instacast oder Downcast, was da noch alles so gibt, sich versucht für denselben PCAST-Typ zu registrieren, dann kommen sie damit nicht durch. Also Apple forciert quasi den Vorzug für die eigene Podcast-App. Und grundsätzlich ist es nicht möglich, dass zwei Programme sich dasselbe Uri-Schema teilen. Wenn du dir mal die Situation unter Android anschaust, da ist es anders. Wenn du bei Android verschiedene Programme hast, die dasselbe Uri-Schema machen und du klickst auf so einen Link, dann kommt tatsächlich so ein Dialog hoch und sagt, mehrere Programme unterstützen diesen Link, welches von diesen Programmen möchtest du gerne haben. Das heißt im Idealfall, wenn du da auf PCAST links, dann bekommst du schon vom Betriebssystem eine Auswahl verschiedener Programme präsentiert, was an sich super ist. Bei Windows Phone ist es sogar noch ein Zacken Kesser. Da funktioniert es nämlich erstmal genauso. Wohlgemerkt Windows Phone 8 und auch Windows 8. Im Übrigen, wenn ich das noch nicht selber ausprobiert habe, aber so wurde es mir zugetragen. Da kriegst du einerseits die Programme, die dieses Uri-Schema unterstützen, angezeigt. Und andererseits, wenn es keins gibt, was das Uri-Schema kann, dann machen sie einen Lookup in ihrem App-Store und zeigen dir auch noch im App-Store die Programme, an die das können. Womit du eigentlich schon mal eine sehr schöne Variante hast, wie du solche Programme klassifizieren kannst. Du gewinnst ja quasi automatisch eine Suche. Das ist mehr als nur eine Suche über irgendeinen String und irgendeinem Keyword. Zum Thema Podcast können alle möglichen Programme was zu sagen haben, die nicht unbedingt in dem Sinne Podcast-Client sind, aber auf diese PCAST-URL zu reagieren, das macht halt nur Sinn für solche Apps.
Das letzte war jetzt aber nur unter Windows, oder wie?
Das war das Verhalten unter Windows Phone 8 und Windows 8.
Ich muss den Mikrofon wieder hinstellen. Aber URL-Spamming ist da noch kein Problem, oder? Dass die Programme auf allerlei Händler reagieren, nur damit sie dann im App Store gefunden werden.
Meine Bitcoins ablauschen können.
Solche URLs findest du dann halt einfach nicht im Web. Du musst dich halt mit solchen Sachen auch registrieren. Und was weiß ich, wie die da ihren Review machen. Aber wenn du da irgendwie auf Spam-Doppelpunkt oder was weiß ich, Porn-Doppelpunkt registriert bist, weiß ich nicht, ob dir das jetzt groß hilft, keine Ahnung. Aber so ist auf jeden Fall die Ist-Situation. Das heißt, tatsächlich unter Windows und Android ist es eigentlich relativ easy. Man muss nur in Anführungsstrichen eine richtige URL zusammenbauen und dann hast du irgendwie das. Wobei das eben so ganz so einheitlich auch nicht ist. Da gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel noch so eine Community-Initiative für Windows-Fone, so eine eigene URI da zu machen, explizit für Podcast-Apps. Die heißt dann WP-Podcast und dann soll die eben auch mehr können als nur Subscription. Problem ist jetzt auf dem Mac und unter iOS geht das halt nicht. Es gibt da keine automatische Auswahl und schon gar nicht so ein Look-Up im App-Store, obwohl sie das ja eigentlich machen könnten. Und da wollen wir das in folgendes machen, das heißt alle Programme, die jetzt eine eigene URI haben, also häufig hast du das ja so, dass so Programme so ein eigenes URI-Schema haben, also Downcast zum Beispiel kann halt Downcast-Doppelpunkt. So und die sammeln wir jetzt gerade irgendwie ein und bauen das irgendwie alles in so einen universellen PodLav-Subscribe-Button ein. Also ein Button. Und dann klickst du da irgendwie drauf. Das Ganze ist noch nicht so ganz zu Ende programmiert, da gibt es noch so das eine oder andere. Ich kann mal kurz hier die All-in-Chat reinschmeißen, da kann man das mal ausprobieren, aber ihr werdet unter Umständen merkwürdige Effekte haben, aber ist wie gesagt noch nicht so ganz fertig. Aber wir sammeln halt jetzt Programme und gucken halt mal, wie das so alles funktionieren kann. Wir überlegen auch noch, ob man da eine automatische Feed-Auswahl auch noch mit reinbauen kann. Weil wenn du die Clients kennst, dann weißt du ja unter Umständen auch, was die können und was die nicht können. Also hat keinen Sinn einem Instacast einen Opus-Feed vorzuschmeißen etc. Aber eigentlich wollte ich ja über iOS 7 reden. Das war also auf jeden Fall der Hauptgrund, warum ich da das Update gemacht habe. Das interessiert euch wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder? Wollt ihr gar nicht wissen, wie schlimm ich es finde?
Leck doch mal dran.
Das lustige ist, das ganze fing ja an eigentlich mit einem Geräteaustausch, wo ich mich ja schon so mental darauf eingestellt hatte, dass ich dann quasi auf iOS 7 gezwungen werden würde. Das war dann aber nicht der Fall. Also man konnte tatsächlich noch Austauschgeräte im Apple Store bekommen, wo noch iOS 6 drauf ist. Oh Wunder, oh Wunder.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie sich auch gewundert, dass du es so explizit haben wolltest, oder?
Komischerweise nicht.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Also die Reaktion war so, ah ja, iOS 6, ich gucke mal, ob ich noch eins mit iOS 6 habe. War irgendwie korrekt. Ich meine, mein altes iPhone 5 war auch wirklich im Eimer. Jetzt hat er wirklich wieder galante Macken.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt schon das dritte oder vierte. Ich glaube schon das vierte, was ich habe.
Seitdem ich dieses Gerät gekauft habe. So oft kam Apple Care schon zum Einsatz, weil immer irgendwas damit war. Beim ersten Mal irgendwas ganz, glaube ich, da ging dieser einen Ausschalter irgendwie gar nicht. Und naja, ein paar Mal kaputt gegangen. Tja, und jetzt habe ich auch dieses OS. Und? Naja, man muss erstmal Dinge ausschalten.
Ja, was denn so?
Na so Parallaxe, dünne Linien und so.
Ja, Parallaxe, also zumindest auf dem iPhone fand ich irgendwie auch anstrengend. Auf dem iPad finde ich es okay. Warum auch immer, ich das finde, aber.
Ja, ich brauche das, das bringt mir irgendwie nichts. Also ich fühle mich natürlich nicht besser.
Ich muss sagen, auf dem 5S stört mich das mit dem Parallaxenzeug deutlich weniger. Durch diesen Motion-Chip, da diesen M7 scheinen die das aber auch besser im Griff zu haben, wie der da parallaxt. Also insofern.
Jetzt so prima ausschalten in Scheiß.
Also kann sein, dass es gar nicht ausgeschaltet ist.
Wo du den Hintergrund einstellen kannst, da kannst du das doch abschalten.
Naja, also es gibt so ein paar Programme, die werden definitiv schlechter, dadurch, dass man die aktuelle Version bekommt. Da war es vorher irgendwie echt besser. Skype ist so ein Beispiel. Skype kommt jetzt irgendwie in so einen komischen Windows-Gewand und es ist wirklich skurril. Gut, man kann besser sein Online-Status verwalten, aber so designtechnisch geht das definitiv in die falsche Richtung. Da bin ich irgendwie nicht dafür. Mit dem Kalenderprogramm...
Skype geht grundsätzlich in die falsche Richtung. Schon seit einiger Zeit, nämlich seitdem sie von Microsoft gekauft wurden. Auch funktional. Jetzt nicht nur von dem Teil, wo du dran leckst, sondern der, was das eigentlich tun soll am Ende des Tages. Da hat es ja massive Änderungen gegeben. Microsoft hat sich überlegt, das ist ja blöde, wenn da Peer-to-Peer-Verkehr stattfindet, den können wir ja gar nicht vernünftig abhören oder nicht vermarkten oder sonst irgendwas. Dann haben die das erst mal so umstrukturiert, dass das halt durch ihr eigenes Server durchgeht.
Dadurch ist es aber nicht unbedingt besser geworden.
Nein, es ist qualitativ schlechter geworden. Und zwar nicht nur in der eigentlichen Übertragung, sondern auch in den üblichen Meta-Methoden. Also das Einbuchen wird zum Glücksfall. Und sich gegenseitig anrufen wird. Auch eher ein Lottospiel und sowas. Das ist schon sehr ärgerlich. Es war mal ein durchaus brauchbarer Tool, aber jetzt ist es einfach nur noch ärgerlich. Wollte ich noch mal so nehmen, weil jetzt darfst du über Design renten.
Naja, ich hab da zu dem Design schon alles gesagt. Da hat sich ja in dem Sinne eigentlich auch wenig dran geändert. Also es ist halt irgendwie mit 7.1 etwas besser geworden, aber es sieht halt trotzdem noch irgendwie alles aus wie HTML. 3.2. Mach doch nur mal deine Kontakte auf.
Also das ist einfach HTML 3.2.
Der Standard von HTML 3.2 ist aber nicht Helvetica Neue.
Das...
Oder?
Es hat keinen Standard-Fond.
Eben.
Na du kannst Helvetica Neue einstellen und HTML 3.2 machen, dann sieht das genauso aus.
Das fand ich übrigens sehr cool. In dieser Platform State of the Union Talk kam irgendwie so ein Typ, so ein Deutscher, das hörte man sofort auf die Bühne erzählen. Andreas Sowieso und meinte so, ja, der neue Fund von Yosemite ist Helvetica Neue. Und übrigens, so spricht man das aus.
Hat sich bestimmt keiner gemerkt. Aber ist auch ein schwieriges Wort, ne?
Neue.
Also für Amerikaner auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ja, ich bin noch nicht so, irgendwie kam diese Sendung doch ein bisschen schneller als erwartet. Deswegen hab ich noch nicht so richtig so ein abschließendes Urteil zu fällen. Das ist aber auch etwas müßig, weil die anderen Leute ja sowieso alle mit ihrem Urteil schon weiß voraus sind.
Du enttäuschst jetzt aber doch die Hörer, die einen epischen Rand erwartet hatten.
Ich hab ja dazu schon alles gesagt. Es hat sich ja nichts geändert. Also es ist ja immer noch alles genauso. Es hat sich ja hier nichts geändert. Es ist halt nur so, iOS 8 hat tatsächlich das Versprechen, auch mal von der Funktionalität her etwas zu verbessern. Es sah ja bis iOS 7 aus, als würde sich ja alles nur verschlechtern.
Die Background-Modes von iOS 7 sind doch göttlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, was du hast.
Die Background-Modes?
So Background-Downloads und so ein Scheiß. Das ist doch...
Die kriegt man als User ja nicht so viel mit.
Die kriegst du als User nicht so mit, aber... Programme, die ohne dein Zutun irgendwie Sachen runterladen. Also gerade für Podcast-Apps ist das halt das Traum-Feature. Weil du kannst da sagen, hier, lad mir doch mal die 100 Megabyte runter. Betriebssystem, sei doch mal so gut. Und dieser Download überlebt halt einen Neustart. Weil der entsprechende Download-Agent von iOS, der macht das halt, bis alles unten ist. Und wenn alles unten ist, weckt er das Programm wieder auf. So nach der Art, ach übrigens, deine 100 Megabyte sind da.
Ja, bei welchen Apps ist dir das aufgefallen, dass das zuverlässig funktioniert?
Sagen wir mal so, ist es mir bei keiner App aufgefallen, dass es unzuverlässig funktionieren wird?
Bei welcher App ist dir überhaupt aufgefallen, dass es überhaupt genutzt wird?
Also Instacast scheint es zu verwenden, weil du ab und zu kriegst so dann mal so eine Local Notifications, ach übrigens, Disda ist runtergeladen und ach übrigens, Disda ist runtergeladen.
Ja, kann ich mich jetzt noch nicht dran erinnern, aber wie gesagt, da benutze ich es vielleicht jetzt noch nicht lange genug dafür. Also ich muss sagen, diese Extensions, die sie angekündigt haben, die haben mir das erste Mal wieder so ein Gefühl bekommen, mich nicht in ein immer engeres Gefängnis eingesperrt zu werden. Also sie haben einfach mit der WWDC so viele Dinge angekündigt, die so eine Perspektive geben, dass es sich dann doch mal vielleicht über ein sich öffnendes System handeln könnte bei allen Einschränkungen, die es hat.
Weil sie haben den Blinker gesetzt.
Schöne Umschreibung, ja genau.
Ja, so ein bisschen eingeschlagen haben sie auch schon.
Tja, dann hab ich irgendwie mit großer Überraschung Tweetbot gestartet in der neuen Version. Ja, da haben sich tatsächlich Dinge verändert, aber es sieht halt alles irgendwie so, es ist jetzt alles so schwarz-weiß.
Ich weiß nicht, hier blau-weiß.
Aber dann gab es irgendwie eine interessante Sache. Es gibt ja einen neuen up.net Client.
Willst du das mitbekommen?
Natürlich.
Ich hab noch mitbekommen, dass du es getweetet hattest oder beziehungsweise geup.net-ed. Wie nennt man das? Post oder so?
Posted.
Geposted.
Na, es ist tatsächlich noch ein neuer up.net Client rausgekommen.
Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt etwas überrascht.
Totgesagte Lebenlinge.
Offensichtlich. Das ist auch ganz fancy Schmenzi. Der macht irgendwie lustige Sachen mit Animationen. Das müsst ihr euch zum Beispiel mal angucken. Das find ich total cool, wenn du irgendwie in so einen Post reingehst und dann...
Lass mich raten, für diesen Client hast du dir jetzt iOS 7 installiert?
Ein Wort glauben wir dir.
Es ist einfach eine...
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich zeig dir eine einzige Animation. Du gehst hier irgendwie in dieses Item rein. Das ist so Single-Post-Display. Und jetzt gehst du wieder zurück in die Timeline.
Oh, das ist schnucklig.
Sollte jetzt nicht so hübsch, geometrisch wieder in die Timeline, so zurück ins Glied. Sehr schön. Heißt blickst. Oder?
Verblickst und zugenäht.
Und der ist so gut, dass er Tim dazu gebracht hat, iOS 7 zu zulernen.
Kannst mal sehen.
Naja, ich wusste einfach, ich hab auf Dauer eh keine Chance und deswegen ist es jetzt einfach mal so weit. Aber das Telefon lief gefühlt auch etwas schneller. Das hat mich überrascht.
schnäppier.
Erhöhte Flupzizität. Also all die geblendeten Massen da draußen... Ja, das Update ist freigegeben. Okay, da das jetzt wenig Begeisterung hervorruft, vielleicht ein kleines anderes Ding zwischendurch, falls ihr mal zu viel Zeit habt. Damit kann man echt prima seine Zeit verbringen. Empfehle ich euch das WikiData Game.
Kennt ihr das schon?
Frage, Antwort? Ich logge mich hier gerade mal ein. Da muss man irgendwie hier sich außen bei Wiki...
Genau.
So, und zwar ich poste mal kurz die URL hier auch in den Chat. Gucken, in welchem Zustand sich das jetzt gerade befindet. Also es gibt, WikiData hatten wir glaube ich schon das Thema, so die Metadatenspeicherung von Wikipedia. Das heißt, da stehen die maschinenlesbaren und klar klassifizierbaren Informationen drin von Wikipedia-Artikeln, die Einwohnerzahl von Berlin, etc. Und um diese Daten zu verbessern, haben sich hier so ein paar Leute bei Wiki, ich weiß nicht, wer das macht, bei Wikimedia das Wikidata Game einfallen lassen, wo man so verschiedene Spiele machen kann.
Ich sehe gerade, da kommen gerade neue Sachen dabei. Oho, es wird immer mehr.
Da kann man, wenn man auf die Seite...
Settings ist ja ein interessantes Spiel.
Ja, die Settings sind erstmal ganz gut, das sollte man nämlich auch mal machen, nämlich zum Beispiel schon mal seine Language-Preferences da einbauen. Ja, Spanisch kann ich lesen.
Okay.
Also Spanisch kann ich nicht sprechen, kann ja jetzt keine aktive Kommunikation damit führen, aber wenn du so einen spanischen Text vor mich hältst, dann kann ich dir sagen, worum es da geht. Bei den Sachen, die das Wikidata-Game mit dir hier macht, reicht das auch irgendwie aus. Also hätte ich haben können, aber hatte ich nicht.
Ich hatte Latein und hab es standesgemäß gehasst.
Ja, genau, ich auch. Aber ich freue mich immer noch darüber, dass...
Ich hatte Französisch und hab es standesgemäß gehasst.
Du kannst dich aber mit immerhin, wie soll ich sagen, 60 Millionen Menschen mehr unterhalten als ich.
Können die meisten Leute, die in Deutschland Französisch in der Schule halten, nicht... Oder auch Englisch, das ist egal. Mit dem, was die meisten Leute aus der Schule entlassen werden, nee, nee, nee.
Französisch meistens. Sprachen an sich?
Ja, sehr häufig.
Also Englisch hat bei mir ganz gut geklappt.
Das ist das WikiData-Game. Jetzt kannst du ja verschiedene Spiele spielen, nämlich Merch-Items oder Person oder Gender. Und dann gibt es jetzt noch ein paar andere neue, die ich mir bisher noch nicht angeschaut hatte. Gender ist ein gutes Beispiel. So, da kriegst du irgendwie drauf und dann kriegst du aus dem WikiData Items vor die Nase geklebt, die zwar als Personen markiert sind, aber wo nicht klar ist, ob es sich dabei um Männchen oder Weibchen handelt.
Ich meine, Instance of Human.
Genau, weil es nämlich Instance of Human ist und alles, was Instance of Humans ist, das wird dir hier vor die Nase gehalten. Und dann siehst du, das ist jetzt hier aus der spanischen Wikipedia und da wird dann irgendwie Martin Ochoa de Capanaia, la la la.
Bis 1661.
Man könnte jetzt sagen, dass es ein Mann ist, aber bei den Spanier-Italienern, da bin ich mit den Männern immer nicht so sicher. Die haben ja auch einen Andrea, da weiß man ja auch nicht, was das ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Martin nicht auch so ein Problem ist.
Ja gut, aber dann kannst du halt hier irgendwie gucken, irgendwie escritor und traductor, dann weißt du schon, das ist männlich, also mann, zack, bumm. Sagst du mail und dann kriegst du schon den nächsten vor die Nase. Jetzt krieg ich komischerweise nur Spanische vor die Nase, aber hier Fouet und Pedagogo ist also auch männlich und so weiter. Und so kann man sich dann hier irgendwie wirklich den ganzen Abend durchklicken und Punkte sammeln und da irgendwie in die Highscores vom Wikidata-Game kommen und nebenbei verbessert man quasi den Datenbestand von Wikidata.
Hier steht, to play these games you have to use WeDAR. What is WeDAR?
Wikidata Remote. Ein Single Sign on. OAuth.
Und ist Maria jetzt auch ein Typ?
Maria ist eine Mädel und zwar nicht wegen des Vornamens, sondern es una jugadora de golbalespañola. Female und so weiter.
Guck mal jetzt mal in Englisch.
Genau hier in Englisch. So kannst du also immer weitermachen. Das ist irgendwie das Gender-Game, dann gibt es noch generell Person. Da kriegst du halt irgendwas vor die Nase, wo du sagen musst, ist eine Person oder ist keine Person. In diesem Fall heißt der Artikel United States Senate Election in Virginia 1968.
Ist eine juristische Person.
Ist keine Person. New Canada Party ist auch nicht, Human Trafficking in Russia auch nicht, List of Tollest Billing auch nicht. Ringo Starr in this All-Star-Band, naja, nice try.
Die All-Star-Band ist aber keine Person.
Nein, nein, das ist eine Band.
So, aber hier. Main Subjects of Documentary-Film würde ich sagen auch nicht, ne, ist keine echte, weiß ich nicht. Warum nicht? Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher.
Meinen wir auch im Film, ist das dann auch eine Person oder sind nur real gelebte oder lebende Personen?
Na ja, eine Person, also eine Figur, also eine, weiß ich, ein Film dargestellte Person.
Aber es darf ja nicht, dass es eine natürliche Person sein soll. Steht da nicht.
Ich sag jetzt einfach nur, ich bin nicht sicher.
Falkling, das war eine deutliche Person.
Kannst ja selber machen, sind deine Punkte. So, aber das ist halt der Punkt. Du gehst halt hier irgendwie durch und wenn du dir sicher bist, dann bist du halt sicher und es kommen immer wieder welche. Also du bist unter Umständen schneller, wenn du ehrlich bist, dass du dir nicht sicher bist. Fictional Characters zum Beispiel, keine Person. Na ja und so weiter. Das ist halt das Person-Game. Alles sehr einfach. Sie könnten es noch ein bisschen besser machen, indem die Button sich immer an derselben Stelle befinden würden, weil dann muss man nicht die ganze Zeit immer noch diese Browser Navigation machen.
Und indem der Font nicht so klein wäre, dass man den Text tatsächlich auch ein bisschen lesen kann.
Ja, da kannst du ja einfach mal in deinem Browser ein bisschen größer machen.
Dann hab ich das überall.
Na ja, dann gibt es hier noch so Country of Citizenship und irgendwie Birthdates und Bilder. Dann kannst du ja halt irgendwann deine Statistik anschauen.
Boah, bei Birthdate kann man bestimmt voll viele Punkte machen, oder? Da muss man ja richtig was wissen. Das ist ja nicht nur so Yes und No, sondern... Ach so, man muss das bestätigen, verstehe.
Na, hier steht es halt drin im Text da. 23. August, 84 und dann musst du wahrscheinlich das anklicken. Genau, dann musst du das anklicken, was da im Text steht und dann passt da das und wenn du das als richtig erachtest, dann kannst du es auswählen. Nee, gleich Accept. Das ist nicht tot, okay, alles klar. Auch lustig, das ist neu, das Game. Also da kommen am laufenden Meter irgendwelche Sachen dazu. Aber fragt er jetzt eigentlich nach Birthdates? Ja, er fragt nach Birthdates. Ach so, verstehe, man kann Geburtsdatum und Todesdatum kann man hier angeben, genau. Aber Henry Glöckner lebt ja noch. Ja, so kann man sich hier auch schön durchklicken, macht auch Spaß. Deutscher Politiker, guck mal, hier ist sogar einer tot. Da kann ich dann beides angeben.
Nee, kannst du nicht.
Ups, doch.
Ach so, ja, genau. Geboren da, gestorben da, fertig.
1694 bis 1721.
31. Alter, sind die damals sicher geworden.
Also macht, macht süchtig, kann ich euch verraten.
Wie viele Punkte hast du schon?
Das wollen wir jetzt aber wissen.
Ja, ich hab's jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt, aber ich bin glaube ich nie in der Top 10.
Jetzt die wichtige Frage, geht das auch, kann ich das auch auf dem iPhone spielen, weil sonst habe ich keine Zeit dafür.
Ja, eigentlich werden die ein bisschen schlau werden, dann würden sie nicht ein Game machen, wo man gegen irgendeine Punktezahl kämpft, weil das ist ja langweilig, sondern müssen ein richtiges Game daraus machen, wo man gegen andere spielt. Und du denkst du spielst ein Spiel und in Wirklichkeit machst du dir WikiData schön. So ein bisschen so wie auch...
Es darf dir nicht total egal sein, wie das Ergebnis ist.
Also es ist eigentlich total egal.
Nee, ich bin überhaupt nicht in den Top 10.
Total number of players 962 ist aber jetzt auch nicht so viel.
Ich glaube bei Country of... irgendwo bei Merch Items habe ich es mal relativ schnell hingekriegt, da in eine Sub-Pkette zu gehen.
Aber nach dieser Sendung wird die Teilnehmerzahl sich verhundertfachen.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, jemand soll ein schickes iPhone-Game schreiben oder Android von mir aus, ist ja egal, irgendein Game schreiben, wo das halt so als Spiel gegen anderen übernommen wird.
Mit Game Center Integration. Hat der Game Center gesagt, ja.
Also ich finde einfach die Idee cool, dass man einfach da so spielerisch die Sachen macht. Also ich würde sagen, mir macht jetzt...
Bist voll der Gamification-Fan.
No Date macht jetzt am meisten Spaß.
No Date.
Genau, wir können auch mal bei No Image gucken, was er da einem eigentlich vorwirft.
Bei No Image.
Da gibt es Bilder in den Artikel.
Taisley Locomotive Works.
Dann kann man sozusagen das Bild dazu herauswählen. Ja, das sieht doch alles ganz gut aus.
Ja, das sind aber Lokomotiven und nicht die Werkstatt dazu.
Aber hier geht es doch auch um die Lokomotive.
Da oben geht es ja um Taisley Locomotive Works.
Das ist ja auch ein Foto von...
Formerly the Birmingham Railway Museum.
Passt schon.
Also ich meine, das ist doch vollkommen klar, dass das hier eine 60-163-Tornado-Taisley-Locomotive ist.
Das sieht doch jeder.
Dieses Item hat keine Image, aber die Wikipedia kann auch ein Item oder ein File ausfüllen, wenn es für den Arzt nicht genutzt ist. Also ich würde sagen, du musst nur die Locomotive-Works da anklicken und nicht die Locomotives selber.
Ja, das sind ja Picture von dem Artist. Also wenn man das Work als den Artist sieht, dann ist die Locomotive ja sein Werk, ne?
Also, klick jetzt die Works.
Mach einfach Not Sure.
Nee, klick das Image von den Works an und nicht die anderen.
Not Sure Minuspunkte?
Ja, aber es sind Locomotive und nicht die Works. Ja, es ist nicht die Werkstatt. Es geht um die Werkstatt an den Artikeln, nicht um die Locomotiven. Siehste, haben wir schon einen schlechten Eintrag vor Tims windigen Entscheidung gerettet. Wunderschön ist die ja auch. Was gibt's denn da zu lachen? Lass mal wieder ein bisschen über Podcast reden.
Das ist WikiData, das Game.
Ich empfehle das.
Applaus, Applaus, Applaus.
Jetzt mal jemand anders.
Mach mal.
Ihr dürft wählen zwischen üblichen Rant, Thema LTE oder Thema OpenVPN. Ja, LTE.
Luftansaug.
Ich hab mich damit nochmal ein bisschen intensiver befasst in den letzten Wochen, weil ich da konkrete Anwendungen für hatte, insbesondere auch mit dem Markt. Also jetzt nicht nur die übliche Befassung mit naja, Kurve mehr in Sim steckst, ins iPhone passt schon, sondern irgendwie, was kriegt man hier eigentlich so? Insbesondere deswegen, weil ich war ja auch neulich nochmal wieder in London, ich hatte das im Frühjahr schon mal erwähnt, da gehst du halt in so ein Dreiladen rein und sagst, hier bitte das All-You-Can-Eat-Paket mit Tra-La-La-Soße und Schaf, dann sagt der 15 Pfund bitte und dann gehst du da wieder raus mit einer SIM-Karte, also innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden, mit einer SIM-Karte, die ist übrigens auch schon aktiv und so, also nicht noch mit Anmeldung, Tra-La-La, sondern dann gehst du dann halt raus und da sind dann keine Ahnung, 3000 Gesprächsminuten und 3000 SMS und was weiß ich nicht, alle drauf. Und All-You-Can-Eat-Data. 30 Tage. So, All-You-Can-Eat-Data. Nicht nur das, sondern angeblich ist es jetzt sogar so, dass diese Karte das sogar im Roaming macht, allerdings nur in anderen Dreinetzen. Werde ich jetzt gleich mal ausprobieren, bin nämlich in ein paar Tagen nochmal in Österreich und dann schauen wir mal, was das dortige Dreinetz abgibt und danach dann in Schweden natürlich wieder, dann guckt man mal, ob meine englische Karte da auch noch geht mit All-You-Can-Eat-Data und so. Ja, gehört, ja, wird auch in Italien gehen. So, und so sieht mal so ein bisschen grob die Situation im Ausland aus. Über Schweden hatte ich ja eh schon ein paar mal auch geschwärmt. So, und übrigens auch, ich hab auch schon länger noch eine 3-Karte aus Österreich und so, die tut er auch und die expired auch nicht, selbst wenn ich da jetzt irgendwie jahrelang nicht war oder so was, die geht immer noch. Und dein Honig läuft gerade über, obwohl ich ihm gar nichts getan habe, ich habe nicht mal geschwenkt, aber das ist saut hier rum auf dem Tisch, egal. Also so sieht es draußen aus. Ja, der will raus aus dem Glas. Ja, und dann hab ich mir gedacht, jetzt guckst du mal, welche Anwendungen ich dafür habe in Deutschland und hab erst mal festgestellt, also grundsätzlich diese All-You-Can-Eat-Nummer gibt es hier gar nicht, selbst wenn man dafür Geld spendieren will, richtig viel Geld. Ich hab dann zum Beispiel mal bei einem angeblichen Marktführer angerufen, zum Beispiel der tollen Firma Vodafone, hab gesagt, so hallo, ich hab hier mal ein kommerzielles Projekt, ich weiß euer Produkt ist ohnehin teuer, das ist mir scheißegal, das kann kostenbar, das will, ich hätte gerne LTE-Karte, die nicht ausgeht. Wie meins sind das? Sie so, ich so, naja, üblicherweise habt ihr ja auf eurer Flatrate ein Datenkontingent drauf und wenn das abgelaufen ist, dann geht das ja aus. Sie erstmal so, nee, nee, sie werden dann nur gedrosselt und ich so, ja, das ist aus. Hab's jetzt nicht auf den berühmten Song hingewiesen, aber hab dann gesagt, wenn man mich irgendwie von 100 Megabit auf 63 Kilobit runterdreht, ist das aus faktisch, das ist unbrauchbar. Naja, es gäbe da Angebot und hier gibt's irgendwie 10 Gigabyte. Ich so, ja, das ist aber, was passiert denn nach 10 Gigabyte? Na ja, dann könnte man da nochmal, aber ich könne ja weitersurfen. Ich sag, nein, kann ich nicht mit 63 Kilobit, kann ich nicht weitersurfen. Und das Netz besteht nicht nur aus Surfen. Haben sie nicht was, was nicht ausgeht? Und dann hat sie richtig rumgewühlt, meine Rude, ist aber teuer. 50 Gigabyte, ich sag mal, was passiert nach 50 Gigabyte in einem Bit? Na ja, dann, ich so, ja, tschüss. War nicht zu haben. Wo es sowas gibt, allerdings auch schweineteuer, ist bei der Telekom. Es stellte sich dann inzwischen raus, dass es bei fast allen Betreibern, außer bei Vodafone, hab ich jedenfalls nicht gefunden, so geheime Optionen gibt, die nicht unbedingt beworben wären, wie man immerhin dieses Kontingent verlängern kann. Die Telekom macht das offiziell. Wenn da deine drei Gigabyte, deine fünf Gigabyte, deine unglaublichen fünf Gigabyte, wenn du die endlich runtergenuckelt hast, dann kriegst du da so eine SMS und dann kannst du auf diese SMS antworten mit dem Wort Speed. Dann buchen sie dir nochmal 14,95 ab für weitere fünf Gigabyte. Es geht auch über ein Web-Interface und bei der Telekom gibt es auch das Feature, was aber so verborgen ist, dass es einem nur die Hotline freischalten kann, dass das automatisch passiert. Immerhin kann man denn machen. Allerdings gibt es das nur für Vertragsgeschichten. Also ausschließlich 24-Monats-Verträge von Prepaid oder so ist da gar keine Rede. Es gibt ohnehin fast kein Prepaid-Angebot für LTE in Deutschland. Komme gleich noch drauf, was ich entdeckt habe. Und ja, so sieht es dann da aus. Wie gesagt, wurde davon gar nicht. Telekom teuer, aber geht. Aber nur mit Vertrag. E plus hat ja derzeit glaube ich mal so eine Handvoll LTE-Touren endlich mal aufgestellt im Jahr 2014. Wahrscheinlich sind denen doch viel zu viele iPhone-Kunden von Base weggerannt oder wie auch immer. Kannst du mir nicht anders erklären. Muss ich jetzt plötzlich doch damit anfangen. Und deswegen spielt E plus noch nicht in dieser üblichen Liga mit von wir schließen erstmal alle Altkunden aus von so einem Feature. Sondern wer eine funktionierende E plus Karte hat mit Daten drauf, kann die auch derzeit erstmal im LTE benutzen.
Wenn du weißt, wo so ein LTE-Turm ist.
Ja, hier in Berlin stehen ein paar rum. Ich dann natürlich auch gleich in den nächsten DM in so einem Drogerieladen da, da hängen die Dinge in einer Kasse für 8,45 oder so was, eine Blaukarte geholt, ist ja E plus Netz. Und die aktiviert, da kann man dann auch für recht teure 15 Euro, kann man sich dann 3 GB kaufen, aber immerhin mal prepaid. Und das steckst du dann rein und wenn du dann mal so ein E plus LTE-Turm findest, das scheinen noch nicht so viele Leute zu wissen, dass es da LTE gibt, dann whoopt der sogar ganz ordentlich. Was für E plus Netz eher erstaunlich ist, aber das geht. Da können wir uns jetzt noch darüber unterhalten, was es da für lustige Geräte inzwischen gibt, die man dafür benutzen kann. Also das kann man, wer mal schnell mal irgendwo mit ordentlichen Bits mal drei Gigabyte braucht, die man übrigens dann auch noch mal verlängern kann, weil da eben auch nur die Hotline verrät, das steht auch auf keiner Webseite oder so. Da kann, also du müsstest damit mal spielen. Bis auch dann, die wieder den Rückschritt einlegen. Das ist jetzt wieder so ein toller Trend, während sich in anderen Ländern sich das Netz vorwärts bewegt und die Tarife vorwärts bewegt, geht es bei uns rückwärts. Da hat zum Beispiel die tolle Firma Kongstar Anfang des Jahres beschlossen, dass sie kein LTE mehr unterstützen. Nö, es wird dann laff ich damit, ist nicht Vertragsbestandteil. Habe ich dann die angetwittert, habe ich gesagt, so Freunde, wie ist denn das so? Ich habe jetzt hier gerade LTE bei euch. Was passiert denn, wenn ich an meinem Tarif mal wackele oder so, geht denn mein LTE aus? Die sagen natürlich nicht ja oder nein, warum, das wäre ja viel zu, könnte man ja breit treten, wie ich jetzt hier. Sondern die sagen ja, LTE ist nicht Vertragsbestandteil. Ich sage, ist mir doch scheißegal, ihr liefertet mir doch jetzt. Ich habe jetzt seit längerem schon LTE bei euch. Was ist denn dann? Ja, ist nicht Vertragsbestandteil. Also geh mal davon aus, dass in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie an meinem Vertrag wackele, oder Leute, die jetzt neu hinzukommen, da einfach gefickt werden. Nochmal, das ist alles Zeug, was sie haben. Es gibt auch keinen technischen Grund. Ich vermute mal, da ist da, Kongster, eine 100% Telekom-Tochter. Das ist bei denen irgendein Marketing.
Kongster ist der, den ich billig mag. Natürlich sagt die Telekom, ihr macht nicht mehr LTE, weil wir wollen den ja verkaufen.
Ja, und der Typ, der den feuchten Traum hatte, war der Telekom, ruft natürlich an bei seiner Tochter und sagt, nehmt das mal raus, weil er dann glaubt, dass alle Leute sofort zur Telekom rennen und für dieselbe Dienstleistung mehr als die Doppelte bezahlen, als die, die sie jetzt momentan bei Kongster haben.
Wahrscheinlich sind zu viele zu Kongster geflüchtet und der musste das mal stoppen.
Ja, nichtsdestotrotz, wenn du das mal von außen siehst, als jemand, der jetzt nicht, wie wir das Geheimnis wissen, dass Kongster eine Telekom-Tochter ist. Du siehst jetzt eine Telco, die auch überall wirbt wie dumm, ja, und die fährt sozusagen wieder Rückwärtsgang. Alle Welt geht sozusagen voran, technologisch und tariflich, und die fahren Rückwärtsgang. Das ist halt so Deutschland. Hallo. Ja, fand ich jetzt auch wieder besonders toll. Ja, und das ist, wie gesagt, so sieht die Situation hier aus. Das ist sehr, sehr bestürzend. Tim sagte was von wegen, der ist ja O2-Kunde. Du sagtest, es gibt irgendwelche O2- Geschichten, die man auch heimlich irgendwie verlängern kann. Hast du da einen Überblick über die Preise oder so? Also heimlich heißt, man muss dann irgendwelche mit gekreuzten Fingern rückwärts über den Bordstein springen oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe es jetzt noch nicht selber ausprobiert, deswegen kann ich die Prozedur nicht beschreiben. Mir wurde bloß von einer vertrauenswürdigen Quelle gesagt, dass es definitiv die Möglichkeit gibt, sein abgelaufenes Datenvolumen zu verlängern bei O2. Zumindest so manuell. Warst ja schon mal ein Vorschuldführer.
Ja klar, immerhin.
Dass man deutscher Unternehmen dazu bekommt, dass man bei ihnen was kaufen darf. Es ist einfach unfassbar, wer was lernt.
Kunde droht mit Auftrag.
Studiere die nicht alle BWL, bevor man irgendwie anfängt, da in der Wirtschaft was zu machen oder wenn die Leute jetzt schon irgendwie so direkt aus dem Irrenhaus da irgendwie mit dem Management gesetzt werden?
Aber sie glauben immer noch, wenn sie dich nur scharf genug gängeln mit ihrem Scheiß, dass du dann in den nächsthöheren Tarif wechselst, natürlich mit 24 Monate Vertragsverlängerung. Das ist immer der Glaube, von dem sie ausgehen.
Ich glaube, die machen alle im Grundstudium vier Semester höhere Milchmädchenrechnung.
Also das ist wirklich echt ganz bitter. Ich warte jetzt nur wirklich darauf, dass diese Roaming-Geschichte da greift. Angeblich ist es jetzt, also offiziell, nicht angeblich, offiziell ist es ja so, dass du jetzt ab 1. Juli deine eigenen Roaming-Abkommen schließen kannst mit anderen Netzprovidern. Das ist eine relativ wilde Geschichte. Das ist auch wahrscheinlich so unausgeboren, dass es nach meinem Wissen derzeit auch noch keinen gibt, der das wirklich macht. Aber theoretisch ist es so, dass du dann hingehen kannst ins Ausland und jetzt ohne dir eine dortige SIM zu kaufen sagen kannst, hier mit meiner deutschen SIM möchte ich aber gerne deinen Datentarif hier nutzen, lieber drei in Schweden, England, Italien, Österreich.
Das wird doch werwest.
Aber O2 hat, oder zumindest so ein Laden auf der Prenzlauer Allee, hat so ein Werbeplakat draußen gehabt, das ist jetzt auch mit irgendwie Roaming inklusive europaweit und so weiter.
Hast du diese Dinger mal angeguckt, die Roaming-Angebote, die da drin sind, so, wir geben dir 10 Megabyte am Tag umsonst. Manche sogar 50. Allerdings nur für den ersten Tag oder so. Mit sonstigen Sternchen und Fußnoten und das sieht nicht. Ich finde es immer wieder unglaublich anmaßend, wie diese Hotliner, diese Twitter-Hotliner, egal wen du da fragst, die dir mal einreden wollen. Das passt schon so, mehr brauchst du nicht. Ich finde es echt immer toll, wie die sich vor einem aufbauen und genau wissen, was mein Nutzungsprofil ist und was ich machen will und mir sagen, das passt schon so. 10 Megabyte reicht dicker aus. Also das ist wirklich ganz bitter. Liebe Hörer, wer da lustige Tarife hat für LTE, für Prepaid in Deutschland oder sonst irgendwas, ich bin da sehr aufnahmefähig. Das ist auch wirklich mal Sachen, die teste ich dann auch wirklich mal. Weil ich hab jetzt in einem kommerziellen Projekt ein paar von diesen Telekom-Karten am Start natürlich mit den 24-Monats-Verträgen der Autoverlängerung, weil ich konnte ums Verrecken meiner Fritzbox nicht beibringen, auf eingehende SMS mit Speed zu antworten. Das muss man sich dann selber wieder basteln. Das ist jetzt mein nächstes Projekt, wo ich mit so einem Speed-Stick, also so ein UMTS-Dongel, da habe ich eigentlich einen gefunden, der ganz ordentlich funktioniert, nämlich den witzigerweise von der Telekom Speedstick Nummer 3, das ist ein Huawei.
Der heißt Speedstick, weil die einzige Anwendung davon ist, dass man einmal im Monat Speed als SMS darüber versteht.
Nee, das Ding kann auch Daten hin und her schubsen. Das ist übrigens sehr spannend, wenn man sich das mal, wenn man mit dem Ding rumhackt. Wie gesagt, ich bastel da so einen kleinen Router da noch drumherum, wie sich diese Dinger zwischen verhalten. Früher waren ja diese Dinger serielle Ports. Die steckst du rein in deinen Linux oder deinen Rechner, wie ich es immer erinnere, tauchen die als serielle Ports auf. Und dann wurden die angequatscht wie so ein Modem, AT-Command-Z, und dann wird da gedialt und dann wird da PPP draufgemacht und so. Und diese Interface haben die immer noch, jetzt machen sie aber folgendes, da sind zwischen rausgefunden, dass diese LTE unter Umständen doch schon mal ein bisschen schneller ist, nämlich weitaus schneller als dein VDSL-Anschluss hier. Also sowohl up als auch downlink. Ist es auch wirklich, wenn du gute Netzabstattung hast?
Also mehr als 9600 baut.
Ja, dass diese ganze, wir nuckeln einmal was durch einen virtuellen Serienport, der vielleicht auch nicht mehr so performant ist. Also macht das Ding folgend also erstmal, wenn du das erste Mal reinsteckst, ist es erstmal nur so was, ist ein CD-ROM. Da siehst du gar nichts von Daten. Das heißt, da gibt es dann gibt es dann so tolle, unter Linux, gibt es dann so tolle Utilities, wo man so geheime, aber von irgendwelchen Hackern ausgeknobelte Kommandosequenzen an diesen Stick schicken kannst. Du kannst sagen, du bist jetzt erstmal kein CD-ROM mehr, sondern du bist jetzt mal echt. Du, das mit dem CD-ROM machen sie, da ist halt die Software drauf, die du brauchst. Wenn du das Ding reinsteckst in so einen Rechner, dann kommt da gleich dein Installer und sagt, hier du für Mac oder Windows, wie auch immer, installier doch den tollen Daten-Tralala-Manager oder sowas. Aber wie gesagt, wenn man das unter Linux betreibt, dann kann man dem so ein Kommando schicken, dann wird der echt. Dann hat er immer noch sein Modem-Interface, wo man sich mit ihm unterhalten kann, was ich sehr gut finde, weil darüber kann man ihn steuern und abfragen, wie es ihm geht und senden stärker und alle Möcher. Und SMS schicken und empfangen. Und wenn man dann eine Verbindung aktiviert hat, dann tut er so, als wäre er eine Externet Ethernet. Das heißt, er taucht dann auch mal als Ethernet-Interface mitsamt eingesteckten Kabel auf. Und da machen sie dann den eigentlichen Datentransfer rüber. Das ist der Standard. Ein virtuelles Ethernet ist der Standard.
Na ja klar, für die reine Übertragung nur der normalen Ethernet-Verbindung hat halt normalerweise keine SIM-Karte, wo du eine PIN eingeben musst.
Das machst du über diesen Modem-Teil, wo du dann da über ganz normal das AT-Command-Set bzw. GSMA-Erweiterung dort den PIN da einhackst.
Ja, aber da spricht sich doch auch irgendwie alles anders an. Warum gibt es nicht einfach ein ich bin eine SIM-Karte, die weiß? Ja, wäre ja nicht so schlimm. Und dann gibt es einfach einen Standard-Triver in jedem Scheiß.
Es gibt sogar noch viel schlimmer Sachen. Es gibt diese Sticks auch, die benehmen sich wie ein Ethernet-Kabel mit einem Router dran. Mit einem Web-Interface. Du steckst das Ding rein, dann hat dein Rechner ein Ethernet-Interface mehr und dann redest du über Web-Browser mit diesem virtuellen Router an dem Ding drin. Das ist natürlich auch wieder bitter, wenn du so ein Software schreiben willst, die dann automatisch SMS verschickt, um deinen Datenkontingent zu verlängern. Aber wie gesagt, das ist keine Empfehlung. Das sagst du ausdrücklich immer wieder, weil ich werde dauernd immer gefragt, was du in der Freak Show la-la-la empfohlen hast. Ich empfehle nichts. Das ist das, was ich mache, womit ich spiele und sage euch, was damit funktioniert und was nicht. Was ist denn das Teil? Auf Ebay, per Sofortkauf gekauft. 70 Euro oder so.
Speedstick.
Ein E3276 Huawei. Das Schöne ist, diese Ding kann halt alles, was derzeit im Umkreis von 30.000 km um uns herum funkt.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht auf irgendwelche SIM-Karten gelockt?
Aber das kann halt 2G. Das kann GPS. Das kann Edge. Das kann UMTS mit HSDPA, bis der Arzt kommt, auf all möglichen Frequenzbändern. Und das kann LTE auf all möglichen Frequenzbändern, die wir im nahen und ferneren Umkreis um uns herum haben. Deswegen fand ich es ganz sympathisch, der Ding. Er hat einen kleinen Nachteil, weil er nämlich so viele Frequenzbänder hat, wenn du ihn erstmal ansteckst und er versucht Netze zu finden, oder du ihm sagst, zeig mir mal, welche Netze da sind, kannst du in Ruhe einmal aufs Klo gehen. Das dauert nämlich eine Weile, bis er das alles abgescannt hat. Aber es tut mal so. Wird von der Telekom vermarktet und das Speedstick Römisch 3, ich hab den wie gesagt auf eBay geschossen. Ja, also das mal so zum Zustand LTE. Ich hab auch weitere Sachen noch ausprobiert. Nämlich da, wo ich die Plus-Karte mal reinschieben wollte. Hab mir auch mal zum Spielen so ein LTE-Plastrouter geklickt. Die berühmte Fritzbox, die hatte ich ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, dass die habe. Da geht das natürlich auch ganz schön. Da gibt es so ein Plastrouter von D-Link. Ich glaube DWR921 oder so. Moment, D-Link 921. Das Ding funktioniert sogar relativ einfach. Das heißt, du steckst die SIM-Karte rein, machst ihn an und fertig, peng. Hat noch einen WLAN drin und so vier Ethernet-Ports und so. Ist jetzt auch nicht so teuer, kostet so 120 Euro oder so. Ist allerdings echt Plastik. Merkst, dass China Plastik ist. Also gerade im Vergleich zur Fritzbox, der kann jetzt zum Beispiel nicht ansagen, wie gut dein Empfang ist, um ihn zum Beispiel in irgendeiner Art und Weise auszurichten oder die Antennen auszurichten. Der zeigt dir seine Empfangsqualität dadurch an, dass er draußen eine Leuchtdiode hat, die ist entweder rot oder grün.
Reicht doch.
Ja, das ist aber blöd so zum Antennen ausrichten.
166 Euro sehe ich hier gerade.
Ja, habe ich aber nicht dafür. Der DWR 921 oder was?
Der sieht ja schick aus mit den beiden Hasenohren.
Und da, wie gesagt, da ist die Fritzbox deutlich besser, aber auch deutlich teurer. Da gibt es dann richtig so ein Antennenausricht-Tool, was dann auch teilweise rumpiept und so, wo du dann deine Antennen da drehen kannst und so. Was sich mir übrigens auch lohnt, weil ich habe in meinem Projekt, betreibe ich ja mehrere Karten parallel, über die ich dann den Datenverkehr bündle. Oh, jetzt habe ich wieder böse Worte gesagt, jetzt kriege ich wieder irgendwie 1000 Mails. Oh, du kannst Daten bündeln, ja, kann ich, weil ich einen Router im Internet habe, wo ich die wieder zusammenfassen kann. Und da willst du natürlich ausgerichtete Antennen haben, weil wenn ich eine LTE-Zelle leer gemolken habe, brauche ich ja noch eine zweite. Und deswegen muss ich dafür sorgen, dass ich sozusagen nicht beide Dinge auf derselben Zelle einbuche. Und deswegen ist das schon ganz gut. Aber wie gesagt, deutlich teurer, das Plastik-Ding von D-Link funktioniert. Wer sich also so etwas mal billig ins Fenster stellen will und mal einen Tarif findet, der dafür brauchbar ist, be my guest. Ist keine Empfehlung, aber tut. Ich hab übrigens diesen Speedstick auch in den von mir neulich mal erwähnten TP-Link Mini unterwegs, Router mal reingesteckt, der wird zwar offiziell dort unterstützt, hab's aber bisher nicht zum Laufen bekommen. Das liegt auch daran, dass die Weltfirma Huawei von diesen Dingern unter derselben Nummer, an diesem E3276 oder so was, ungefähr 30.000 Modelle rausbringt. Ich meine, das ist auch klar. Bei so einer groben Produktbezeichnung wie E3276, da kann sich natürlich alles und jeder darunter verbergen. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Variante davon 3277 nennen oder so was. Die heißen alle so, und dann gibt's noch Strich S150 und was weiß ich nicht alles. Also das ist noch ein ziemlicher Zoo in diesem Markt.
Das ist halt ein Klassiker, da kannst du nicht einfach den Namen ändern.
Ja, das mag durchaus sein, aber auch das steht übrigens da im Chat, der S150. Das ist der, den man hier bei uns in unserer Gegend haben will. Auch von den Frequenzbändern her. Also da ist noch ein bisschen Room for improvement in der ganzen Geschichte. Ansonsten, man muss ja sagen, LTE ist ja eine Technik, die ist wirklich sehr schön. Das einzigartige daran, die krankt, ist halt die Politik, also die Art und Weise, wie dort Adressen vergeben werden und mit dem ganzen Natt. Und dass natürlich die Telekom in den allermeisten Tarifen, den erst mal alles kaputt macht, was Spaß macht, also deinen Skype kaputt macht, deinen Mumble kaputt macht, deinen Facetime kaputt macht und wahrscheinlich diverse andere Sachen auch. Weil sie immer noch glauben, dass sie auch nur eine Telefonsekunde mehr dadurch verkaufen, wenn sie mich daran hindern, irgendwie VoIP zu benutzen. Oder so. Also abgesehen von solchen politischen Schwächen, ist das eine Technik, die eigentlich durchaus sehr ordentlich ist. Auch die Pinkzeiten darauf sind sehr, sehr vernünftig. In der Tat wäre es, wenn es einen ordentlichen Tarif gibt, ein hervorragender DSL-Ersatz. Weil die technischen Werte sind auch besser als VDSL. Zumindest derzeit noch. Es ist natürlich eine Frage, wie viele Leute die Zellen als Anfang zu belasten werden, wenn das populärer wird.
Schneller, wenn die Zelle für dich alleine ist, oder wie?
Natürlich, du teilst dir die. Wie alles, was mit Funk zu tun hat, teilst du dir die mit allen anderen. Aber es ist für so eine Telco viel einfacher, so eine Kapazität auszubauen, als jetzt hinzugehen und im Falle von VDSL jetzt nochmal neue Kabel auf die Straße zu ziehen.
Aber wie würde das LTE aussehen, wenn ganz Berlin kein VDSL hätte, sondern alle LTE machen würden?
Dann wahrscheinlich werden die Senderdichte sich höher.
Du kannst ja die Sender nicht unendlich erhöhen, oder? Dann sprechen die sich ja gegenseitig über.
Nee, nicht unendlich erhöhen, aber du kannst schon ziemlich kleine Zellen bauen. Das haben sie ja schon damals, als es mit GSM losging, schon gemacht. Natürlich willst du Kabel. Solange Kabel da ist, ist ja auch fein. Aber nicht alle Leute haben Kabel. Und das buddelt dir keiner mehr ein, weil es schlichtweg zu teuer ist.
Wenn erst mal alle LTE benutzen, dann haben die genug zu tun, um die Leute, die auf der Straße rumlaufen, zu versorgen mit den Telefonen.
Ja, aber es kann, wie gesagt, es ist für so einen Operator auch deutlich kostengünstiger, das auszubauen, als jetzt nochmal hinzugehen und wirklich in jedes Haus nochmal neue Kabel oder ein Glasfaser reinzuziehen. Also von daher ist es eine durchaus interessante Alternative, insbesondere weil es gibt ja schon LTE-A und LTE-Plus und LTE-A-Plus und la la la und natürlich wird auch schon an 5G gebastelt oder so. Aber es ist, wie gesagt, von der Funktionalität her ist es inzwischen recht brauchbar, wie gesagt, tariflich leider vollkommen, komplett für den Arsch. Hier in Deutschland jedenfalls, ganz finster.
Ich kann ja noch mal so ein bisschen erzählen, wie es in Italien war.
Damit man sich wieder toll fühlt, oder?
Also das Problem ist, erst mal überhaupt rauszufinden, wer bietet welchen Tarif an und was kriegst du dafür? Weil italienische Telcos können kein Englisch und zwar grundsätzlich nicht. Also das war...
Fahr mal nach Spanien.
Also aus den Webseiten wurde es nicht so ganz klar, was was ist. Dann hatte hier irgendjemand über... Irgendjemand hatte so eine Webseite empfohlen, wo dann so ein bisschen was drauf stand. Dann sind wir zu so einem Laden gegangen und gesagt hier, ja, hier einmal Karte mit Dingstarif und so weiter. Und dann brauchst du erst mal eine italienische Steuernummer. Und irgendwie brauchst du aber eine neue italienische Steuernummer. Du kannst nicht die nehmen, die du letztes Jahr hattest, sondern du musst eine neue klicken. Und dann gibt es so eine offizielle Webseite, wo du irgendwie deine neue Steuernummer zusammenklicken musst. Und das funktioniert alles nicht. Also wir haben irgendwie eine dreiviertel Stunde in dem Laden verbracht und sind dann mit so einer Trä, also drei Karten rausgegangen. Das lief dann auch einigermaßen. Das einzige Problem war, dass der Provider irgendwie in der gesamten Zeit zweimal plötzlich vergessen hatte, was für ein Tarif wir gebucht haben. Und auf einen anderen Tarif umgeschaltet hat, so für mehrere Stunden. Und der Meinung war, ja, aber jetzt ist das prepaid alle. Weil jetzt ist ja ein anderer Tarif und jetzt gilt es ja volumenmäßig und ihr habt so lange gesurft und jetzt ist kein Geld mehr drauf. Und das hat sich dann aber immer mal wieder gefixt. Dann war es wieder der erste Tag.
Hat sich selber gefickt? Hat dich gefickt und sich selber gefixt.
Und dann haben sie es wieder gemerkt, ach so, ja, richtig, das 3-Gigabyte-Paket war ja doch gebucht. Ja, stimmt, das ist noch nicht alle. Und es ging irgendwie zwei- oder dreimal so und du denkst dir nur so, ey Leute, was soll denn das?
Ja, ist mir wie gesagt mit den anderen drei nicht aufgefallen. Your mileage may vary.
In Italien, das war total problemlos.
Ich glaube, das ist ehemals, ist das nicht ehemals Omnitel?
Na Wind ist der Zweitgrößte, Tim ist der Größte, Wind ist der Zweitgrößte.
Dann ist das ehemals Omnitel.
Und Tre ist der Drittgrößte, kann man so sagen.
Ja Tre ist überall, die sind zu spät gekommen. Hinter Tre steckt grundsätzlich immer, oder in den allermeisten Fällen, immer Hutchinson Vampore, also so eine Hongkong-Truppe, die aber auch recht ordentlich investieren und so. Und eben halt, was ich an denen schätze, ist, die machen halt diese Shut-up-and-take-my-money-Ding. Du gehst halt bei den Englern da rein, oder auch in Schweden oder so, sagst hier so ein Geld, und dann, die fangen nicht an, da irgendwie rumzueiern, und nee, du darfst aber hier keinen Woip benutzen und Tethering, hahaha. Sondern du kaufst halt deine Bits, und was du damit machst, ist denen scheißegal.
So, fertig, peng. Mir hat die Frau in dem Laden irgendwann Leid getan, weil es war völlig klar, wir zahlen da 15 Euro für diese Karte plus Tarif. Und die war da irgendwie eine dreiviertel Stunde, fast eine Stunde am Machen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel sie davon abkriegt, von diesen 15 Euro, aber das kann kein guter Stundenlohn gewesen sein.
Nee, aber das ist, wie gesagt, der Problem. In England, wie gesagt, hab ich es ja nun schon mehrfach gemacht, ich hab jetzt nämlich, als diesmal war, noch eine Karte mit rausgeholt, noch für jemand anders. Meine alte, die ich von der ITF noch hatte, jetzt dieses Jahr, die ich mir da gekauft hatte, funktionierte ja noch. War übrigens auch so ein Ding, ist nicht expired noch nicht. Wie gesagt, die österreichische Karte hab ich schon seit Jahren nicht mehr in Österreich sich sehen lassen, die geht immer noch, die rum auch und so, die sind da ganz locker. Die chargern dich halt für das, was du benutzt und dann ist gut und machen aber, wie gesagt, keinen Zick-Zack mit. Du müsstest sie aber mindestens einmal aufladen für so und so viel, sonst sperren wir dir die Karte und so ein Scheiß.
Die Amis sind da noch viel krasser drauf, da musst du irgendwie jeden Monat aufladen, sonst sperren sie die Karte und nach noch einem weiteren Monat ist sie dann weg. Und als ich das letzte Mal da war, hab ich halt wieder so T-Mobile, weil das waren die einzigen, die wenigstens halbwegs realistisches Angebot hatten.
Die haben wir übrigens auch IPv6.
Hab ich die Karte rein getan und es hat irgendwie so ein oder zwei Stunden gedauert, dann hat der erste angerufen. Also die recyceln die Nummern so schnell, dass du die Karte reintust und dann ruft jemand an, weil er meint, er würde jemand anders ranrufen.
Die kosten da drüben übrigens richtig Geld auch. Der AT&T Laden war am besten.
Der AT&T Laden war am besten. Wir kommen so rein und meint der so, ja, das sind 50 Dollar für die SIM-Karte und dann nochmal für einen Monat 70 Dollar. Und wir so, 50 Dollar für eine SIM-Karte? Es ist beide so losgelacht und der Typ stand so so, hä, hä?
Ihr kennt das, weil ich ja wie gesagt mit der IETF-Truppe, da sind ja sehr viele Amis dabei und immer wenn wir hier irgendwo in Europa unterwegs sind, besorge ich denen ja SIM-Karten oder wir sind halt zusammen los. Ich finde das halt raus, was in dem Land so geht, dann nehme ich die an die Hand und wie gesagt jetzt gerade die Nummer in England war echt krass, weil die sind eben solche Preise gewohnt und ich da rin mit denen in den drei Laden und hier so, ja, jeht mal 15 Pfund und dann der hat die SIM-Karte rausgedrückt und fertig so und der Ami so dann, der eine von denen ja und what do I need to do to activate this? No, it's active already. It's active already. So, na ja, da kannst du halt jetzt so klicken, surfen, bunten, email, la la la, viel Spaß, ganz Facetime nach Hause und so. Er so, also wie gesagt, auch wenn wir jetzt hier mal über Deutschland schimpfen, es gibt da Dinge, die noch...
Die in England besser sind.
Ne, nicht in England, aber es gibt noch Leute, Länder, die noch viel schlimmer unter der Knute stehen und damit meine ich nicht Nordkorea. Aber wir sind da schon dicht dran. Hier im Chat fragte jemand, ob der 3276 externe Antenne unterstützt. Ja, sogar zwei davon. Du kannst eine Mimo-Antenne da dranhängen. Mit T9-Steckern. Soviel mal zum Thema. Wir haben mal ein bisschen mit LTE gespielt. Wie gesagt bin für Tarifinweise dankbar.
Gut, willst du deinen OpenVPN-Kram jetzt auch gleich noch hinterher schmeißen oder sollen wir erstmal Roddy zum Thema Pizza befragen? Ich möchte übrigens darauf hinweisen, dass wir heute relativ pünktlich...
Wer muss denn heute vom Zug abholen?
Ja, dann sag ich doch schnell noch was über OpenVPN. Ich meine, für die Details fehlt hier immer, eh immer die Zeit in dieser Sendung. Ja, das ist ein Problem mit diesen Kurzformaten. Wir werfen mal kurz heute auf den Tisch.
Wir klagen jetzt erstmal eine Kapitelmarke ein.
Früher gab es doch diesen Master-Tech-Sound. Wo ist denn der endlich hin? Also OpenVPN. Ich hab nach längerer Zeit mal wieder mit OpenVPN gespielt. Ich hab das ja eine Zeit lang links liegen lassen. ja, keine Ahnung. Hat doch mal eine Weile ein bisschen gestunken. Wie gesagt, für die Details fehlt jetzt mehr die Zeit. Aktuell ist OpenVPN allerdings macht durchaus Spaß. Das ist jetzt mal eine Empfehlung. Aber nicht notwendig, eine Empfehlung zu nutzen, sondern sich das mal anzuschauen. Ja, dieses Programm hat leider ungefähr 200 Optionen. Ist kein Witz. Man muss schon Spaß haben, auch mal eine längere Mainpage zu lesen. Das Schöne daran ist, ich hab's jetzt mal kreuz und quer mal eingesetzt und getestet. Das Schöne ist, es geht einfach. Es geht einfach plattformübergreifend. Und es tut all das, wo sich andere VPN-Techniken zu fein dafür sind. Es tut zum Beispiel auch so was, wie über IPv6 zu funktionieren. Oder IPv4 über IPv6 oder IPv6 über IPv4. Oder IPv4 und IPv6 über denselben Tunnel zu transportieren. Das ist ja alles so was, wo sich die ganze IPSEC-Truppe so wahnsinnig die Knochen dran bricht. Oder mit irgendwelchen, ja, das musst du da noch einen GIE-Tunnel einpacken und bla und so. Aber das tut einfach OpenVPN von Hause aus. Außerdem haben sie vor einiger Zeit mal auch Shared Keys eingeführt. Das heißt, man muss jetzt nicht erst eine ganze PKI mit eigener CA und Zertifikaten und LA und SILS aufsetzen, um damit spielen zu können. Man kann einfach das Programm aufrufen und sagen, generieren wir mal einen Random Key und den kopierst du auf die andere Seite und dann kannst du damit schon loslegen. Dann startest du halt immer einfach über die Kommandozeile oder für die Leute, die jetzt auf dem Laptop benutzen wollen, gibt es auch lustige WIs dafür und deswegen kam ich auch drauf, Dennis, du hattest mal gefragt, was mit VPN an ist und an bleibt. Das tut OpenVPN auf dem iPhone. Wenn du da das VPN anmachst, dann geht es an, bleibt an, selbst wenn du mal die Netzverwendung verlierst, geht es dann natürlich nicht. Aber sobald du wieder Netz hast, geht es automatisch wieder an und spielt weiter. Und wenn du deinen OpenVPN-Server richtig aufgesetzt hast, behältst du deine ganzen IP-Adressen und alles, das heißt, du kannst dann auch schön weiterspielen.
Wir machen das mit dem iPhone, wo eigentlich alle Sandbox ist.
Die klinken sich so ein bisschen ein in diese VPN-GUI von iOS. Das heißt, wenn ich also mit, kann dir das mal zeigen, wenn ich das OpenVPN anmache, über diesen Client-Malmacher. Da sag ich jetzt hier mal Connect. Geh doch mal weg. Du fährst irgendwie mal dein iPhone nach ein paar Stunden an und erst mal kommen diese ganzen Dinger oben runtergescrollt, diese E-Mails. Du willst genau da oben hin, weil da ist der Button, wo du hinklicken willst und da kommt immer dieses E-Mail-Fenster dazwischen.
Diese Notification.
Ich hab's jetzt hier angemacht, siehst du aber das normale VPN-Logo oben. Und du siehst, es taucht auch hier auf in den VPNs von iOS.
Das heißt, die bei Apple haben einen VPN-Schnittsteller anscheinend und es geht nicht nur die drei Sachen, die sie da so vorschlagen.
Zumindestens für die GUI. Das heißt, die klingen sich zu ein. Kannst du jetzt auch über das Einstellungsding kann ich es auch ausmachen, dann geht es auch wieder aus. Was sie allerdings nicht machen, ist, wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke, diese Dinger hier selektiere und jetzt hier oben ansage, dann sagt er, ne du sollst bitte diese komische App dafür benutzen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die App das erzwingt, weil die ist nämlich kostenlos und schwatzt sich dafür mit Werbung voll oder sowas. Ob sie das deswegen gerne haben wollen, aber klingt sich zumindest da ein. Ich hab das jetzt auch mal ausprobiert, hab das mal ein paar Tage mit Split-Tunnel laufen lassen. Wenn du eine Netzverbindung hast, geht das immer auf. Wenn du zum Beispiel ins WLAN wechselst, wechselt der das auch mit. Das kann OpenVPN-Zauber auch, einen bestehenden Tunnel, mitwechseln. Das ist zum Beispiel das geile Tool für Bahnfahrer, die sich immer darüber ärgern, dass sie ihnen in der tollen Bahn im WLAN immer die Verbindung wegnackt. Und jedes Mal, wenn sie sich neu verbinden, müssen sie alle ihre Applikationen neu machen, weil die alle eine neue IP-Adresse gekriegt haben. Das kannst du schön durch einen OpenVPN-Tunnel durchmachen. Und dann hast du das auch. V6 geht auch bis aufs iPhone durch.
Und auf der anderen Seite hast du was?
OpenVPN ist ja ein Programm, das auf beiden Seiten läuft. Das ist die selbe Software, mal als Client, mal als Server gestartet. Ich hab da diverse virtuelle Maschinen oder reale Maschinen oder sowas. Ich hab's auch auf dem Edge-Router zum Beispiel zu laufen, auf dem ich schon mal erwähnt hatte. Also es gibt diverse Plattformen, wo du das drauf machen kannst. Und wie gesagt, also die iPhone-Plattform, also wenn du das mit dem iPhone benutzen willst, musst du zwar immer noch ein Zertifikat und so weiter generieren. Der traf ich noch nicht herausgefunden, wie das mit Shared Key geht, aber auch das, du generierst ja selber die Zertifikate. Musst du auch nichts unterschreiben lassen. Du machst deine eigene CA und generierst, unterschreibst dann deinen kleinen Zertifikat und dein Server-Zertifikat und fertig. Das ist jetzt nicht so. Die liefern sogar inzwischen bei OpenVPN so ein Set von Shellscripts mit. Oder einfach sagst, ja mach mal. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob du willst, ja mach mal. Das stellt dir zwei Fragen, wie deine Organisation heißt oder tippst du irgendwas ein und dann generiert dir die drei Dinge und fertig. Mit Keys und so. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Ding, womit man mal spielen kann. Was ich auch sehr schön finde, ist, dass man es customisieren kann, was mein ursprünglicher Grund war. Ich brauchte nämlich für diese LTE-Geschichte, von der ich vorhin sprach, die Möglichkeit, mal einen ordentlichen Tunnel zu machen, den ich auch selber besteuern kann, mit möglichst wenig Overhead. Das heißt, du kannst bei OpenVPN auch sagen, mir geht es nur darum, dass ich hier einen vernünftigen, kontrollierten Tunnel habe, der V4 und V6 kann, aber ich brauch zum Beispiel keine Krypto oder ich will keine zusätzlichen Sonderfeatures da drin haben, sondern dadurch wird halt der Overhead auch relativ klein. Ich hab damit also auch OpenVPN-Tunnel hingekriegt, die nur 8 Bits Overhead haben. Also plus natürlich IP drauf, also 28 Bits. Das finde ich schon ganz okay eigentlich, dass man da dran rumtunen kann. Wie gesagt, 200 Optionen, die aber ganz gut beschrieben sind. Man muss auch nicht alle anfassen, aber man kann. Du kannst halt eben auch so Sachen machen, wie noch Skripts hinterlegen, die automatisch gestartet werden, wenn sich so ein Tunnel verbindet, damit du halt zusätzlichen Quatscher noch machen kannst oder so. Wie gesagt, ist jetzt nichts genanlos Neues. Aber das aktuelle OpenVPN ist wirklich hochportabel, sehr flink, sehr schön und gut dokumentiert. Und da kann man mal Spaß haben. Also ist mal eine Empfehlung, sich das mal anzugucken.
Und die App ist auch free, sonst hätte sie keine Werbung eingeblendet, oder?
Ja, ist ja open source, kannst du selber kompilieren. Ach so, ja, die ist free. Für die GUI, da gibt es verschiedene Dinge. Es gibt da open source und kommerzielle GUI, für die Laptops, für Windows wird sogar eine mitgeliefert, die ist absolut minimal. Das heißt, du strickst dir deinen Config-File da selber mit irgendwie fünf Parametern drin und wirfst dir das vor und klickst dir nur noch drauf und dann tut es da irgendwie was. Gibt es aber auch schön mit Click und Bund und Parameter-Abfrage und so weiter. Ich habe hier zum Beispiel auf dem Mac mal so eine Bezahl ab, die aber relativ günstig war am Start, die nennt sich Viscosity. Genau. Und das finde ich sehr schön. Und wie gesagt, man kann damit basteln und das ist halt unprätentiös. Ich habe jahrelang auch immer sehr viel von diesem Ipsac gemacht oder machen müssen. Das ist halt immer so, ja und ich kann das nicht und da ist wieder ein Parameter und der stimmt nicht und la und so. Jeder, der schon mal ein bisschen mehr mit Ipsac gemacht hat, weiß, dass fucking Pain in the Ass ist. Und das OpenVPN tut einfach mal das, was im Manual steht. Allein das ist es schon wert, dass man sich mal anguckt. Ist schlimm genug, dass man das heutzutage über eine Software sagen muss, aber das ist so. Ich liebe Software mit großen Manuals, die einfach korrekt sind. Deswegen stehe ich auch immer noch Exim. Exim oder Postgres oder solche Sachen, die haben zwar ein großes Manual, aber da steht was drin und das stimmt. Man kann das einfach so machen, was da drin steht und das ist heutzutage echt nicht mehr üblich. Also gerade auch bei Routern, der Klassiker ist, wenn du so ein Cisco-Router auch aktuell nimmst, guckst du in das aktuelle Manual, da ist ein Beispiel drin, ein Beispiel-Config. Die nimmst du aus dem Online-Manual mit Copy und Paste und pastest sie in deinen Router rein. Und der sagt erst mal zu dem Beispiel Syntax-Error. Das heißt, die kriegen abwiesen dafür, dass es logisch schon kaputt ist. Aber es ist noch nicht mal syntaktisch korrekt. Und das finde ich halt einfach bitter. Tunnelblick wird hier auch erwähnt im Chat, hatte ich auch mal. Vor allem damals, als ich schon mal mit OpenVPN gespielt habe, könnte man jetzt noch mal machen, aber wie gesagt...
Ich habe gerade eine gute Alternative für Viscosity-Tunnelblick. Ist andersrum. Viscosity ist eine sehr gute Alternative für Tunnelblick. Tunnelblick auf dem Mac nehmen die meisten Leute, weil es erstmal gratis ist und so weiter. Aber das ist irgendwie nicht so...
Ein Punkt übrigens noch für immer, wenn ihr da schon mal drin rumlässt, befasst euch auch mal mit Layer 2 VPNs. Also mit virtuellen Ethernet-Kabeln. Das ist nämlich echt spaßig. Das ist einer der Punkte, wo ich überhaupt damit mal angefangen habe, weil ich nämlich mal ein Layer 2 VPN machen wollte, das ich auf WLANs transportiert habe. Also sozusagen ein virtuelles Ethernet-Kabel mit allem, was da drauf gehört. Wie gesagt, inklusive WLAN-Tagging usw. Und das kannst du bauen mit OpenVPN. Das ist also schon eine sehr lustige Sache. Ihr guckt so? Wofür will man das? Wofür braucht man das?
Virtuales Routing von allen möglichen, auch bei Audio, ist immer gut.
Ein Vorteil ist, wenn du Routing machst, musst du halt eben wirklich Routen machen. Das heißt, du musst neue Adressen, Adressbereiche generieren. Wenn du jetzt aber nur ein Laptop mit einem Heimnetz verbinden willst, ohne jetzt separat nochmal Adressen zu machen, dann kannst du auch einfach ein virtuelles Ethernet nehmen. Das hat halt den nebenbei den Folgen. Das erzeugt natürlich mehr Verkehr, als drüber sein müsste, weil du natürlich auch das ganze Multicast und Broadcast gesabbelhörst von den Leuten in deinem Heimnetz. Aber zum Beispiel diese ganze Apple-Spielreihen funktionieren dann immer noch. Du kannst dann auch aus der Entfernung auf deinem Laptop irgendwie iTunes starten und auf deinem... Das Bonjur? Ja, das ganze Bonjur, wie gesagt, das ist wie ein Ethernet-Kabel. Das heißt, alles, was zu Hause geht, geht auch unterwegs. Und kannst dann da Video streamen oder sonst irgendwas machen. Und du musst dich halt eben nicht um Adressvergabe kümmern, weil das macht dir dein Router, weil dir zu Hause sowieso schon mit DHCP ist, wie ein Ethernet. Also es ist schon sehr lustig. Kann man also mal damit spielen finden.
Die Password-Density ist zu hoch, die schonen sich schon. Die hast du nicht mit dem Schreiben hinterhergekommen.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt nur noch schnell reinstopfen hier in unsere Kurzsendung, bevor du die Tür zu machst. Bevor du zum Bahnhof musst.
Uns fehlt die halbe Stunde, die wir am Anfang verpassen.
Ansage an die Hörer, wir machen jetzt wieder ab 19.30 Uhr. Haben wir beschlossen, weiß Tim noch nichts davon.
Oder 19.45.
Weiß Tim noch nichts davon, aber...
Wird doch alles dann wieder nicht pünktlich und so.
Seitdem die Pizza um 19 Uhr da ist geht es.
Die Pizza war schon immer um 19 Uhr da.
Da hätten wir am liebsten schon angefangen, aber die Pizza war noch nicht da.
Die Pizza kommt deshalb unpünktlich, weil ich sie zu spät bestelle und ich bestelle sie zu spät, weil du dich immer erst eine Stunde vor der Sendung meldest, was du haben willst.
Weil du mal gesagt hast, bis 18 Uhr müssen die Bestellungen da sein.
Ja, spätestens.
Sag einfach 17 Uhr.
Schaffst du auch nicht immer.
Klar schaff ich das.
Aber wenn du 19.45 Uhr anfangen willst oder 19.30 Uhr, dann muss ich das natürlich ein bisschen entspannen.
Und zum Notbestellst du mir eine Dutchman und ein Eis und alles gut.
Keine Schulddiskussion.
Schreib doch mal einer eine Web ab.
Selbst Swift kann Default-Parameter her. Da wirst du das ja wohl auch hinkriegen.
Den ist generic.
Bin ich objektorientiert?
Bist du funktional oder was?
Ja, Multiple Pizza Inheritance.
Genau.
Ja, ich hab das mal so aufgeschrieben, weil es vielleicht ein bisschen egal. Also in Italien, in dem Haus, da gibt es auch einen Pizzaofen. Den kann man so mit Holz befeuern. Und dann kann man da Pizza drin machen. Und das ist zwar ein bisschen aufwendig, aber wenn man das richtig macht, ist das sehr lecker. Also mal abgesehen davon, dass man einfach genug Holz reinmachen muss, damit alles genug wird. Das ist der einfache Teil. Pizza-Teig. Ich wollte ein bisschen über Pizza-Teig reden.
Wir müssen mehr über Pizza-Teig.
Wir müssen mehr über Pizza-Teig reden. Und zwar gibt es da einen Blog, das heißt Plötz-Blog, von einem Typen, der irgendwie nur übers Brot backen schreibt. Und zwar nur. Der hat irgendwie Dutzende von Backet-Rezepten.
Und der kriegt es gebacken, ja?
Der kriegt es gebacken. Genau. Und zwar, was ich beim Hefeteig, eigentlich die wichtigste Zutat ist ja Geduld. Das hat man ja immer selten irgendwie. Man muss das Teil einfach früh genug ansetzen. Und ich hab den auch immer zu trocken gemacht. Also der wahre Tipp ist, der Teig muss feucht genug sein. Wenn er nicht an den Fingern klebt, dann ist er zu trocken. Und der muss halt mindestens irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Also wenn man die Zeit hat, dann sollte er schon vier, fünf Stunden gegangen sein.
Wieso wird er denn feuchter, umso länger er geht?
Nee, er wird einfach besser.
Also wie äußert sich das in der Konsistenz? Sehr klebriger? Also wird er nicht tendenziell immer trockener? Das ist das, was ich sagen will.
Nee, der wird nicht so schnell trocken. Also trocken wird er dadurch, dass man zu viel Mehl ranmacht für die Menge Wasser, die da drin ist. Also einerseits verklebt halt irgendwie das Gluten relativ gut dann. Und andererseits kann halt die Hefe richtig in diesen Teig reinwachsen. Und dadurch wird er so, dass du ihn halt in die Länge ziehen kannst, ohne dass er reißt. Also man sieht das ja immer irgendwie in so Videos, wo Leute irgendwie posen, dass man da so den Pizzateig so rumwerfen kann. Und dann wird er von alleine rund und...
Na, die machen das halt durch die Fliehkraft, dass ich den nach außen dehne.
Ja, das muss man dann schon gut im Griff haben.
Ich hab ein Knall und das Gummibrot.
Nee, das Ding ist, wenn der Teig richtig ist, dann kann man ihn halt auch ziehen. Und meine Beobachtung ist halt auch, man darf ihn nicht ausrollen, man muss ihn in die Länge ziehen. Es ist wirklich irgendwie, ich weiß nicht woran es liegt, aber wenn man den platt rollt, dann hat man hinterher einen Keks, wenn man ihn gebacken hat. Und wenn man ihn auseinander zieht, bleibt er luftig.
Na, weil durch das auseinanderziehen, Luft kann man...
Drinbleiben und nicht platzen. Wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung. Also als Pi mal Daumen mengen würde ich sagen, man nimmt so 500 Gramm Mehl, 300 Milliliter Wasser, eine Einheit Hefe, also sprich entweder ein Packung trockenen Hefe oder so einen Würfel. Manchmal auch einen halben Hefe-Würfel nehmen, das ist nicht so wichtig. Und dann geht's los. Achso, einen Teelöffel Salz, sonst schmeckt's nicht.
Und das pannst du einfach zusammen und dann schleuderst du es?
Genau, und da... Am besten, man macht einen Vorteil. Also man macht nur die Hefe und das Wasser zusammen und macht drei große Esslöffel Mehl rein. Und dann wird das so eine Suppe und die zieht dann erstmal für eine halbe Stunde bloppert so vor sich hin. Und dann macht man das restliche Mehl rein. Und dann braucht man die Bosch Küchenmaschine. Das ist auch so ein...
Brauchen die Italiener nicht?
Das ist... genau. Die gibt es irgendwie unter verschiedenen Bezeichnungen, aber es ist einfach nur die Bosch Küchenmaschine. Es gibt nur diese eine, die irgendwie alles tut und die total genial ist. Die kostet wenig Geld, aber sie kann auch richtig gut Teig kneten. Mum irgendwas heißt die.
Wo ist der Link?
Ich knete selber. Das funktioniert auch, macht Muckis in der Arme.
Wo ist Sach, wie heißt der Teil?
Gegen die Nerd-Verschwächlichung.
Also hier habe ich zum Beispiel eine. Das Ding ist, es gibt diese Maschine halt mit verschiedenen Anbauten und Zusatzteilen. Also es gibt den auch mit zum Schredder und du kannst irgendwie einen Fleischwolf ranmachen und eine Eismaschine und so weiter. Ich hätte mal diesen Link hier. bloghefe.de Ich hätte mal diesen Link hier von Amazon. Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt die halt in verschiedenen Verkaufsverpackungen mit unterschiedlichen Zahlen, je nachdem was dabei ist. Aber die, die ich da angeklickt habe, da ist halt eine Schüssel und ein Knethaken. Weißt du, für den Anfang, wenn du jetzt keine Möhren schnitzeln willst.
Für nur 199€.
Also es gibt auch von, ich glaube, der Tomster, der hat sich doch von, wie heißen diese Marke mit den grünen weißen Staubsaugern?
Vorwerk.
Ich glaube, die haben auch so eine Küchenmaschine und das ist wohl das Referenzmodell oder so.
Der Klassiker ist doch so eine uralte US-Maschine, wie heißt denn die? KitchenAid. Genau, das ist doch der Goldstandard.
In der alten Welt ist das der Goldstandard.
Amerikanische Sachen Goldstandard.
Seit wann ist die frisch?
Die KitchenAids, die kriegst du in Amiland, für 200 Dollar oder so. Da brauchst du natürlich einen Trafo, weil das Ding 110 Volt hat. Und hier geht es irgendwie ab 600 Euro los für irgendwie das gleiche Ding. Und die sind zwar gut, aber ob sie dann so viel Geld wert sind, naja, ich weiß nicht.
Die sind auf jeden Fall schwer. Die hoppelt nicht vorm Tisch beim Rühren.
Diese Vorwerkenmaschine, da gibt es eigene Kochbücher zu, weil die halt auch wirklich alles Mögliche macht, also da kannst du auch drin garen und also es nicht nur rühren. Genau, die ist wirklich...
Der Haushaltspodcast.
Die kostet allerdings auch einiges, aber...
Kannst du die mit dem iPhone ansteuern?
So wie die aussieht.
Na die macht halt auch wirklich mehr als andere Geräte.
Die kann Dampfgaren mixen, kochen, kneten, wiegen, hacken.
Das ist quasi so eine Küche in einem Gerät.
Dampfgaren finde ich jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich hab die auch noch nicht benutzt, aber ich kenne auch nur Leute, also alle Leute, die ich kenne, sind total beeindruckt und begeistert von diesem Gerät. Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Also ich finde diese Bosch gut, die sie jetzt glaube ich auch schon seit 20 Jahren mehr oder weniger unverändert bauen und die einfach tut und irgendwie alles macht, wenn man die entsprechenden Zubehörteile dran macht.
Die man alle extra kaufen muss, die zum Preis dann nochmal dazukommen.
Ja, es gibt halt verschiedene Bundles irgendwie auch. Aber es ist jetzt alles nicht so fürchterlich teuer.
Imulgieren, mischen, schlagen, rühren, kontrolliertes Erhitzen, Dampf garen, mixen, kochen, kneten, wiegen, hacken und mahlen.
Das ist halt voll nerd-kompatibel, weil da musst du wirklich nur die Sachen in die richtigen Behälter reinschütten und am Ende kommt Essen raus.
Ich warte bis der Replikator da ist und dann...
Achso, ein Kollege von mir hat sich das gekauft. Und dann dachte ich auch so, wovon sprichst du? Dann hab ich mir das da rein gefahren, weil er meinte auch, meine Kochprobleme sind jetzt gelöst. Der ist halt auch so nerd-mäßig unterwegs und der hat voll davon geschwärmt, dass er jetzt endlich mit dem Kochen und so alles im Griff hat.
Zu dem Pizzateig noch eine kleine Sache. Und zwar, wenn man wirklich einen guten Teig machen will, schaut euch unter PlötzBlock nochmal an, was Teigfalten ist. Ich hab's nicht geglaubt, aber es bringt tatsächlich was.
So wie beim Dalmatiner Schwert oder Klinge oder Stahl oder wie auch immer.
Und man braucht keine Maschine, man kann es auch mit der Hand machen. Die hab ich auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Mein Nudelteig und mein Pizzateig ist original muckig geknetet.
Naja, Nudelteig würde ich auch nicht in so eine Maschine tun. Weil ich glaube, eine Maschine, die Nudelteig knetet, das gibt es glaube ich nicht für den Haushaltssektor.
Ja, kann sein.
Da ruinierst du dir glaube ich alles, es sei denn du hast die Schlagbohrmaschine am Start.
Wieso? Weil der so kompakt ist?
Ja.
Aber dann ist ja sogar Pizza-Teig noch einzeln.
Pizza-Teig ist okay, so ein Hefe-Teig das passt schon.
Das stimmt, der Hartweizen-Gries bei den Nudeln.
Weil du beim Nudelteig tust halt so viel Ei rein und relativ wenig Wasser und dann wird es halt... Bombeige Pampe, naja nicht mal Pampe, aber halt so ein...
So, haben wir noch Themen jetzt hier?
Nee.
Wie? Da war noch ein IPv6, das ist bestimmt kurz oder nicht?
Ich hab schon alles nach unten verschoben, wozu ich keine Lust mehr habe, darüber zu reden.
Aber der IPv6 sagt, das geht doch schnell oder nicht? Echt nicht?
Tim will raus.
Dann muss ich erst mal drüber abbrannten.
Ich will raus. Jetzt darf Uncle noch entscheiden, ob er noch sein Thema von vorletztem Mal bringen will oder nicht.
Welches war das?
Das ist alles alt.
Das ist alles alt, kann raus, kann gelöscht werden. Interessiert kein Saubruder mehr.
Nur noch Clemensen-Option. Kannst ja auch aufheben.
Ich bin jetzt auch zu friedlich. Ich muss da ein bisschen frischer sein, um mich da nochmal ordentlich aufzuregen.
Um den Morgenstern nochmal mit voller Dynamik anzuschminken.
Ja, und überhaupt.
Deine Webseite geht ja wieder, Tim.
Zwischendurch manchmal.
Zwischendurch mal. Da ist irgendwie die Hölle los. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo die Lot herkommt. Ich kann das alles nicht messen.
Hast du jetzt wieder das BSD auf der F1 oder was?
Nee, das ist ja sein Jail dabei. Aber die Diagnosen nicht leichter macht. Vielleicht befragst du mal deinen Provider, die mal für dich draufgucken, was das Ding macht. Weil du kannst halt nicht alles in so einem Jail sehen. Also das erste, was ich machen würde, wenn das meine Maschine wäre, ist, ich würde mal gucken, was da an Netzverkehr von draußen kommt. Das kannst du aber nicht im Jail.
Ich weiß.
Deswegen musst du mal deinen Provider fragen, ob die da mal raus mit dem Album oder nicht.
Ja, ich müsste mal umziehen, ich müsste mir mal eine Strategie machen, was ich irgendwie auf einem Rechner mache und was ich nicht auf einem Rechner mache, was ich mit einer 4M mache und so weiter, wie ich das am besten mache. Tja, Huckel, musst du mal hier die Beratung machen.
Der muss doch irgendwo wohnen, dieser richtig geile Server.
Ja, das kriegt man wohl geregelt.
Es gibt Leute, die dir das anbeten, ja.
Habe ich so mit voll gehört.
Ich sammle ja gerade Daten irgendwie über die Auslastung und so weiter. Und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, was da das Ergebnis von ist. Wenn ich mich immer nur um Systemadministrationen kümmere, kann ich mich um die ganzen anderen Sachen nicht kümmern.
Du könntest zum Beispiel mal wieder Podcasts machen.
Zum Beispiel. Naja, diese Woche habe ich ja schon einiges gemacht.
Und das ist gerade mal Mittwoch.
Ja, das ist gerade mal Mittwoch, schon die dritte Sendung.
Fast wieder wie bei der WM-Nit die Torquote.
Ganz produktiv hier so.
Durchschnitt 3 Tore, aber wir waren vorhin schon drüber. Die Tore ziehen gerade runter.
Die spielen nämlich 0-0.
Ja, aber die fallen dafür. Dafür sind schon 3 irgendwie mit dem Schalke rausgetragen worden.
Und bei den Schweizer sind 3 Tore.
Ist jetzt auch gleich Schluss hier, war?
War eigentlich bei den anderen. Das ist irgendwie mit 9 Toren ausgegangen. Jetzt liegt da noch der... Drei zu zwei und... 3-1.
Das ist aber 0-3 und 0-0.
0-3 und 0-0. Aber das sind immerhin 4 Spiele mit 12 Toren.
Will jemand morgen beim Firmenfußball gucken, im Pavillon im Volkspark Friedrichshain noch, auf Wugars kosten Bratwurst und Bier konsumieren, in rauen Mengen?
Ich werde nicht kommen können, aber du kannst ja alle einladen.
Ich hab nur 1 plus 1.
Ja, ich leider auch nicht. Gut, also sieht aus, als ob, während wir gesprochen haben, Frankreich und Spanien in die nächste Runde eingezogen sind.
Spanien?
Spanien sind schon raus. Hab ich Spanien gesagt? Schweiz wollte ich sagen. Das andere ist Spanien.
Wenn du ein Amerikaner wärst, würdest du das auch noch für richtig halten.
Schweiz oder Spanien, Hauptsache Mailand.
Ja, 3-0 und so. Das ist doch schon ganz gut. Viel Spaß bei der WM. Wir haben übrigens extra den nächsten Freak Show-Termin WM-kompatibel gelegt. Ich möchte das hoch angerechnet bekommen. Wir werden also nicht an einem Mittwoch, sondern einen Montag.
Also auf gut Deutsch, ihr sollt dankbar sein, dass Tim das Halbfinale gucken möchte.
Genau, dass ich das Halbfinale auch sehen will.
Aber jetzt, wo er das Update freigegeben hat, sind die Hörer eh friedlich gestimmt.
Und vor allem beschäftigt die nächsten zwei Wochen.
Da geht jetzt gleich nach der Sendung nochmal das Konzept von Podcasts und was einer der großen Vorteile ist von Podcasts.
Akamai kann sich schonmal warm anziehen.
Da geht was. Na gut, ich denke wir können jetzt hier mal langsam die Kiemen einklappen. Vor allem eigentlich sehr sportlich heute, oder? Da ging was, auf jeden Fall.
Nicht mal vier Stunden die Sendung.
Genau, in zwölf Tagen ziehen wir wieder durch.
Ich nicht, ich will tanzen.
Und Clemens ist tanzen.